Liebe Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger, dies sind nur ganz wenige Ausschnitte aus dem zurückliegenden Jahr.
Okay, wenn wir das Kalenderthema noch mal kurz aufgreifen, das ist ja durchaus ein als spannendes Feld. Es gibt noch eine Software im App Store und Zeit auf jeden Fall erstmal als kontinuierlichen Strahl darstellt und zwar horizontal. Ich persönlich bin nicht so sehr ein Freund von horizontal, ich bin mehr so wett.
Heute nun können sie darauf vertrauen, dass ich alles daran setze, Kalender-Apps zu stärken. Gelingen aber wird das nur, wenn Europa Lehren aus Fehlern der Vergangenheit zieht. Ab Februar können sie im Internet mitdiskutieren und Vorschläge einbringen. Ich lade sie alle ein, machen sie mit.
Was mir hier aufgefallen ist bei BusyKal, sie blenden die automatisch Sonnenaufgang und Sonnenuntergang ein.
Dafür bin ich dankbar. Darauf baue ich auch in Zukunft. Ich wünsche ihnen und ihren Familien ein frohes, gesundes und gesegnetes neues Jahr 2012.
Herzlich willkommen bei Bumzack Return.
Da sind wir wieder. Eure sieben Zwerge. Wer waren wir noch gleich? Eure...
Dreifaltigkeit heute in dem Fall.
Ja, eure Dreifaltigkeit, das Hochamt, wie wir uns auf Twitter mitgeteilt wurden.
Das Hochamt?
Ja. Das sind wir. Wir sind das Hochamt.
Ist das eine Beleidigung oder ist das nett gemeint?
Das ist ein guter Witz, würde ich sagen. Ja, da wurde jemand, wie sagt man so schön, ins Boxhorn gejagt. Das ist von Zeit zu Zeit auch nötig, Leute ins Boxhorn zu jagen. Ich denke, dieses Jahr wird sich da auch so einiges ergeben. Wie auch immer, hier ist MOBA Max, Ausgabe Nummer 79.
Ist es Zufall, dass du hier so eine Illuminaten-T-Shirt an hast?
Nein. Das ist ein Hypnose-T-Shirt. Ich setze mich mit diesem T-Shirt hin. Ich habe gerade eben erstmal ein Pullover ausgezogen, damit du unvorbereitet drauf stößt. Und jetzt, wo du schon schwer atmest, zeigt sich, dass es auch wirkt.
Denis ist schon krank?
Denis ist schon krank und Max ist quasi paralysiert. Wenn ich hier zu meiner Best-of-2011 anschwinge, dass du mir da einfach nicht in die Parade fährst. Dachte ich mir so.
Ja, dann mach mal. Viel Spaß.
Jetzt hast du auch viel zu früh verraten, dass Denis gar nicht da ist. Jetzt droppt hier schon das Hörer-Meter gleich. The Voice ist nicht dabei. Ist Denis The Voice?
Mach mal dein Mikrofönchen ein bisschen mehr an deinen...
Hallo. Hallo.
Ich glaube, wir sind einfach ein bisschen leiser als du mal wieder.
Ja, ich...
Ich weiß, dass du das nicht... Ich weiß, dass du...
Du meinst... Warte mal. Kleiner Test.
Guten Tag.
Nichts falsch machen.
Test 1, 2, 3.
Jetzt bin ich weg.
Jetzt noch mal.
Immer noch. Weg.
Jetzt sind wir leise.
Ich bin... Ich bin... Ich hör mich gar nicht.
Ich hör mich auch gar nicht.
Ja, ihr seht, auch in 2012 hat sich am generellen Vorgang nichts geändert.
Jetzt. So.
Auch... Oh, jetzt haben wir wieder lustige Stimmen. Das ist kein Klavier-Tim. Du fähst gerade episch live.
Ja.
Hört man uns überhaupt? Ja, sehr leise.
Chet, könnt ihr uns hören, wenn wir brühen?
Tim hat jetzt zwischen den Tagen das Studio total umgebaut. Ich frag mich nur gerade, warum. Damit das mit der Technik endlich mal gut funktioniert.
Er meint, wir...
Jetzt war ich kurz da.
Ja, so ein bisschen besser.
Hättest du vielleicht doch nicht auf Windows 7 umstellen sollen?
Ich fang jetzt gar nicht an. Ja, don't get me started.
Immer noch kein neues Mischpult.
Na, wozu auch? Das Mischpult ist super. Das ist nicht das Problem. Also...
Ich bin leise immer noch, aber jetzt hab ich das Mikro doch schon fast auf der Zunge.
Was meinst du mit du bist leise? Du bist für dich leise.
Nee, ich bin okay super. Also eben Kopfhörer ist super.
Aber?
Die da, die Huckel ist zu leise.
Ist ust zu leise.
Huckel kaum zu hören.
Huckel zu leise.
Huckel kaum zu hören. Fast alle außer Tim zu leise, dann bleibt nicht mehr.
Huckel mein, das ist der Punkt.
Insbesondere Denis ist viel zu leise. Der brüllt hier die ganze Zeit, aber man hört ihn gar nicht.
Also wir hören, das was du hörst auf dem Kopfhörer, ist das, was alle hören. Also von daher ist einfach unterschiedliche lautstärke Wahrnehmung an der Stelle bestenfalls subjektiv.
Tim ist niemals lauter als wir. Das ist reine Einbildung.
Aber der Chat gibt sich ja hartnäckig.
Das ist so eine akustische Täuschung. Wie so eine optische Täuschung denkt man immer, dass Tim lauter wäre als wir.
Ja, ich mach mal für den Chat immer den Booster an, dann äh...
Und jetzt fliegen sie alle von den Tischen.
Ja, das hab ich den Booster angemacht. Jetzt ist es richtig scheiße laut. Siehst du mal, Sound war gut, jetzt ist er scheiße. Siehst du mal, man kann einfach mit dem Internet keinen Konsens erzählen. Ich schau dir das an. Die Hälfte schreit besser und die andere Hälfte schreit furchtbar.
Nee, bisher hat einer... Wer hat das ja furchtbar geschrieben?
Der überwiegende Teil ist schon begeistert, muss man sagen.
Ja, ich mein, dafür hab ich ja den Finalizer. Ich hab den bloß mal rausgenommen, weil ich halt neulich hab ich halt durch einen Fehler einer Aufnahme bin ich auf das Backup gegangen, das war bei NSFW und wenn da Musik drin ist und man laut ist und so weiter, dann hat das Ding einfach furchtbar überrissen. Wenn wir jetzt hier so galant vor uns hinreden, ist das irgendwie alles super, dann macht das Ding genau das Richtige. Aber das ist alles auf der Liste und andere Dinge. Ja, ich meine, es ist ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass hier kein Fortschritt festzustellen wäre in der Metaimera. Hat sich jetzt vielleicht nicht so unmittelbar auf Mobamex ausgewirkt. Aber ihr werdet sicherlich festgestellt haben, dass ich so über Weihnachten das ein oder andere getan habe.
Ja, aufgeräumt. Zum Beispiel.
Hier im Studio? Ja, und gebaut und neue Stühle gekauft.
Ja, wir sitzen jetzt sehr wohlgepolstert.
Ja, es gibt einen neuen Computer. Da können wir auch gleich mal drüber reden hier.
Naja, erstmal reden wir ja natürlich über die große Auflösung.
Ja, das stimmt. Die große Auflösung.
Welche große Auflösung?
Von dem tollen Wetzel.
Ach so, die Auflösung.
Ich dachte, die hätte sich irgendwas aufgelöst.
Tim hat es wirklich geschafft, die ganze Zeit tapfer durchzuhalten. Es ist keine Information nach draußen gesickert. Und jetzt sind wir alle sehr gespannt.
Und die machen halt immer noch, du wärst leise. Stimmt aber auch.
Ach, aber mein Kopfhörer, der ist wiederum laut.
Sollte das Internet etwa Recht haben.
Schneidest du eigentlich den Teil dann aus der Sendung wieder veröffentlicht wieder raus?
Mit dem ganzen Live-Scheiß langweilen wir dann unsere Podcast-Führer.
Die können vorspulen.
Die müssen ja auch nicht dafür bezahlen, immerhin, ne?
Genau, die können vorspulen. Die anderen müssen auch nicht dafür bezahlen.
Naja, bei Bits und so, da muss man doch das...
Ist doch egal, was andere machen. Andere Podcasts, andere Welten, andere Realitäten.
Andere Rituale.
Aber passiert das wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Da läuft es wie geschmiert.
Da läuft es wie geschmiert. Ja, das ist halt hier so ein... Eins nach dem anderen. Ich musste erstmal einen neuen Computer... Den Move musste ich jetzt erstmal machen. Den habe ich gemacht. Da kommen wir dann auch gleich nochmal zu. Aber als erstes kommen wir...
Zu großen Auflösungen.
Kommen wir zu großen Auflösungen.
Und Max, hast du das in der Zwischenzeit rausbekommen?
Das Thema hast du uns ja auch nicht verraten.
Ja, du musst uns auch nicht verraten.
Aber ich habe erstaunt, ich habe ja so einen Make-Up-Buch.
Ihr wisst es ja auch nicht. Aber du hast trotzdem meinen Make-Up-Buch. Das hättest du gewonnen. Na gut, also wer die letzte Sendung aus fragwürdigen Gründen vielleicht aber nicht gehört hat, dem erzählen wir jetzt mal, worum es eigentlich geht. Es ergab sich kurz vor Weihnachten in unserer Sendung vom...
Irgendwann?
12.
oder 13. Dezember, dass ich just kurz vorher einen Make-Up-Bot zum Verlosen bekam. Also es war nicht meiner oder so, sondern mir wurde der quasi hier zum Verschabeln freigestellt.
Eigentlich bist du nicht Bundespräsident da.
Dann hättest du ihn auch automatisch gewonnen, oder was?
Nee, dann gibts jetzt hier gleich mal Anprangungen für Schenkungen.
Na die soll mal kommen, den plattere ich auf den AB.
Ist doch eher umgekehrt fürs Geschenk kriegen, oder?
Wie auch immer.
Auf jeden Fall fand ich das im Nachgang ganz cool, wie wir dann hier doch binnen von 20 Minuten dieses Rätsel zusammengebaut haben. Und jetzt wollen wir uns mal hier an die 6 Fragen heranwerfen. Ich weiß nicht, gibt es noch dieses Pad, wo die Leute aus dem Chat gemeinsam gerätselt haben? Können die Chat uns noch mal sagen, ob es dieses Pirate-Pad noch gibt? Jetzt beklagen sie sich darüber, dass ich dröhne.
Das machen sie aber immer.
Du dröhntst ja doch.
Hier ist der Link, das ist nämlich ganz lustig, weil da kann man nämlich so einige Dinge ganz gut sehen, wie sich so manche so verrannt haben. Das war super, euch dazu zu gucken. Das hat sich auch in manchen E-Mails wiedergespiegelt. Ups, jetzt hat's natürlich gleich einer gelöscht. Ganz klug irgendwie. Super, echt geil. Du bist total cooler Troll. Du klappst auch besser mit dem Sex, Mann.
Ich glaub, der drückt gerade massenhaft immer auf Save. Und speichert Revisionen ab.
Gut, egal. Ich erzähl einfach mal, während du da klickst. Also wir haben da diese Fragen zusammenkompiliert. Und die Lösungen wurden halt auch zusammenkompiliert in so einem Pratenbrett. Wir haben hier nach der Sendung auch live oder schon während der Sendung live zugeschaut, wie da diverse Finten erst mal ausgewalzt wurden, bis man festgestellt hat, dass es nicht die richtige Lösung ist. Und dann stand es auch schon teilweise eigentlich fast da, bis dann aber doch wieder Fear, Uncertainty and Doubt die Gemeinde erfasste. Und dann wieder völlig falsch abgebogen wurde. Genau. Und...
Ach schade, jetzt hat noch jemand hier irgendwo eine Vision, die noch funktioniert und kann die uns mal zuschicken hier. Und dann war ja so lustig, was da so als Alternative drin stand.
Ist erstmal egal. Und dann war es ja so, dass während wir noch hier im Studio abgebaut haben, kamen wir dann tatsächlich auch die erste Mail mit der Lösung rein. Also es waren ja auch schon ein paar Mails da, die alle falsch waren, und dann kam aber auch gleich schon der Gewinner durch.
Also ich glaube, es hat 15 Minuten nach Ende der Sendung kam es rein. Was ich eine gute Leistung fand. Weil es waren doch schon ein paar Hürden zu nehmen. Kommen wir doch vielleicht mal zu den Fragen. Die erste Frage hieß, wie hieß der erste Webbrowser von Apple? Und natürlich gab es hier eine Menge Leute, die dann gleich so, na, hier Safari und so. Aber das kann man sich natürlich an einer Hand abzählen, dass das kaum unsere Frage gewesen wäre, wäre Safari tatsächlich der erste und letzte Webbrowser gewesen?
Da stand erstaunlich oft stand da Netscape und Mosaik.
Ja, da frag ich mich auch, wie man zu so einer...
Ja, Mosaik war vielleicht der erste Browser, den es auch auf dem Mac gab, aber nicht von Apple.
Ja, ich denke mal sowas, oder dass man dachte, dass was installiert war oder so, kam der Mac mal mit Netscape Navigator installiert? Nee, kam er nie. Nur Internet Explorer war der einzig gebandelte Browser.
Doch, doch, die haben eine Zeit lang auch mitgeliefert, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, es gab früher auf der CD, war da irgendwie auch sowas bei.
Ja, da hat noch jemand ein PDF-Dokument gerade bereitgestellt, netterweise.
Auf welcher CD?
Nee, irgendwie. Mir ist so, als wäre, als sie ihre Internet-Multimedia-Phase hatten, dass sie dann auch irgendwo den Internet, aber ich weiß es nicht genau.
Die haben Internet Explorer mitgeliefert und Netscape war auch dabei. Das war... Ja, aber wollen wir sagen, was wir machen wollten?
Also es macht jetzt... Dieses PDF ist ganz lustig, dass das jetzt hier so... Das zeigt aber nicht diese ganze Verpeilung. Also lustig wäre es jetzt gewesen, durch diese Timeline hier durchzugehen. Ich lasse das jetzt erstmal weg. Wie auch immer. So, der erste Webbrowser von Apple hieß CyberDog. CyberDog war... Ich mochte CyberDog. Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch ging. Ich mochte das, ich fand das total toll. Vor allem fand ich etwas toll.
Was findest du daran toll?
Na also, wir müssen mal kurz überlegen, was damals so die Realität war. Das war Mac OS 7.5.
Also es war OpenDog, ja, irgendwie. Der war ja OpenDog-basiert.
Jaja, das waren noch so die Zeiten, wo sie mit OpenDog irgendwie rumgespielt haben. OpenDog, muss man nochmal kurz erläutern, war einer von mehreren vollkommen in die falsche Richtung weisenden Versuche von Apple, irgendwie der Zukunft näher zu kommen. Damals eine Kooperation mit IBM, die ja auch so in diesem objektorientierten GUI-Kram mit OS2 rumwilderten und irgendwie fanden Apple und IBM damals viel Gefallen aneinander. Da gab es ja auch PowerPC als Kooperation und software-technisch versuchten sie dann auch irgendwie was auf die Reihe zu bekommen. Aber so dieses ein Teil der Software wird von IBM entwickelt, ein Teil der Software wird von Apple entwickelt. Das war so einer der Holzwege, auf dem sich Apple damals einfach befand und der dann einfach zwangsläufig in den Abgrund führte. Wozu auch? Naja, weil damals es ging um modulare Softwareentwicklung. Das Ziel kleiner Ups, das war damals schon absehbar oder die Realität. Es war sehr aufwendig, Programme zu schreiben. Und jetzt kann man natürlich über viele Maßnahmen nachdenken, wie es einfacher wird, Programme zu schreiben. Einer dieser Glaubenskriege tobte sich dann halt sehr, um dieses ganze Objekt orientierte, verarben, Komponenten-Software, das war so Buzz. Das haben ja auch viele später auch nochmal durchexerziert. Auch bei Java gibt es ja ähnliche Konzepte. Man kann nicht wirklich sagen, dass sich das durchgesetzt hat. Auch Microsoft hat ja hier mit OLE und ähnlichen Sachen auch eben versucht, so modulare Softwareentwicklungen zu machen. Aber die Dependencies kriegte man damit eben auch nicht weg. Dann gab es aber zumindest mal ein Open-Doc-1.0-Release. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht mehr sicher, ob das ein Dameco S75 oder S65.
Die erste Beta von CyberDoc kam für S751 raus.
Da lag er nicht ganz falsch. CyberDoc war halt einer dieser Komponenten. Vielleicht ist es etwas vermessen, von einem vollwertigen Programm zu sprechen, so wie man das heute so kennt, so ein Stand-alone-Ding. Aber es gab da so ein Hund, das war dieses nette Logo, mit dem Hund, mit dem Astronauten-Glaskugel so auf dem Kopf, der irgendwie einen Raketen-Rucksack aufhatte und der flog halt irgendwie ins All. Und das war CyberDoc. Cyber war ja damals noch so, für das Internet, so auch ein ganz populäres Präfix. Und ich mochte CyberDoc, weil er nämlich im Vergleich zu Netscape Navigator einfach schnell war. Er war schnell und er war vor allem extrem light-white. Und was mir persönlich am besten gefiel war, dass wenn ich irgendwie so eine CyberDoc, wenn ich CyberDoc eine URL eingegeben habe, dass das Fenster, um diese URL einzugeben, so groß war, wie ein Fenster sein muss, um eine URL einzugeben, aber nicht 90% des Bildschirms mit einer weißen Fläche zukleisterte oder damals eher noch grau, so wie das eben der Netscape Navigator machte. Ich muss zugeben, das hat sich durchgesetzt. Man macht das immer noch so. Es hat sich einfach etabliert, dass, wenn man noch nichts sieht, dass man dann auf ein weißes Blatt schauen muss. Okay, meinetwegen. Damals war das Spiel noch offen. Ich fand's irgendwie cool, dass er erst die URL aufgelöst hat und dann in Abhängigkeit davon, was da kam, entschieden hat, ob es eine Webseite anzuzeigen gilt, weil es hätte ja auch einfach ein normaler FTP-Download sein können. Eine URL, die einfach auf irgendeinen File zugreift. Heute ist es so, wenn nur ein Download-File, also wenn da etwas von dem Webserver oder von was auch immer in dem Moment mit der URL adressierten Entität zurückgeliefert wird und es handelt sich um ein Download, dann bleibt die Seite weiß und stattdessen, ja jetzt beim Safari springt dann irgendwie rechts oben was in so einem Icon, woanders geht dann noch ein anderes Fenster auf oder im schlimmsten Fall siehst du es halt gar nicht, ja, irgendwas wurde dann so runtergeladen innerhalb von ein paar Bruchteilen von Sekunden, du starrst nach wie vor auf deine weiße Seite. Also ich finde das von der User Experience eigentlich immer noch scheiße. Und bei Sabadoc war es einfach so, du gabst die URL ein, zack, return und wenn da halt der Download lief, dann hattest du da einfach nur den Progress Bar. Also du hattest die URL und darunter den Progress Bar, mich recht ins Sinne und wenn ich mich noch rechter ins Sinne war dann danach das Fenster, auch das Dokument. Nee, so war es nicht. Das ist wirklich lange her. Aber es war vor allem im Vergleich zu dem sonstigen statischen langsamen Scheiß, mit dem man so leben musste, insbesondere im Netzgebenden-Havigator. Damals eine Software, das muss man sich mal vorstellen, die die Seite neu geladen hat, wenn man die Fenstergröße verändert hat. Also du schiebst, machst rechts unten, fasst du dieses Fenster an, machst es etwas enger und dann lädt er die Seite neu. Das muss man sich einfach mal vorstellen.
Was erlaube Netzgebend.
Was erlaube Netzgebend. Und da war einfach CyberDoc eine Verheißung. War. War.
Aber CyberDoc war, also ich weiß noch, als ich CyberDoc das erstmal benutzt hatte, war es schon ein komplett veralteter Browser und ich glaube, in dem Moment, in dem es rauskam, war es ein komplett veralteter Browser.
Wer meinte, das war ein komplett veralteter Browser? Die konnten alle nix.
Na ja, aber er konnte nicht mal das, was Netzgebend 2 konnte oder sowas.
Der konnte nicht mal das Blinktag.
Ich weiß nicht, Frames oder so.
Das fand ich auch geil, dass er keine Frames konnte. Ja, Frames waren einfach The Fail. Ich meine, Frames haben uns wahrscheinlich, das hat uns um Jahre zurückgeworfen. Gott sei Dank, ich meine, endlich. Wann hast du das letzte Mal eine Webseite, das einzige Mal, wo es noch Frames gibt, ist wenn du irgendwie so Google Search machst oder so. Da mag das sogar noch Sinnvoll sein.
Das ist ja auch für API-Dokumentationen, wo du links immer deine Methoden brauchst und rechts ist auch alles mit Frames meistens.
Stimmt, diese ganzen Ruby-Docs und so was, die sind auch alle...
Alte Sachen, ja.
Nee, die sind hochmoderne Seiten sogar, weil die benutzen trotzdem sehr. Und es ist jetzt nicht total... Also ehrlich gesagt weiß ich nicht mehr, ob es immer noch Frames sind, aber es ist jetzt nicht... Also man sieht es schon...
Es sieht aus wie Frames oder es sind Frames?
Es sind ziemlich sicher Frames.
Das Problem mit Frames ist halt leicht zusammengefasst. Du hast es nicht mehr mit einer URL zu tun.
Ja, ja, ja, wir kennen alle Frames. Also wer sie nicht mehr kennt, sei froh, dass er sie nicht mehr kennt. Aber es war damals die beste Technologie für einen besonderen Anwendungsfonds.
Für geschnitten Brot. Egal. Sie wurden zu 99% fehl benutzt.
Das kann man durchaus so sehen, ohne jede Frage, aber es war damals notwendig, dass man, wenn man im Web surfen wollte, braucht man Frames und CyberDoc konnte glaube ich keine Frames. Ich weiß aber nicht. Er konnte hoffentlich auch andere Zeug auch nicht.
Egal. Frage Nummer eins.
Das war CyberDoc halt.
So viel kann man dazu sagen. Also die Antwort wäre gewesen, CyberDoc und die Buchstaben wären Y und Cyber und ein Y und ein E. Ich blicke hier gerade auf dieses Public Pet. Das ist wirklich ein interessanter... Also dieses...
Da gibt es übrigens auch... Klick oben auf einfach Timeslider. Da kann man sich die alten Versionen alle angucken. Das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Ja, aber wenn jemand gerade die ganze Zeit save, dann ist das ein Problem irgendwie.
Ja, ja, das dauert ein bisschen.
Das sagt mir aber schon, dass wir mal hier ein eigenes Pet aufmachen, dass man da auch mal ordentliche User-Accounts vergeben kann, dass sie dann zum Penner wegfallen. Echt im Kette, live.
Du bist einfach ein Mensch, der gerne auf Diskettensymbole klickt.
Ja, das ist einfach ein fucking Troll.
Das Diskettensymbole ist ein Diskettensymbole.
Na, egal. So, kommen wir zum nächsten Streitpunkt. Wie lautet der ursprüngliche Projektname von Mac OS 8? Tja, was gab es da so für, da gab es auch so verschiedene, aber das war glaube ich, das haben glaube ich viele irgendwie hinbekommen. Oder?
Na ja, da gab es auch erstmal so ein paar fehlgeleitete Versuche.
Tempo, genau, zum Beispiel. Ah ja, genau, Tempo. Genau, die eigentliche Konfusion war, dass Mac OS 8 irgendwann mal The Next Generation Mac OS war. Das war quasi der verkündete, die verkündete Version, die es dann mal werden würde, während man sich eben noch bei System 7 oder Mac OS 7, je nachdem, wie man das nennen möchte, befand. Wie hab ich den Satz angefangen? Ich weiß nicht mehr. Ich bin auch schon wieder ein bisschen angeschlagen. Wie auch immer. Dann kam ja, dann wurde ja so der Niedergang eingeleitet und unter anderem haben sie dann irgendwann dieses...
Bei 7.5 war schon der Niedergang.
Bitte?
Bei 7.5 war er schon, also da war er schon voll ausgeprägt.
Ja gut, aber noch eine Weile bestand ja dieses Projekt, dieses Next Generation OS. So, jetzt sagen wir den Namen. Der Projektname war Copland. Copland. Das, was später als Mac OS 8 rauskam, war halt nichts anderes als ein Mac OS 7.8.9, was aus Marketinggründen halt 8 hieß. Aber das war halt nicht das eigentliche Mac OS 8 und der damit verbundene Projektname war Copland. Und das ist das, was wir hier eigentlich bei Frage 2 wissen wollten, um zwei weitere Buchstaben zu erhalten, nämlich LA, Y, E, LA. Ja, Copland. Ja, Copland war eigentlich auch ein totaler Fail damals.
Das eigentliche Copland.
Ja, weil schon das Mac OS 8, also sie haben, muss man mal kurz nachdenken, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, eins von den beiden fehlten, ich glaube, Multitasking hatten sie quasi drin. Das war ihnen dann schon klar geworden, dass man also mal Multitasking braucht, so richtige, mehr so.
Und Speicherschutz.
Speicherschutz haben sie nicht.
Die wollten ja kompatibel sein. Und dann war der Speicherschutz irgendwie nicht machbar.
Das war einfach in die falsche Richtung gedacht. Sie haben halt viel mehr in Richtung Open-Doc-Komponenten-Fu und so weiter. Und den Rückwärtskompatibilität. Wahrscheinlich auch. Also was auch immer sie gedacht haben, es war einfach klar, dass es das nicht ist. Ich hab damals ein bisschen vorm Rechner gesessen und geweint, weil ich irgendwie neben Anstalt so ein PC und es war irgendwie Windows NT drauf. Und ich meine, man kann jetzt über Windows NT sagen, was man will.
Das konnte Multitasking.
Ja, es konnte halt, es hatte halt einfach mal eine ordentliche Memory-Protection, weil sie halt da einen ordentlichen Kern eingebaut haben. Damals hat sich ja Microsoft den Kernel-Developer geschnappt, der seinerzeit für die... Oh Gott, die Zeiten sind alle so alt. Der von Deck kam, glaube ich. War das nicht dieser... Krieg ich jetzt fast durcheinander. War das dieser Typ, der auch irgendwie FaxOS gemacht hat? Ich weiß es nicht mehr ganz genau. Auf jeden Fall Experten hatten sie am Start. Und das mit dem Speicherschutz und mit dem Virtual Memories haben sie irgendwie auch verstanden. Und das war da halt einfach drin. Und es war halt einfach absehbar, dass es irgendwie auf dem Mac einfach noch Jahre dauern würde, bis man diesen Schmutz los wird. Und es ging einfach überhaupt nicht. Und das war... Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch ging, aber für mich war das schon damals alles unerträglich. Weil ich hatte das schon auf meinem PC mit Unix bald seit... Ende der 80er Jahre. War das einfach normal, dass man getrennte Prozesse hat und Virtual Memories.
Wo ich das das erste Mal kapiert habe, das war, als ich an irgendeiner Unix-Kiste saß mit einem Motiv drauf oder sowas. Und da war auch ein Browser offen. Und das war... Das werde ich nie vergessen. Wenn man einen Maus-Cursor nahm und zum Beispiel aus dem Terminal rüberzog, also das Netzgelbfenster hing gerade, weil Netzgelb ja gerne mal hing. Und wenn du die Maus genommen hast und diesen Watch-Cursor und bist auf das Terminal-Fenster, in dem Moment, in dem du das Netzgelbfenster verlassen hast, war das ein normaler Cursor. Du konntest weitermachen, als ob nichts war. Und das war vom Mac halt so dieses, wenn er hing, dann hing er. Und das war so dieses Maus zurück, wieder Uhr.
Genau, bei Mac wurde einfach die Uhr nie los. Ja, genau so ein Test. Das war nämlich, als ich die allererste Developer-Version von Repzody installierte. Also die erste Inkarnation. Da weiß ich noch, wie ich so mit voller Angst irgendwie in diesem Installer-Fenster herummauste und dann so einen ähnlichen Effekt auch hatte. Da war dann auch irgendwie wieder so Gummirehtchen und so weiter. Aber es war klar, du konntest irgendwie immer noch alle Fenster verschieben, nichts ruckelte und so. Und dann wusste ich so, oh Gott, schwitze, haben's irgendwie mitgekriegt. Aber es sollte einfach eeeewig dauern.
Gut, also Copland. Ruhstabe 4 und 5.
So.
LA.
Das nächste?
War das Root-Passwort.
Genau.
Von iPhone. Und da gab's ein bisschen Konfusion. Die richtige Antwort lautet Alpine. A-L-P-I-N-E. Das ist das Root-Passwort des iPhone.
Es gab noch irgendwie das Passwort Dotty. Das war, glaube ich, für irgendeinen Mobile-User, der drauf war auf dem Gerät. Aber ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt auch nicht so hundertprozentig sicher. Aber ich glaube Alpine war es von Anfang an. Alpine war ja auch der Codename vom iPhone.
War da nicht so irgendwie die Ansage, dass dieses Dotty irgendwie die ganze Zeit so als es noch in Entwicklung war, das Passwort war, und dann beim Release war es aber Alpine? Also das, was verkauft wurde, hatte das irgendwie sowas.
Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht genau. Das erste, was ich hatte, das erste iPhone, das war mit iOS, iPhone OS 1.1.3 oder sowas. Da habe ich mir noch ganz böses Baseband zerschossen. Und das hatte schon Alpine auf jeden Fall.
Also ich glaube, Denis meinte das letzte Mal.
Auf jeden Fall haben wir Alpine gesucht.
Ja, egal was stimmt, wir waren nach Alpine gesucht.
Also der Mobile-User hatte Dottie. Also Alpine wäre die richtige Antwort gewesen oder ist die richtige Antwort. Und die beiden Buchstaben, die dabei rauskommen sollen, sind IN.
Next.
Next. Das erste Apple-Gerät mit, nicht mit durchsichtigen Plastik, sondern aus, wie haben wir das formuliert?
Durchsichtigen Plastikgehäuse.
Mit einem Gehäuse aus durchsichtigen Plastik.
Genau, so haben wir es formuliert. Mit einem Gehäuse aus durchsichtigen Plastik. Und das war natürlich eine echte Fangfrage, weil natürlich da alle erst mal glaubten, das könnte ja nur der iMac sein.
Und wir haben diverse Inkarnationen des iMac-Namens in diesem Pad gesehen.
Aber es war natürlich...
E-Mate.
Falls ihr es nicht kennt. Eigentlich fand ich den...
Hab ich jetzt gerade mal in Hamburg, ich war ja noch auf dieser Ausstellung, die ich letzt mal erwähnte.
Hast du mal gesehen?
Hab ich den noch mal live gesehen, ja.
Ich glaub, der ist ganz cool.
Ja, also der E-Mate war halt der zweite Formfaktor des Newton, mit dem Newton OS. Und hat er halt gegenüber dem normalen Newton, der ja nur mit diesem Berührungsbildschirm, sag jetzt mal nicht Touchscreen, ne, also diesem...
Mit Stiftbedienung. Mit reiner Stiftbedienung.
Drucksensitiver, genau. Also mit Stiftbedienung und Handschrifterkennung ausgestattet war. Und der Newton als Plattform wurde auch noch auf dieses andere Gerät, was es aber so nur in den USA gab.
Und eigentlich auch nur für Schüler.
Und primär über diesen Education Channel verkauft wurde. Ja, das war halt der E-Mate. Und der E-Mate hatte halt tatsächlich auch schon so dieses durchsichtige grüne Plastik.
Und sah aus wie so ein kleines...
Wie ein Klodeckel.
Wie so ein kleines Eibuck. Wie das Eibuck der ersten Generation so ein bisschen.
Oder ein Brotpixel.
Also halt so ein Laptop-Format. Mit Aufklappen und so.
Jaja, also der E-Mate...
Das Natur macht vor allem den Eindruck, als ob sie durchaus was hermachen könnte. Aber es gab ja noch mehr Formfaktoren von Newton. Siemens hat den Newton ja in ein Telefon eingebaut. Jaja, es gibt so ein Siemens-Telefon, also so richtig so ein Tischtelefon, wo dann so ein Newton drin ist. Den kannst du auch rausnehmen. Dann ist das eigentlich im Wesentlichen ein Newton, auf dem Siemens drauf steht. Aber dann nimmst du halt noch so einen Telefonhörer und kannst dann irgendwie noch Telefonnummern eintippen. Ich hoffe, es war Siemens, aber es ist... Da gab es schon sehr abenteuerliche Sachen.
Gut, also...
Der Name, der sich für diesen E-Mate früh einbürgerte, war Klingonenhandtasche. Weil das Ding halt so absurd aussah, mit diesem durchsichtigen Plastik, und es hatte ja auch schon so einen Griff, zum Wegschmeißen. Im Prinzip waren da auch schon eine ganze Menge Cues drin. Also wenn man das Teil so sieht, und danach ist irgendwie das E-Book, so recht keine Überraschung mehr und eigentlich auch der iMac in dem Sinne gar nicht. Ich frage mich irgendwie auch, der e-Made war halt hier in Europa nicht so präsent, aber warum das auch in den USA, irgendwie Kanad kommen sehen, ist wirklich eine gute Frage. Wann wurde der e-Made veröffentlicht?
97 März.
97 und der iMac war?
Das iBook war 99 und der iMac glaube ich auch. Dieses iBook, das sieht so kacke aus, das ist echt unglaublich. Also das hat der...
August 98.
Das iBook hat ja im Club immer den Namen Klodeckel oder Brotbüchse, das war...
Guck, so sieht das Siemens Note Phone aus. Hier nochmal für dich.
Achso, da haben sie einfach den da so reingebaut. Ach, das wusste ich gar nicht.
Genau, und unten steht Siemens drauf.
Wirklich?
Das ist das andere Kult, Tim.
Nee, also ich finde die Idee eigentlich, das in so ein Telefon einzubauen, gar nicht so blöd. Also quasi das erste iPhone, oder?
Desktop-iPhone.
Googelt mal nach Siemens Note-Phone.
Gut, nächste Frage jetzt hier.
Ja, so, das heißt, weitere Buchstaben konnten gewonnen werden, EA. So, und jetzt kam so ein bisschen was, was so ein bisschen abgewichen ist, damit wir uns nicht immer nur so in dieser ganzen Apple-Vergangenheit rumschmiegen, die kleinste Einheit von Bitcoins.
Hab ich mir sogar gemerkt, hat sich direkt in meinen Hirn gefressen.
Das hat natürlich Denis ausgeübt. Die Frage wurde gesponsert von Denis.
Genau. Antwort ist Satoshi, S-A-T-O-S-H-I, welches ist der Vorname des Entwicklers?
Das ist auch nicht die offizielle Bezeichnung dafür, sondern die quasi inoffizielle Bezeichnung von dem, so ein Spitzenname mehr.
Really?
Meinte Denis jedenfalls, ja.
Das soll man ja auch so formulieren müssen.
Na ja, war alles ungültig. Ungültig Wiederholung.
Schick uns den Makerboard zurück.
Aber das haben, glaube ich, die meisten Leute richtig gemacht. Es gab sehr viel mehr durcheinander bei dem Root-Passwort, bei dem Code-Namen und bei dem ersten Apple-Gerät.
Was hingegen ja alle wussten scheinbar?
Doch, doch, doch. Es ging erstaunlich schnell, das muss man sagen. Ich dachte, das wäre so eine Frage, wo vielleicht niemand draufkommt, aber sonst hat er tatsächlich draufgekommen. Welche Waffe in Worms Amageddon ist auch ein Codename einer Apple-Software?
Ja, das haben irgendwie auch alle irgendwie hinbekommen.
Aber da gab es natürlich auch witzige, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was es war, weil es gab dann irgendwie eine erstaunlich hohe Korrelation von Apple-Codenamen und Waffen in Worms Amageddon. Tatsächlich? Ich glaube, es waren dann noch so zwei, drei dabei, die auch irgendwie drin vorgekommen haben.
Das war natürlich nicht mehr so in Detail.
Amageddon? Na, irgendjemand hat halt einfach noch ein paar Listen mit irgendwelchen Apple-Codenamen ausgegraben und irgendwas war dann noch dabei.
Sollte nicht auch eine Apple-Software ähnlich heißen? Also die gesuchte Lösung war auf jeden Fall Holly Hand Grenade.
Holly Hand Grenade.
Das war bestimmt auch alle aus, aber das wäre zu einfach gewesen, aus Die Ritter der Kokosnuss kennen. Und war der Codename, also die Waffe kenn ich nicht.
Ist halt, macht halt einfach bumm.
Viel bumm.
Und dazu Halleluja, genau.
Ja, so und jetzt haben wir halt irgendwie einen Buchstaben eingetümmt.
Für AppleShare-PDS war das das, AppleShare-irgendwas, war das der Codename. Und hat auch so ein kleines Killer-Kaninchen als Eiken.
Naja, also der Bezug war schon... Ja, man hätte vielleicht noch mal die Piesen zur Sicherheit mit reinbringen sollen, auch wenn das schon...
Ja, ich fand das super auch, ja. Das ging ja schnell genug, also das war wirklich auch.
Das finde ich auch, das fand ich auch. So, das heißt, die Lösung lautet Jela, Jelainastengr. Und jetzt gucke ich da unten gerade...
Was übrigens die Worte waren, die Steve Jobs gesprochen hat, als er gestorben ist.
Und das ist das, was ich jetzt hier in der Vorlesung habe. Und das ist das, was ich jetzt hier in der Vorlesung habe. Und das ist das, was ich jetzt hier in der Vorlesung habe. Und das ist das, was ich jetzt hier in der Vorlesung habe.
Also nächstes Mal, Kinder, ist übrigens so als kleinen Tipp, ja. Wenn ihr wieder so eine Aufgabe zu lösen habt, da gibt es so Webseiten, wo man so Akronym- äh, ne, ähm, hier, wie heißt das? Nicht Akronym-Finder, sondern Anagramm-
Anagramm-Generatoren.
Anagramm-Generatoren, genau. Da gibt es auch einen, der ist ziemlich gut, muss ich mal raussuchen, wenn ich den noch finde, tue ich in den Chat und da könnt ihr dann das nächste Mal ganz prima schauen.
Das war so ein Tipp, den wir dann so richtig nicht gegeben haben, weil das war dann am Schluss noch so ein bisschen der Hacker-Test. Weil das war dann am Schluss noch so ein bisschen der Hacker-Test. Also jetzt so die Buchstaben angucken und da die richtige Lösung finden. Zumal man ja sich dann auch die anderen hätte damit erarbeiten können. Weil man eine Frage nicht gewusst hat, dass da nur noch zwei Buchstaben fehlen. Und es hätte sich ja schon in der Richtung, ich möchte auflösen und ich möchte noch ein E-Kaufen und so weiter. Das wollten wir dann irgendwie dann doch vermeiden.
Und?
Ja, also die Lösung war natürlich insanely great.
Ach, jetzt hast du es einfach so gesagt.
Ach, das war die Lösung? Nee, also, äh, war insanely great tatsächlich. Und einer hat es rausgefunden relativ schnell. Und der hat jetzt auch sein Make-Abot schon bekommen.
Der hat den Make-Abot bereits bekommen. Der wurde dann sogar noch vor Weihnachten angeliefert.
Also von daher alles voll Luxus. Und hat er uns jetzt ein Mobile-Max-Logo gemakert?
Das ist allerdings, auf die Idee bin ich ja noch gar nicht gekommen. Also ich finde auch, der Make-Abot, junger Mann, wenn du uns wieder live zuhörst, dann könntest du ja mal... Wollen wir hier noch den Namen verkünden? Oder ist das Privatschutz? Privatschärfe.
Das hat Tim alleine entschieden.
Nein, ich sag mal hier den...
Das hat Mark Zuckerberg auch gesagt.
Ich sag mal hier die Schuhgröße. Friedrich heißt er.
Friedrich hat gewonnen.
Mit Vornamen?
Oder mit Nachnamen?
Ist Innenminister?
Nachnamen lassen wir jetzt mal weg. Aber ja, Friedrich hat gewonnen. Und Friedrich ist aus irgendeiner Stadt, von der ich nicht genau weiß, welche das wohl ist. Oder? Doch, warte mal, das müsste ich dir ja auch noch wissen.
Du hast es ja schließlich dahin geschickt.
Wir haben es ja dahin schicken lassen.
Das war noch im Norden, oder?
Ich hab sogar ein Foto von ihm bekommen, als ich das gesehen hab.
Also, wer Tim da jetzt noch die Adresse sucht, können wir uns ja nächsten Themenkomplex mal aussuchen.
Haben wir Themen?
Aber wir haben Komplexe auf jeden Fall.
Kann ja mal von meinem McPro berichten, von dem ich ja schon so viel berichtet habe.
Na ja, das war auch eine schöne Seite.
So, Lüneburg. Friedrich aus Lüneburg hat gewonnen und ist voll berechtigt, stolz zu sein auf sein geleistetes Werk.
Sollen wir hier mal kurz über diese Seite erzählen? therestartpage.com ist eine ganz tolle Seite, wo ihr euch angucken könnt, wie diverse Betriebssysteme neu starten. Also es hat so was meditatives. Man sieht so die Neustart-Dialoge von Windows und von alten Mac OS Versionen und von was auch immer das hier alles ist. Obwohl so viel ist es gar nicht. Das sind so ein bisschen wesentlichen Windows und Mac und Apple 2 GS und weiß der Teufel was. Und dann kann man immer auf Restart klicken. Und dann sieht es so aus, wie das damals aussah, wenn das System neu gestartet ist. Das dauert glaube ich auch ungefähr genauso lange.
Wahnsinn!
Je nachdem, wie schnell dein Rechner ist.
Kann man sich so hervorsetzen, kann man warten, bis der Computer neu gestartet ist.
Ich glaube, ich habe nur einen einzigen Vorgang, davon kannte ich noch nicht. Wenn ich mich so richtig erinnere, habe ich glaube ich nur einen einzigen nie gesehen und das ist lustigerweise einer von Apple. Wir haben nämlich ernsthaft noch nie an einem Apple II gesessen.
Ja, ich auch.
Noch nie? Ernsthaft?
Nee.
Ich auch nicht.
Also ich habe schon mal vor einem gestanden, aber ich habe keinerlei Erfahrung mit Apple II.
Ich hatte mal einen Apple II Plus, also der war nicht meiner, der stand irgendwo rum und ich hatte da ein paar Tage lang, da hatte ich glaube ich ein Praktikum irgendwo gemacht, da konnte ich dann auch ein bisschen auf einen Apple II rumhecken und einen Apple II GS hatte ich auch schon mal selber gesehen.
Also es gibt natürlich so Emulatoren und so weiter, aber da habe ich mir ehrlich gesagt auch noch nicht mit beschäftigt.
Ich sag mal so, das ist heutzutage auch glaube ich nicht mehr wirklich.
Aber ich fand den Apple II GS fand ich echt cool, weil da haben sie das komplette Mac OS in klein nachgebaut. Das ist echt...
So, jetzt aber mal wieder in die Zukunft, obwohl du hast ja einen gebrauchten Mac Pro gekauft. Also sagen wir mal, wir rücken jetzt von vorm Krieg zumindest nah an die Schallmauer der Gegenwart. Oder wie alt ist der Mac Pro?
Der ist im Prinzip der Bruder oder die Schwester von dem iMac, den ich hab, also 2009er Generation.
Und was musstest du bezahlen?
Euro.
Das ist ja günstig.
Ich hab das Ding zusammen mit dem 27 Zoll Bildschirm gekauft.
Und wie ist jetzt so das Fahrgefühl mit dem Aluminium-Panzer unterm Tisch?
Also ich bin wirklich froh, dass ich den habe. Ganz ehrlich. Und zwar allein schon, weil ich einfach so diese ganze Appearance von dieser Maschine einfach saugeil finde. Ja, also da kommt auch ein bisschen wieder was zurück, was ich echt vermisst habe.
So dieses Profe-Feeling auch.
Ja, der hat irgendwie analoge und digitale Audio-Ausgänge und die sind natürlich alle separat. Und nicht so Kombi-Stecker und je nachdem, was du da reinsteckst, schaltet es um und so. Und immer diese scheiß Kompromisse an Laptops und auch bei diesem iMacs, das irgendwie alles so zusammen genudelt und so. Abgesehen davon, dass ich ein paar mehr Audio-Ein- und Ausgänger habe, finde ich, ist das einfach ausgeräumt. Und einfach USB vorne und hinten und Firewire vorne und hinten. Und Audio-Out hat er auch nochmal vorne, sehe ich gerade.
Und Löcher vorne und hinten.
Ungenutzte Audio-Ports an Tim's Mac Pro.
Ja und ich konnte da einfach mal so BAM BAM BAM vier Platten reinhauen. Ja, das finde ich einfach wirklich super. Und auch so dieses Potenzial. Danach, kaum dass ich das Ding hatte, bekam ich die tolle Nachricht, dass es irgendwie mit der Audiokarte, die ich da unbedingt reinstecken möchte, noch Monate dauern wird. Bis sie dann endlich mal verfügbar ist. Und ich werd noch wahnsinnig. So, hab mich da jetzt mal für einen Beta-Test beworben, mal gucken, ob das irgendwas bringt.
Also falls ich den Herstellern dieser Audiokarte einen Tipp geben kann, auf keinen Fall.
Die haben es mir angeboten. Ich hab den schon in der anderen Karte, da hab ich den schon irgendwie Bugs gefixt. Also nicht gefixt, aber gefunden. Die haben es gefixt.
Und wichtige Frage, auch aus dem Chat. Hast du auch eine SSD reingesteckt?
Ja klar, ich hab einfach die SSD, die ich vorher externe an meinem iMac baumeln hatte, hab ich da einfach reingeschoben und zack, lief. Bumm zack, ging einfach. Ja, insofern kann ich gar nichts Besonderes berichten, außer dass das so funktioniert hat. Also die einzige Besonderheit ist, dass hier sich nicht mehr die Original-Grafikkarte drin befand, sondern der Eigentümer sich da so aus Mangel an Performance einem damals aktuellen Modell oder vor kurzem erst aktuellen Modell einer ATI, jetzt geht's wieder los hier mit den Zahlen, Radeon. Das war wiederum die andere Schattenseite, wo ich mir dachte, oh man, jetzt muss ich mir darüber Gedanken machen, was ich für eine Grafikkarte in meinem Computer habe. Das sind ja auch echt so die Dinge, die man einfach gar nicht möchte. So und jetzt habe ich da nämlich eine AMD, also ATI, AMD, Radeon, HD, 6870-Karte drin. Das gibt mir die Zahl. Ist das so, dass umso größer die Zahl, umso besser? Oder ist das irgendwie schmoo?
Nee, ist schon bestimmt so, glaube ich.
Interessanterweise wird auch für die aktuellen Mac Pros derzeit nur so eine 58 irgendwas Karte.
Achso, nee, nee, da gibt es, ach, frag mal nächste Woche Denis nochmal genau. Da gibt es tatsächlich welche mit kleinerer Nummer, die aber auch besser sind als welche mit größerer Nummer, aber die sind dann vielleicht für unterschiedliche Sachen auch besser.
Diese Karte wurde zwar dann später von Mac OS unterstützt, also Apple hat offizielle Treiber mit an Bord dafür, aber diese Karte hatte halt mal so ein PC-Bios. Ist dann irgendwie umgeflasht worden, was aber immer noch nicht dazu führte, dass diese Karte von der Firmware erkannt wird. Das heißt, wenn das Ding bootet, kann er mit dieser Grafikkarte nichts anfangen. Sondern erst, wenn das OS geladen wird und das OS mit seinen Treibern kommt, dann sieht er, ah, da ist ja auch eine Grafikkarte, mit der ich was anfangen kann. Das heißt, ich sehe den Firmware-Dialog gar nicht mehr. Das Ding ist einfach schwarz. Ja, wenn ein OS geladen ist.
Also Abuser-Login oder...
Nee, wenn halt der Apfel kommt.
Der Apfel kommt. Und vorher diesen ganzen... Was natürlich das Problem ist in dem Moment, wo dir eine Bootplatte zickt oder du von einer anderen Platte booten möchtest und somit Alt drücken und diese ganzen Späße, das geht halt so nicht.
Hast du denn auch die originale Grafikkarte, die da mal drin war?
Tja, naja, das... Grafikkarten sind ja nicht so teuer heutzutage mehr.
Ja, aber ich hab schon mal geguckt, ob ich auf Ebay mal so ein Ding einfach so für Notfall kriege.
Die ganzen Bitcoiner, die müssen doch das jetzt wieder verkaufen, denke ich. Die haben noch vorher gehorchtet und jetzt...
Ja, ich frage mich nur, warum das eigentlich so ist, weil... Ich soll mein Bäuchchen aus dem Mund nehmen, sagen sie alle. Mach ich gleich.
Wenn es aufgelutscht ist.
Und wenn da schon wirklich eine andere Firmware draufgebrannt wurde, warum führt das dazu, dass... dass die EFI von dem Mac Pro...
Die gute alte EFI, ja weiß ich auch nicht.
Also ich meine, wenn da schon was anderes draufgebrannt wird, dann ist es ja vor allem die Firmware, weil in dem Moment, wo das OS mit den Treibern kommt, kümmert sich das OS ja sozusagen selber darum und aktiviert da nicht mehr Code. Und das bringt mich so ein bisschen in diesen Glauben, dass das vielleicht noch nicht so das Ende vom Lied war, nicht die richtige Firmware war. Andererseits war es wohl auch so, dass es vorher gar nicht funktionierte. Also das ist mir ein Rätsel. Wenn da irgendjemand...
Den coolen Grafik, das Grafikkarten-Toolkit.
Genau, also falls da irgendjemand dieses Problem konkret aufklären kann, da wäre ich doch sehr dankbar. Radeon HD 6870 steckt hier in einem Mac Pro von 2009. Und ja, ist mir so ein bisschen unklar.
Was lutscht du da eigentlich die ganze Zeit?
Salami...
Salami?
Salmiak Lakritzbonbons. Das ist sehr unangemessen für Podcasting. Ich merke es gerade, weil die lösen sich irgendwie nicht so schnell auf. Ich werde das mal los.
Willkommen zurück. Alles los.
Hab da keinen Drei, wenn ich irgendwie nicht da bin.
Doch, ich...
Ich dachte, ich mach mir jetzt einfach mal cool noch einen Kaffee.
Ich hab mir Sorgen um dich gemacht.
Trinkst Mate, genau so macht man das.
Hier gibt es nämlich auch eine neue Kaffeemaschine.
So, vielleicht noch ein paar Anmerkungen zu dem Mac Pro, außer dass ich den total geil finde. Hätte mir noch irgendwas Cooles ein dazu. Da hab ich natürlich nachgedacht, PC-I-Karten und so. Weil ich hasse das immer, wenn ich so einen Rechner habe, der erweiterbar ist und dann sind keine Erweiterungen drin. Dann hab ich als erstes mal festgestellt, Scheiße, das Teil hat ja noch nicht mal WLAN. Das ist ja eine Option zum Anklicken. Da ist man gleich auf eBay erstmal nochmal an diese Karte geklickt. Weil ich kann es nicht vertragen, wenn ein Rechner keinen WLAN hat. Das geht aber nicht. Nicht, dass ich es jetzt zwingend brauche, weil er hat ja auch mal 2x Gigabit und so. Das holt es ja aus dem Vollen.
Ohne WLAN geht einfach nicht. Das ist ein stationärer Rechner, das hat doch keinen Punkt.
Aber es ist auch 21. Jahrhundert.
Das ist eine Netzwerkschnittstelle. Das braucht man halt manchmal, wenn es nur zum Testen ist.
Ah, okay.
Um zu sehen, ob ein Netz da ist oder so.
Oder deine E-Mail-Passwörter sind.
Oder, dass ich einfach nochmal einen zweiten Scanner brauche oder nochmal einfach einen zweiten Client und dass man Latenztests macht oder so.
Die AirDrop?
Was? Sie ist noch nicht drin.
Sie ist noch auf dem Versandweg.
Aber ich hab diesen Finder Default eingestellt, dass er AirDrop auf allen Interfaces macht. Und trotzdem erscheint das dann nicht. Also mir erscheint es so, dass er selbst dann, wenn eben gesagt wird, nimm alle Interfaces, er trotzdem sich überhaupt nicht aktiviert, wenn gar kein WLAN da ist.
Okay.
Sozusagen kommt das nur hinzu. Ist eine Vermutung von mir. Wie laut ist der Mac Pro im Vergleich zum iMac, wird hier gefragt.
Also ich hab gar nicht gehört, dass er da ist.
Also das Ding ist nicht laut. Der ist leise. Das kann man mal so sagen. Ich meine, das mag davon abhängen, wie viele Grafikkarten man da drin hat, etc. Und auch, wie die Festplatten sich so verhalten. Das ist klar. Wenn die Festplatten jetzt halt da dicke, stinke Wärme erzeugen, dann dürfte sich der Lüfter schon mal ein bisschen mehr bewegen. Aber grundsätzlich ist dieses ganze Lüftungsprinzip bei dem Mac Pro gelöst.
Sind hier überall Löcher drin?
Der hat auch wirklich große Lüfter. Also große Lüfter sind sowieso schon mal, haben einfach mal ganz andere Frequenzen am Start und also wenn hier im Studio irgendwas wirklich auffällig ist, dann ist es der Beamer. Weil der ist auch ein bisschen lauter geworden jetzt so, nachdem wir jetzt hier schon so ein paar Stunden, also das ist jetzt hier die lauteste Störkomponente. Und ich habe den Mac Pro jetzt auch noch nicht so gezwungen. Ich habe da mal so ein bisschen mit Handbrake rumgespielt, aber das Ding hat ja auch irgendwie acht echte Chores. Das heißt, ich habe 16 virtuelle Chores mit Halbpass-Threading. Und da dauert halt einfach so ein DVD-Encode nicht lang.
Ne, das ist jetzt so wie früher MP3s von der CD machen, was so eine Stunde gedauert hat und dann irgendwann später so, komm geh weg. Und jetzt fängt es mit DVDs so an. Das ist dann so die Grenze, wenn Formate wirklich aussterben. Dann kann man daran messen, dass es dann einfach zu Endkoden und Dekoden einfach kein wirklich signifikanter Aufwand mehr ist.
Das stimmt. Ja, ist fast dran. Jetzt hab ich halt so geguckt, also neben dieser Audiokarte, die ich da gerne reinstecken möchte, wer das wissen möchte, worum es sich dabei handelt, also ich möchte gerne da so diese Audiokarte von Dante reinstecken. Also nicht von Dante, sondern von einer Firma, die heißt Ordinate, die Produkt-Serie heißt Dante. Und das ist halt das, was ich auch in meinem Mixer drin habe und das ist halt Audio über Gigabit Ethernet. Und derzeit kann ich halt mit meinem 16 Kanäle von dem Mischpult einfach auf Ethernet legen und das hat halt einfach eine geile Performance. Das ist einfach stable und felsen solide und wie ihr ja am Anfang gehört habt. Und vor allem bietet es mir dann interessante Optionen. Jetzt wo ich zwei Rechner habe, kann ich halt auch künftig dann mit Multicast arbeiten. Das heißt, ich kann das Mischpult, die Audioströme per Multicast auf das Ethernet legen und dann von mehreren Rechnern gleichzeitig empfangen. Das heißt, wenn mir ein Rechner mitten drin abschmiert, sagen wir mal, dass er sich einfach mitten während der Aufnahme auslockt. Wie man das ja einem Windows-Rechner gerne unterstellen würde. Machen tut es dann aber zum Beispiel meinen Computer. So geschehen hier vor drei Wochen.
Während der Aufnahme?
Während der Aufnahme. Einfach so. Weg, ausgelockt. Ich weiß auch schon, wer der böse Wicht ist. Und zwar? Ich weiß, wer es ausgelöst hat. Ausgelöst hat es der QuickTime Player. Ich hatte nämlich noch ein Backup laufen, in Anführungsstrichen. Also ich nahm auf, wie immer, mit Live und hatte nebenbei meinen QuickTime Player laufen. Also den QuickTime X, den modernen QuickTime Player. Da kann man ja mal so eben mit Tastenkombination sagen, hier neues Audio Dokument und dann wählst du deine Input-Quelle. Das habe ich bisher auch immer benutzt und habe halt als Quelle üblicherweise den Digital-Innen genommen, was halt der normale Audio-Innen ist. Der Digital wird in dem Moment, wo man da auch ein Digital anschließt, wie ich schon eben gesagt habe, mit diesem Switching-Audio-Devices, die Apple da immer aufbietet. Das hat soweit auch wunderbar funktioniert und dann nahm er eben auf. Und das war bisher auch eigentlich relativ problemlos. Durch diesen Plattenwechsel und dadurch, dass eben diese ganzen Audio-Devices vielfältiger und anders sind auf dem Mac Pro, also quasi dasselbe OS mit seinen Voreinstellungen und Settings, die die ganzen Programme hatten, kam er halt einfach immer auf eine andere Hardware hoch, wo alles anders war. Und so nahm dieser Quicktime-Player eben nicht über dieses Digital-Interface, was ich vorher eingestellt habe, auf. Weil das war halt so das Standard-Audio-Innen von dem iMac und auf dem Mac Pro finden das irgendwie anders aus. Auf jeden Fall hat er sich dann mein Dante-Interface genommen und hat da aufgenommen, wo auch tatsächlich die Aufnahme auch wirklich korrekt vorgenommen wurde. Soweit war das eigentlich alles vollkommen in Ordnung. Nur, was ich erst in dem Moment wirklich realisiert habe, ist, wenn du dem Quicktime-Player sagst, er soll von einem Device aufnehmen, dann nimmt er alle Kanäle auf, die dieses Device ausspuckt.
Das hat ihn wahrscheinlich relativ schnell ziemlich voll gemacht.
Ja, er hat 16 Kanäle parallel aufgezeigt und performance-mäßig hat ihn das nicht groß gezückt, aber er hat halt 16 Kanäle aufgezeichnet und wenn ich mich recht entsinne, hat er sie auch raw aufgezeichnet. Also nicht encoded den Moment.
Quicktime-Player macht doch eigentlich nicht raw.
Aber es ist egal, also bei 16 Kanälen wurde die Datei dann doch schon sehr schnell voll. Naja, mitten in der Aufnahme macht es auf einmal so. Und ich blicke auf meinen Computer und es einfach nur log in. Einfach alles ist verschwunden. Von 0 auf 100, so bang, weg. Und ja, dann habe ich halt so ein bisschen Forensik da betrieben, allein schon um meine Audio-Dateien zurückzubekommen, die natürlich alle nicht richtig weggeschrieben wurden und dann header kaputt und Audiofalls erstmal nicht zu gebrauchen und so. Und vielen Dank an Timo von Bits und So, der mir da schnell und unbürokratisch mit seiner, ich editiere mit dem Hex-Editor eine Dateikennnissen, die Audiodateien schnell wieder gerade gebogen hat, wofür ich keine Zeit hatte. Und dann ist mir halt aufgefallen, dass eben diese Dateien, diese Backup-Dateien, die der QuickTime Player aufgenommen hat, 4,26 GB groß waren. Das war das, was mir der Feinde anzeigte. Ring the Bell. Ring the Bell. Dann hab ich mir immer genau anzeigen lassen, wie groß das jetzt, also wie viele Bites da tatsächlich in dieser Datei drin waren. Und in Hex war das halt, ja, FF, FFF.
Bis zum Anschlag.
Bis zum Anschlag, bis auf so ein paar Bites. Also da fehlt irgendwie nur noch so ganz wenig, bis die 32 Bit halt voll waren. Mit anderen Worten. Hier meine These. QuickTime Player, wenn man ihn einfach aufzeichnen lässt und er schreibt in so ein MOF-File rein und das MOF-File ist vier Gigabyte groß, also überschreitet die 32 Bit Grenze, in dem Moment crasht nicht nur der QuickTime Player, sondern unter Umständen sogar, jetzt kann ich nur spekulieren, das ganze Chor-Audio. Oder QuickTime. Oder irgendein anderer Querschläger, der einfach alles, also ich denke zu dem Zeitpunkt ist sowieso schon alles aus. Und letztlich ausloggen. Ich meine, ich hätte ja kein Problem damit gehabt, wenn der QuickTime Player stirbt. Damit hätte ich irgendwie ein Leben können. Aber ich glaube halt nicht, dass es das war. Ich glaube, dass tatsächlich diese Aufnahme, die dann eben an diese 4 GB stieß, dazu führt. Also ich hab's dann nochmal reproduziert und normalerweise stirbt der einfach. Also wenn du so ein 16-Kanal-Interface machst mit Rohrnummer auf, dann dauert es ein paar Minuten, dann hast du deine 4 GB voll und dann macht's Kabang und dann ist irgendwie dein QuickTime Player einfach Asche. Das heißt, diesen eigentlichen Effekt, den ich hier hatte, habe ich jetzt so nicht nachvollziehen können. Aber ich habe jetzt bei dem Test auch nicht gleichzeitig von demselben Audio-Interface aufgenommen. Weil das ist genau das, was ich gemacht hatte. Ich hatte zwei Programme, die an demselben Audio-Interface nagten, während bei dem einen halt irgendwie was kaputt ging und keine Ahnung, was an der Stelle dann wirklich passiert ist und wie reproduzierbar das ist. Auf jeden Fall führte es dazu, dass der Windows-Server letzten Endes durchgedreht ist, weil wenn, also die einfachste Methode, alles diesen Effekt zu erzeugen, dass ich alles auslaufe. Ich hab das jetzt bei Line so noch nicht probiert, aber meiner Meinung nach, wenn du den Windows-Server killst, dann lockst du dich aus, ja? Dann lockt sich alles aus und alle deine Programme werden einfach mitgekillt und genau diesen Effekt hatte ich. Jetzt ist mir natürlich immer noch ein Rätsel, wie es sein kann, dass wenn so ein Subsystem da irgendwie failt oder ein Prozess failt, wie das so eine unmittelbare Auswirkung haben kann auf den Windows-Server. Aber das kann ja auch einfach nur sein, dass es einfach ein Fehler ist, in den sie nicht gerannt sind, der dann wieder um irgendeine andere Warnmeldung erzeugt, die dann wiederum den Windows-Server durcheinander bringt.
Es könnte ja auch eine Ebene höher gewesen sein, dass das dann einfach dein, also ich weiß nicht, wer den Windows-Server startet, dass der dann einfach dein Windows-Server gestorben ist und deinen Windows-Server mit in den Abgrund gerissen hat. Weil Windows-Server ist ja auch nicht ganz oben, es ist ja hier...
Heißt er Windows-Server oder ist er Windows-Server?
Launch die, startet den.
Wie heißt denn dieser Podcast? Windows-Server, genau.
Und der wird von Launch die hochgefahren.
Genau, und der Windows-Server. Also W, I, N, D, O, V-Server.
Den können wir jetzt mal kurz quitten und dann sehen wir, was passiert.
Aber der ist ja gar nicht mehr der Meister von allem, oder?
Also wenn Login-Window gekillt wird, ich glaube, dann bist du auch ausgelockt.
Ich probier das mal.
Es kann auch sein, dass sich das unter Line jetzt anders verhält. Ich rede jetzt noch so ein bisschen mit meiner Erfahrungswelt bis SnowLab hat.
Ja, aber da war der Window-Manager auch nicht das Oberste. Er ist halt für alle Fenster zuständig. Und wenn die in dem Moment, in dem die ihre ganze Grafikausgabe verlieren, dann sind sie halt quasi tot. Also, dann siehst du halt nicht mehr viel.
Ich würde mal sagen, ich habe so das Gefühl, ich sitze auf einer Couch, ja, so ein Doktor im weißen Kittel hält meine Hand und ich rede über meine Beziehung zu Laine. Ja, und ich hab einfach das Gefühl, so geht's nicht weiter. Ich hab noch nie so ein schlechtes OS-Release gehabt seit sehr langer Zeit. Also ich kann mich gar nicht erinnern, was so viel Ärger erzeugt hat wie dieses Laine.
Bei mir ist es halt so, ich bin ja so viel im Terminal unterwegs, dass ich es gar nicht merke wahrscheinlich. Meine Multimedia-Zeit ist so ein bisschen vorbei gerade, deswegen...
Multimedia-Zeit ist vorbei.
Na ja, ich gucke mal einen Film und spiele ein bisschen Musik und ansonsten bin ich im Terminal unterwegs oder im Browser. Deswegen, ich merke gar nichts mehr vom Betriebssystem so richtig. Was ist denn da so schlimm? Ich habe überhaupt gar keinen Stress damit.
Also ich habe am Laufen, ich habe ja letztes Mal schon drauf geklagt.
Also mach mal die Management Summary, wir wollen ja noch mal was erzählen.
Management Summary, hängende Prozesse, WLAN-Probleme, hängende Prozesse, hängende Prozesse und abstürzende Sessions. So und das ist mir einfach, das ist mir einfach too much.
Das habe ich gar nicht, wa?
Ja, ich meine, vielleicht sind wir auch wieder in der Ära des Clean Install angekommen.
Ich habe abgegradet, das erste Mal seit 10 Jahren habe ich abgegradet. Und es läuft smooth.
Vielleicht darum.
Ich hatte so ein Gut-Feeling. Dieses Release will abgegradet werden.
Das brauchst du ein bisschen, das brauchst du ein bisschen.
Das will ja auch abgegradet werden. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie mache ich überhaupt ein Clean Install? Es braucht Hände unter den Nägeln quasi.
Du bootest von der Recovery-Disc und dann sagst du......Platte löschen und... Achso, Platte löschen und dann pumpst du drauf. Lädt der ein bisschen runter?
Ja, nee, das müsste schon...
Gibst du deine Apple ID ein, dann lädt der halt ein bisschen und dann machst du Cleaners drauf. Habe ich schon gemacht, das geht.
Hier fällt mir nicht ab.
Geht aber auch nur, wenn man schon die Recovery drauf hat.
Nee, die hat er ja immer.
Die hat er seit Lain.
Ja, wenn du eine frische Platte dir da rein stopfst, dann hast du die nicht.
Achso, da hast du auch keine Recovery. Du hast also auch kein Installationsmedium.
Aber da könntest du im Prinzip wiederum remote installieren, über Netz.
Ich glaube bei hier, bei dem...
Wenn du alt drückst, das ist ja in der ME-Federn drin.
Aber kann ich mir einfach dieses Install-Line-Teil auf irgendwie... Ja, ich muss ja auch... Aber davon kann ich ja nicht booten.
Doch, doch.
Die bieten so ein Tool an, mit dem du dir auf einen USB-Stick einen Installer bauen kannst.
In diesem Installer-Ding, das du dir gekauft hast, da gibt es dieses ESD-Install-Image. Da kannst du dann Show Package-Content machen. Und das machst du dir mit Disk Utility auf einem USB-Stick, auf einer DVD, was auch immer.
Bist du sicher?
Ja, das hab ich schon tausendmal jetzt gemacht.
Auch mit der App für Android?
Das hab ich nicht laut gesagt. Das war natürlich nur einmal. Das war eine Privatkopie. Und ich hab eine Lizenz für das ganze Haus. Also du hast in deinem Programm diesen Line-Installer wahrscheinlich noch rumliegen. Install macOS Line. Da machst du Show Package-Contents. Dann klickst du auf Contents. Und dann liegt da... Wo liegt da denn? In Shared Support liegt Install ESD DMG. Und das restorest du dir auf eine Festplatte, auf einen USB-Stick, brennst es dir auf einer DVD, was auch immer.
Und wenn du das alternativ kannst, kannst du auch bei Apple dir das entsprechende Tool runterladen.
Ja, mittlerweile, genau. Am Anfang gab es dieses Tool nicht, aber es gibt auch ein Tool, was diesen Vorgang für dich wrappt.
Irgendwie was mit Recovery DVT.
Da ist heute eigentlich ein Pad mit, ich bin gerade extrem schlecht im Notieren unserer Show notes.
Na du kannst es hier hinterher nochmal anhören.
Recovery Disk Assistant. Das werden wir ohne den Shet.
Nichts, ein feuchter...
We're sorry, we can't find the article you're looking for.
Also ich hab hier www.apple.com/macos10/recovery.
Und dann?
Ah und da ist unten das Learn more about Recovery Disk Assistant.
Und dann page not found.
Und dann download. Genau.
Na in der Tat, da kommt was. Hat er nicht geschwindelt. Die recovery, Kavallerie.
Ist doch genau das gleiche Link, den ich da unten geklickt habe.
Meiner ist besser. Das ist bestimmt Lion dran schuld.
Ich hab diesen Link, das ist genau derselbe Link.
Hier, klick mal das da, das ist viel besser. Guck mal da, zack.
Ist auch mit Bildchen und so.
Ist mit Bildchen, ist viel bunter.
Aber da sind mehr Bildchen. Noch mehr?
Ja.
So ein Airport-Symbol.
Und einen schönen USB-Stick.
Ist ja gut. Also ein Clean-Install ist möglich. Okay, ich wusste gar nicht, dass da so ein buntes Bildchen für haben.
Ich hab schon mal mit Lion hier mit meinem alten MacBook Pro, das ich dann neulich weggegeben habe. Oder hab ich dann mal so ein Clean-Install gemacht.
Wenn du dann auf diesen Download-Link also es geht erst beim Reload. Du landest dann auch bei dieser Support-Seite tatsächlich. Du brauchst mal Urlaub für Clean-Install. Ein Clean-Install-Urlaub, super. So wie Zen-Garten, so wenn man dann irgendwie mit der Hake die kleinen Steinchen wieder...
So wie es in Zugs Kliniken gibt, so gibt es dann auch Clean-Install. So Entschlackung.
Soll ich mal in der Zwischenzeit was ganz Aktuelles erzählen?
Sind wir denn mit dem Thema durch, was auch mal unser Thema jetzt gerade war? Wir haben über den Mac Pro geredet, wir haben über Line geredet, wir haben ein bisschen geschimpft. Gibt es noch Fragen zu dem Mac Pro? Nee, eigentlich nicht, oder? Ach ja, doch, ich wollte noch sagen, da kann man von ab dieses Karten reinstecken. Ich war ja bei dieser Grafikkarte ein bisschen hingeblieben und bei dem Abstürzen. Aber es gibt ja dann auch so andere Karten, die man da reinstecken kann. Zum Beispiel gibt es da so eine Raidkarte von Apple. Ich weiß nicht, hat da jemand schon mal Erfahrung mit gemacht?
Wie viel Platz hast du denn da? Ich hab Raidkarten. Benutze ich ja nicht mehr.
Dann sitzt ihr auch nach der Raidkarte voll. Haben wir ja Glück.
Na ja, Hardware-Raid ist nicht mehr zeitgemäß.
Warum?
Na ja, weil... Das Ding ist halt, ich meine, ich mach echt nicht viel mit Servern im Vergleich zu manch anderem. Aber auch ich hatte schon dieses Phänomen, Hardware-Controller im Arsch, kaufst das gleiche Modell, hat aber eine andere Firmware-Version, in den Raid geht nicht. Und das ist halt so der übliche Schmerz mit Hardware-Raid-Controllern. Wenn du dir einen kaufst, kauf gleich zwei, leg den anderen in den Schrank, weil wenn dein mal kaputt geht, dann brauchst du genau den mit genau der Firmware und genau dem aus der gleichen Fabrik. Sonst kommst du an den Raid nicht mehr ran.
Das ist echt eine Krankheit, oder dass genau diese Sicherheitssysteme dann an solchen Stellen so versagen?
Also das ist, und es ist schon immer so, also ich weiß, vielleicht hat sich jetzt im 21. Jahrhundert auch an dieser Hinsicht was getan, aber es war schon immer Schmerz. Wenn du nicht wirklich Deluxe de la Cac, was weiß ich. Vielleicht gab es auch Hardware-Raid-Controller, die super waren, aber die, die ich hatte, oder Freunde oder Kollegen, die waren, wenn sie mal kaputt gegangen sind, Schmerz. Und heutzutage, wo die Rechner schnell genug sind, die Busse schnell genug und alles Mögliche, sowieso, und das ZFS auf dem Server.
ZFS, kommen wir gleich drauf. Kurz noch mal die Klammern schließen, die ich alle vorhin aufgemacht habe. Die andere Klammer war das mit dieser Ordinate-Karte. Vielleicht noch kurz dazu, also die wird von Focusrite, beziehungsweise die soll angeblich mal von Focusrite vertrieben werden, aber weil sie irgendwie alle ihre anderen Produkte noch nicht fertig haben, kommen sie halt mit dieser Karte nicht raus, obwohl die seit einem Jahr angekündigt ist. Also ziemlich genau heute vor einem Jahr ist das Ding angekündigt worden. Es ist immer noch nicht verfügbar, obwohl die Karte im Prinzip fertig auf dem Tisch liegt. Sie verkauft hier bloß keiner. Wenn das Ding da mal drinsteckt, dann hab ich so richtig schön seidig, niedrige Latenz und ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz viele Kanäle.
Verkauft dir die keiner diese Karte?
Weil sie sich halt einen exklusiven Partner gesucht haben. Ordinate ist halt eine Technologie-Company. Die bauen den Scheiß zwar, aber die haben jetzt kein besonderes Vertriebs-Standing. Und die Karte, die ich jetzt in meinem Yamaha-Mixer habe, die wird auch von Yamaha verkauft, was ganz naheliegend ist bei Yamaha-Mixern. Das war auch an der Stelle kein Problem. Die war dann irgendwann verfügbar, dann war sie meine. Hier bei der für Mac und PC sind sie halt auf Focus-Ride zugegangen, was halt so eine von den bekannteren Audio-Buden ist, die auf allerlei USB- und Firewire-Kram machen. Weil wohl die ganze Produktserie, mit der sich das noch kombinieren, also sie haben noch so diverse 19 Zoll-Equipment, was halt auch mit diesem Dante-Kram arbeitet, das ist halt wohl irgendwie alles noch nicht fertig. Es sind halt Analoge, also es sind halt so Konverter von diesem Ethernet dann wiederum auf Analoge und auf digitale Ports.
Die bringen das erst draus, wenn alles fertig ist?
Offensichtlich. Don't ask me.
Und nehmt's dann vom Markt, wenn eins der Teile wieder veraltet ist?
Ich find's ja auch scheiße, aber ich kann's halt nicht, ich kann's halt nicht ändern. Die Karte hätte ich halt gerne, weil die würde mir eine ganze Menge neue Optionen geben. Ja, und dann bleibt eigentlich nur für mich noch, dass ich überlege, noch eine weitere Grafikkarte reinzustecken. Ich hab aber auch keine Erfahrung wie so ein Mac mit mehreren Grafikkarten.
Moment mal, hast du aber gar keinen Slot mehr frei.
Doch, ich hab jetzt drei freie Slots.
Ach du hast drei freie Slots, okay. Also vier insgesamt. Nee, kannst du ja im Sister Profiler gucken.
Kann ich ja hier auch.
Ja, musst jetzt nicht aufmachen.
Nein, ich mach das nicht.
Nicht, dass die aufnahmen, weil die einen Arsch ist. Ich hab ja nicht den Rechner aufgemacht, da war plötzlich Knock-In-Window da.
Das liebe ich ja auch so an Macs. Man kann ja so ein Programm starten, und das sagt einem, um was für einen Computer es sich handelt.
Nee, die sagen dir, was für ein Board du hast und so.
Wo denn? Wie denn? Ich hab da so einen FreeBSD-Server, der steht da in Holland, und keiner weiß, wie viel RAM man da reinstecken kann.
Das hingegen kriegst du aber schon raus. Es gibt so eine schöne Seite, Unix Toolbox. Die benutze ich ja sehr gerne, da gibt's so alle pfiffigen Commands für FreeBSD und Linux. Unix Toolbox. Und da steht bestimmt auch das magische Kommando drin. Hier, ich paste den Link gleich mal in den Chat, damit alle nicht gleich schreien. Und dann kannst du zum Beispiel Sysctlhw eintippen und dann sagt er dir bestimmt irgendwie welches Board du hast.
Die Beschreibung dahinter. Gibst du a lot of hardware information?
Jetzt sind wir gespannt. Mach mal hier auf dem Beamer.
Ach Gott, das ist ja doch so richtig wie man das so mit grün auf schwarz macht.
Also ich hab schon Maschinen gesehen, wo mehr dabei raus kam tatsächlich.
Nee, mach mal ohne Model, mach mal nur HW.
Nur HW, genau. Wer hat dir denn das Model gesagt?
Der erste...
Ja, das ist ein Glanz auf HW. So, da brüllt er dir jetzt auf jeden Fall einiges entgegen.
Wie viel ist denn das? Das sind zwei Gigabyte? Nicht das richtig? Das ist ja ein bisschen vage.
Das ist bestimmt total interessant.
Warte, warte, warte, warte. Irgendwo steht dann bestimmt auch so ein... Irgendwas, womit du rausfindest, was für ein Board da drauf steckt.
Was für ein Board? Du willst mir nicht sagen, dass mir wirklich das System sagt, was da drin ist? Also hier steht davon nix.
Hätte ja sein können, dass das vielleicht doch die Frage beantwortet. Aber du weißt immerhin, was du für eine CPU hast. Und anhand dieser CPU weißt du ja, was für Chipsets da am Start sein können. Und... Dann...
Ja, aber das gibt mir keine Sicherheit.
Da geht bestimmt mehr als 2 GB.
Ja, das möchte ich auch annehmen.
Ja, das ist bestimmt so. Aber trotzdem weiß niemand, was da reingeht. Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall wäre das mit McIntosh nicht passiert. Aber McIntosh steht halt auch nicht im Rack und ist ein Server.
Apropos FreeBSD, für alle, die es nicht mitbekommen haben. FreeBSD 9 gibt es jetzt auf allen Amazon EC2 Instanzen. Also wer schon immer mal einen FreeBSD sich einfach so mit dem Fingerschnipp casten wollte. Haben sie jetzt ja ein Jahr oder so dran rumgeschraubt. Ich paste mal gleich den Blog-Post dazu noch.
Wie arm wird man denn da, wenn man so eine Kiste eigentlich das ganze Jahr aber durchlaufen lässt?
Wenn du sehr arm bist. Na ja, es kommt drauf an, was du damit machst tatsächlich.
Also wenn du es durchlaufen lässt das ganze Jahr, dann sind physikalische Maschinen durchaus noch deutlich billiger.
Du zahlst durch bei Amazon viermal so viel letztendlich, wenn du die gleiche Leistung in Bare Metal hättest. Also das ist schon um einiges teurer. Aber wenn du halt gerade mal was ausprobieren willst, so mal eben eine Instanz hochfahren, die auch mal zwei, drei Wochen laufen lässt, die nicht viel Traffic macht oder so, dann kannst du halt echt schnell dir einfach mal ein kleines Cluster zusammenklicken und zahlst dann am Ende des Monats 25 Dollar oder so dafür.
Hör mal auf. Allein der Traffic, Alter. Der bringt mich um.
Felsen vom Ast.
So, da ist der, da ist der...
Für die Show-Notes, ne? Für die schönen Höchster habe ich den Blogpost mit reingetan. In Chat Tim.
So, jetzt gucke ich mal, was ich hier habe. Slot 1, Slot 1. Nee, er sagt mir nicht, wieviel Slots ich frei habe. Sagt mir nur, was in den Slots drinsteckt. Aber nicht, was in diesen drinsteckt.
Also, auch nicht besser.
Hier kommen andere Tipps. Ist wahrscheinlich hier Linux-Tipps, oder? linuxtipps.com LSHW, klingt nach Linux. Nee, nee, so nicht. Karten, tralala, okay, keine Ahnung. Ansonsten wüsste ich jetzt nicht noch, was ich reinstecken soll. Karten, tralala, okay. Ich brauch halt noch eine zweite Grafikkarte, weil diese Grafikkarte hat nur zwei Mini-Display-Port-Ausgänge. Ich brauch drei. So, dann sprachst du an ZFS, wo wir schon so über Raid und Platten geredet haben. Dann greifen wir auch gerne noch das andere Thema auf, was du haben wolltest, aber bleiben wir mal dabei. Habt ihr es mitbekommen?
Ja, mitbekommen.
tensecomplement.com, also die Firma, die... Ups...
.sich bezahlt ZFS jetzt ausgedacht hat.
Ja, der Typ, der mal bei Apple herausgeschmissen wurde, der Fallsysteme entwickelt hat, der jetzt seit Ewigkeiten daran bastelt und der das Ganze unter Z410, also Z410, ähm, angepriesen hat, dass es denn mal kommen würde, hat jetzt angekündigt, dass es nun kommen soll. Und das Ganze hat jetzt auch einen Namen, also ist nach wie vor unter tensecomplement.com zu holen und das Produkt heißt jetzt Cevo und kommt dann in verschiedenen Farben.
Und zwar... Bronze und Platinum und Gold und Silver.
Silver, Gold, Platinum und Developer. Also als ob Developer sozusagen noch mal so Beyond Platinum.
Da stehen dann aber nicht mehr mehr Preise dran bei Platinum.
Das Hauptproblem mit diesen Versionen ist, erstmal gibt es nur eine und auch die ist noch nicht zu haben, aber da steht Januar 2012, das heißt heute Aufnahme, 18. Januar, es kann sich jetzt eigentlich nur noch um maximal zwei Wochen handeln, so er denn sein Versprechen einhält.
Die sind bestimmt pünktlich Softwareentwicklung.
Und man kann wohlgemerkt für den wirklich überraschend niedrigen Preis von nur 30 Dollar sich da diese Software kaufen, installieren und dann kann das LQS-Turnen, ZFS, zumindest, wie sie sagen, für Single Volumes. Oder Single, was sagen sie? Ich guck noch mal kurz, wie sie das formulieren. Blablabla. Wo steht denn das überhaupt?
Also für ein Mac Pro empfehlen sie die Gold Edition. Für 50 Dollar.
Genau, im Sinne von mehrere Platten. Also wenn du jetzt nur so ein Mac Mini hast, wo du so ein großes Device drauf hast, dran hast, drin hast, ich weiß gar nicht, also was sie hier nicht sagen ist, ob sie davon booten können.
Also ich warte da auch erst mal, also sowieso, also ich hab jetzt nicht unbedingt den Drang, dass auf dem Mac OS mir da irgendwelche Software zu kaufen und dann meinen Mac OS damit aufzuflanschen und zu hoffen, dass es geht, aber ich...
Naja, also ich würde ja gerne, was ich wirklich tempting finde, auch wenn ich da eher auf diese Platinum-Edition wahrscheinlich warten muss, die dann auch mit mehreren Platten klarkommt, wäre halt so eine Konfiguration, wo du dir ein Mac Mini nimmst und da per Thunderbolt... Dir da irgendwie so einen Platten-Array ranballerst, was aber so JBOD ist, just a bunch of Discs. Und dann kommt halt das ZFS und...
Macht dir mal...
Takes care of it. Und macht dir halt mal ein ordentliches Fallsystem, mal so richtig schön durchbitten. Und das Ganze benutzt du dann eben als Time Machine. Mit Deduplication. Weil das ist das halt, was fehlt. Es fehlt halt Time Machine mit Deduplication. Und das wäre die einzige Möglichkeit, die mir derzeit kommt, wie man das haben könnte. Das heißt, du kannst beliebig fette Dateien duplizieren, rumkopieren und das ist das, was ich hier die ganze Zeit tue. Ich nehme irgendwas auf, dann kopiere ich das auf eine andere Platte und dann, was weiß ich, mache ich noch mal eine Sicherheitskopie davon oder sonst irgendwas. Und am laufenden Meter habe ich irgendwie dieselben Daten und sie belegen dann halt immer wieder noch Platz und ein Backup dauert dann halt immer wieder. Jede Stunde erzählt er mir, dass er dann drei Gigabyte sichern muss. Das ist dann auf so einer Time Capsule.
Der Wahnsinn!
Das ist echt beklopper. Träumen.
Ja, wir warten es mal ab. Mal gucken.
Aber es sieht ganz schnieke aus, auch so mit so einer GUI-Software dabei, um den ganzen Foo zu administrieren. Irgendwo waren hier Sachen. Und dann gibt es noch diese Developer-Edition, die das Feature hat, dass sie keine Features hat. Was hast du da alles auf Kommandozeile machen kannst? Da kannst du einen Screenshot, der einfach nur Terminal ist. Aber da kannst du dann einfach alles machen. Das ist quasi so richtig das nackte ZFS, so wie das Hardcore-FreeBSD-User oder Solaris-User natürlich vor allem kennen.
Wobei die Solaris-User, die haben ja auch eine GUI dafür. Also die FreeBSD, da sind vor allen Dingen die... Die FreeBSD, da sind die Harten.
Alle Daten weg mit einem Wisch.
So Häschen, jetzt kannst du mal ein Thema einbringen.
Mein Thema? Ich hab viele Themen. Aber das Aktuellste von allen, was euch jetzt total aus den Winkeln blasen wird und ihr euch den Geifer kam aus den Mundwinken wischen könnt, so schnell wie er fließt, ich hab jetzt auch ein iPad. Ich sag euch, das ist der Wahnsinn. Ja, natürlich. Und jetzt ist es halt so, ich weiß, ihr habt alle schon ein iPad. Langweilig. Nein, aber ich fand's ja tatsächlich ganz spannend. Insofern, als das für das iPhone, hab ich zwar ein paar Apps gekauft, aber meine Benutzung, also ich benutze nicht so viele Apps da auf dem Phone tatsächlich. Außer Twitter und so.
Jetzt will ich mal sagen, warum du dir ein iPad gekauft hast.
Ich hab's ja nicht gekuft. Habe ich ja geschenkt gekriegt von der Firma.
Ja, aber warum hast du dir das geschenkt lassen und nicht irgendwas anderes?
Na ich hab ja ein iPhone 4 und 4S hat mich noch nicht so gekickt, wie jetzt mal auch ein iPad haben.
Das war so ein Weihnachtsgeschenk quasi.
Naja, die Firma hier, wo ich arbeite, die macht da so Spiele und die machen jetzt auch Spiele auf iOS, damit alle Mitarbeiter auch mitreden können, haben alle Mitarbeiter mal ein iOS gekriegt. Genau. Aber jetzt habe ich ja irgendwie über die Feiertage ja hunderte und tausende Euro ausgegeben für alle möglichen Apps, habe mal voll den Max gemacht und einfach alles installiert, was nicht bei drei auf den Bäumen war. Und habe da jetzt sozusagen, also ich habe vor allen Dingen aber auch Spiele ausprobiert. Aber so ein paar Sachen sind mir aufgefallen. Zum Beispiel, weil es mich jetzt als allererstes mal abgesehen von den Spielen geschockt hat, da ist ja gar keine Alarmuhr drauf. Ja, das stimmt. Und kein Calculator, da bin ich echt hin und übergefallen. Weil ich wollte so dieses Klischee erfüllen, in der Küche stehen, ja, macht mal ein lecker Rezeptchen auf und dann stellt man sich den Timer und dann so... 30 Screens durchwische. Auf dem iPad hast du ja keinen Siri. Und dann hab ich mal geguckt, was es im App-Store so für Uhren-Applikationen gibt. Da bin ich ja tatsächlich hart, so ähnlich wie mit Kalender-Software, aber Uhren ist ja jetzt fast noch simpler. Das ist wirklich eine totale Katastrophe. Es gibt nichts, was nur ansatzweise an die iPhone-Alarm-Klok herankommt, an Simplicität, Eleganz und Funktionalität. Und die wollen alle auch noch Geld dafür haben oder ballern dir irgendwelche Werbung rein. Das fand ich schon mal echt schockierend. Und dann iPad-Spiele-Maschine, dachte ich mir. Da gibt es ja echt viele Spiele, die auf dem iPad einfach viel cooler werden, viel cooler sind, wegen größer und mehr Fläche und nicht so fitzlig klein und so. Und dann habe ich ja echt viel Zeit damit verbracht, Spiele zu suchen, die cool sind auf dem iPad. Und ich habe schon so viel gehört und ich habe ja auch hier von dir Getaway und so und ein, zwei andere Spiele mal installiert. Aber habe festgestellt, dass es auf dem iPad echt nicht wirklich viele coole Spiele gibt. Also es ist wirklich, man kann es fast an zwei Händen abzählen. Also das eine Spiel, was ich gefunden habe, was richtig, richtig cool war, aber das auch nicht alleine fürs iPad ist, heißt Machinarium. Und das ist so ein Click-and-Point-Adventure. Nee, nicht Adventure, sagt man dazu Adventure? Doch, ich glaube schon. Das ist eigentlich ein Spiel, das für ein PC rausgekommen ist oder für Mac auch. Ich glaube, es ist sogar eine Flex-Applikation. Die haben das halt auch auf iPad und es gibt es auch im Mac App Store. Machinarium, total tolles Spiel. Das habe ich zufälliger, ich habe gleich am ersten Tag halt getwittert, so Jungs, gib mir mal Spieletipps. Und da war gleich einer der Mobile-Macs-Follower dabei und hat dieses Machinarium gefeaturet. Und wenn ihr gerade zuhört, nochmal vielen Dank. Weil das war wirklich ein extrem gutes Spiel.
Ich glaube, das haben wir auch schon mal erwähnt.
Ach, dieses Spiel, oh Gott, das ist, das ist sau cool.
Ist das mittlerweile besser geworden?
Auf dem iPad spielt sich das echt gut.
Ich hab das runtergeladen, ich hab's gekauft. Okay, mittlerweile hat's gute Kritiken. Dann hab ich die 1.0 gekauft.
Ja, die 1.0 hatte Probleme, genau.
Die hatte nicht Probleme.
Das ging gar nicht. So wie ich's gelesen hab zumindest.
Die hatte oben, also man musste safen. Also, es war unglaublich langsam. Also wirklich, hier steht auch iPad 2 only und sowas. Ach, echt nur für 8?
Ach so, das ist dieses Flash-Teil.
Genau, das ist ein Flash-Teil. Und wenn du den Home-Button gedrückt hast, warst du tot und hast auch kein Safe-Game gehabt. Dann konntest du nicht weitermachen.
Egal, das Spiel ist gut. Also die Illustrationen sind super, die Puzzle sind super. Das ist wirklich qualitativ, so vom Content her, ist das eines der tollsten Spiele, die ich seit langem überhaupt gesehen hab. Und auf dem iPad im Vergleich verblasst alles, was du sonst in der Hinsicht kriegst.
Nein, vielleicht in der Hinsicht.
Ja, nicht nur in der Hinsicht. Das zweite Spiel, was bei mir und meiner Freundin auch echt, also komplett durchgespielt wurde innerhalb kürzester Zeit einfach aus, weil es so cool gemacht ist, ist Gesundheit. Bei dem Spieltitel bin ich ja erstmal so ein bisschen abgeschreckt. Das ist wirklich ganz, ganz großartig auch. Gesundheit, Gesundheit mit Ausrufezeichen, ist glaube ich von, lass mich nicht lügen, von wem ist es denn, EA? Nee, von Konami. Es war da oben links.
Gesundheit HD.
Ja genau, immer die iPad-Version. Das ist auch richtig liebevoll gemacht, super coole Grafik, super cooler Sound, coole Puzzle und da ist zum Beispiel sowas wie Wo ist mein Wasser? oder dieses Aquarium. Das ist dagegen richtig, also das ist nicht schlecht, aber das ist wirklich Dimensionen besser. Also es ist wirklich High Quality Spiel TM. Von wem ist denn das, von welchem Publisher oder welcher Bude steht das hier irgendwo? Also wirklich total geile Musik auch teilweise. Also ähnlich wie bei Machinarium, wo auch zwischendurch coole Musik kommt und hier ist auch der Soundtrack und die Sounds richtig cool. Schöne Puzzle, kreatives Spiel.
Gesundheit. Warum heißt das Gesundheit?
Na, weil das die Monster sind halt so, du rotzt da die ganze Zeit auch rum und so. Das ist schon...
Muss man auch ein bisschen sabbern und schleimen und so.
Ja, und die Monster, die freuen sich über den Schleim und essen den auf und so. Also das wirklich, glaubt's mir, diese 2,39€...
Es machen sich jetzt wirklich nur noch so Nischen auf, wo man es vorher nicht für möglich gehalten hatte. Über NSFW schrieben uns hier auch irgendwie auch die Developer von City of Toilets.
Ich glaube, das ist aber doch eine ganz andere Liga.
Es kann gut sein, ich hab's nicht gespielt, keine Ahnung, hier sitzt so ein bisschen so E-Boy... Wie heißt die nochmal gleich hier aus?
Pixel... Was?
E-Boy, ja.
E-Boy, genau.
E-Boy Style. Keine Ahnung, aber muss man sich hier ums Close kümmern.
Nee, wir spielen mal gesund, das ist cooler. Und dann zwei andere Spiele, die eigentlich so ziemlich das Gleiche sind, aber die erstaunlicherweise wirklich großartig auf dem iPad sind, scheiße alt sind und trotzdem die Konkurrenz gnadenlos stehen lassen. Monkey Island 1 und 2 Special Edition auf dem iPad. Auf dem iPhone total the Suck, weil die Steuerung einfach auf dem iPhone, ich weiß nicht warum...
Zwei Special Edition und die anderen sind nicht gut, weil die ist ja alles voll mit.
Ne, ne, nimm mal hier. Also das da oben hier, genau, das ist der zweite Teil und davon gibt's dann eben noch hier den Klassiker. Und dann, du kannst halt mit dem Swipe auch zwischen der 8-Bit-Grafik und der neuen Special Edition Grafik umschalten und sie haben es halt neu, also sie haben es vertont.
Das heißt, es handelt sich um dasselbe Spiel, ohne Änderungen, außer dass sie die Grafik neu gemacht haben.
Sie haben alles neu gezeichnet und vertont. Und du kannst auch noch zum alten Mode zurückswischen mit dem Swipe.
Und die Bedienung ist ein bisschen anders, wie du siehst. Also da hast du ja in deinem Screenshot, den du da hast, da ist links die neue, also unten die Bedienelemente sind auch ein bisschen anders.
Das heißt, wenn man das alte Spiel noch kann, dann gibt es eigentlich gar nichts Neues.
Genau.
Aber ich hab das auch gespielt vor, wann kam das raus, 1991 oder so? Oder ist jetzt nur zwei da? Nein, Teil 1 gibt es auch.
Und der ist nicht gut.
Doch, der ist auch gut, hab ich doch gesagt. Teil 1 und 2.
Sind beide gut.
Sind beide sehr gut sogar.
Was ist hier mit Tales?
Ja, das sind halt immer so, das ist doch bei ganz vielen Spielen so, dass dann irgendwelche Rip-Off-Typis ankommen und dir dann irgendwie den Walkthrough noch für 99 Cent verkaufen und irgendwelche irritierenden Namen dazu...
Ach, so ein Scheiß ist das hier, ja? Mehr als das Spiel und so.
Genau, hier mach mal den, das zweite... Wo ist denn dann das hier?
Okay, gut, na dann linken wir mal genau nur das Richtige hier.
Und die Sache ist halt, ich hab das echt vor ewigen Zeiten gespielt, ich kann mich noch erinnern, wie ich mit meinen Kumpels früher vor dem Rechner irgendwie gefühlte Monate versucht hab, das rauszufinden, weil damals gab's ja noch kein Internet mit Walkthroughs und so.
Auf welcher Plattform lief das überhaupt?
Na, das gab's auf dem Mac, das gab's auf PC, das gab's, glaub, gab's das auch für... Monkey Island gab's für Mac? Das war von LucasArts, die haben auch für Mac released.
Ja, aber wann gab's das?
1991 kam's original raus.
Auf dem Mac?
Nein, warte mal.
Für Mac kam's wie immer später, aber es kam auf dem Mac. Ich hab's auf dem Mac auch gespielt. Warte, jetzt gucken wir. Wenn man... Ach Gott, ich hab wieder JavaScript angemacht, jetzt geht die Wikipedia nicht. Ähm, warte, Moment. So.
Der Dackel meint, dass Tales of Monkey Island kein Walkthrough wäre, sondern sehr spielenswert.
Also hier steht, Original Version gab's für Mac OS und die Original Version kam 1990 raus. Angeblich. Also ich hab das auch damals in dieser alten Grafik auf dem Mac gespielt, das weiß ich noch genau. Anyway, ich hab jetzt also bestimmt 15 Jahre dieses Spiel nicht mehr gespielt und dachte mir aus Verzweiflung, weil ich hab wirklich lange, ich hab Nächte damit verbracht, den App Store nach coolen Spielen zu suchen, ich hab mir auch echt viele installiert und ich wollte nach Machinarium eigentlich noch mehr so ne coolen Puzzle-Click-Adventures mit Story. Und dann hab ich halt gesagt, okay, fuck it, lass mal Monkey Island nochmal installieren. Das ist so großartig, das ist so lustig, das macht so Spaß. Ich hab halt viele Lösungen einfach vergessen, so dass ich auch wieder also ich wusste zwar so die ganze Zeit, mir lag die Lösung auf der Zunge quasi, hier war ich doch, wie war denn das? Da musste man noch irgendwie, hmmm. Und die Wortgefechte, die ganzen Sprüche, die da drin sind, die Puzzle, das ist echt großartig. Also die Kohle hab ich auch echt nicht bereut. Und im Vergleich zu den ganzen anderen Spielen, die ich mir installiert hab, zum Beispiel jetzt, was gerade so gehyped wird, dieses Swords & Sorcery, so ein 8-Bit-Spiel auch mit awesome Soundtrack und so, das ist optisch ganz schön. Und der Soundtrack ist auch wirklich toll, wenn man Kopfhörer auf hat, aber die Story ist halt so flach und hohl und uninspiriert, dass man auch überhaupt gar nicht weiß, was man da soll. Also Swords & Sorcery von Superbrothers oder so heißt das.
Also ich hab ja Monkey Island, damals hab ich es nicht gespielt, weil ich einen Mac hatte.
Find ich hier nicht.
Warte mal, ich such dir das.
Dann hab ich es irgendwann Jahre später mal probiert und ich glaub ich bin gleich auf dem zweiten Screen einfach hoffnungslos verzweifelt und nicht weitergekommen und hab es dann sein lassen.
Auf Sword to Sword gibt es hier nur als Buch.
Nee, wie heißt denn das? Ich guck einfach mal in meine Ups hier rein. Wo sind die iPad Ups? Sind die nicht irgendwo rum?
Viele sind das ja nicht.
Nee, da sind ja auch viele, die für beides gehen.
Gib doch da einfach mal Sword ein oder den Namen.
Ach hier, Superbrothers.
Ach das Ding.
Superbrothers, wieso zeigt der jetzt den Titel nicht an?
Mach doch mal einen Doppelklick drauf.
Mach ich doch auch die ganze Zeit.
Ach so, das hier. Sword, Ach so, Sword Ampersand.
Ach ja, Sworcery, genau. Und das ist von der Grafik her und so, das ist für 8-Bit haben die wirklich das Maximum, was im 21. Jahrhundert so geht, rausgeholt. Aber so Monkey Island ist einfach sehr viel cooler. Und ja, Monkey Island ist schwer. Also ich hab auch, als ich angefangen hab zu spielen, im ersten Teil, erstmal ewig lange gebraucht. Aber das Coole ist, es ist einfach echt cool. Die haben sich echt viele coole Sachen einverlassen. Und da sind halt Sprüche drin, die man so kennt. Und die sind einfach, teilweise echt einfach, glaube ich, aus Monkey Island. Die haben sich so in den allgemeinen Sprachgebrauch eingebürgert.
Das Einzige, wovon ich jetzt mittlerweile gelernt habe, ist, schau, hinter dir ein dreiköpfiger Affe.
Ja, das ist der Klassiker, genau. Aber zum Beispiel gibt es dann halt auch mittendrin so Sprüche, wie ist das, eine Banane in deiner Tasche, oder freust du dich, mich zu sehen und dergleichen...
Ich glaub, der ist aber echt.
Ich weiß schon. Aber das kommt halt so zwischendurch. Du bist gerade so am Puzzlen und dabei ein Pirat zu werden, und dann drückt dir so ein anderer Pirat mal gerade so einen Spruch in die Richtung. Oder die Wortgefechte, die legendären aus Monkey Island, wo man halt, wo der Clou ist. Okay, du musst jetzt Schwertfechten lernen und dann erzählt dir aber der Schwertmeister, ja, das kommt gar nicht aufs Fechten an, sondern auf die coolen Sprüche und die Kontersprüche, die du da beim Schwertfechten von dir lässt. Und du musst ja dann gegen den Schwertmeister antreten und musst immer auf seinen Spruch die richtige Antwort, also den richtigen Konterparat haben und so.
Sozusagen so Rap-Battle.
Ja, aber halt auf der Pirateninsel beim Schwertmeister und das ist echt liebevoll gemacht und schön.
Verstehe, in der Piratenpartei funktioniert das ja auch glaube ich noch genauso.
Genau. Und das waren so die vier Spiele, also K-Monkey Allen 1 und 2.
Ich weiß, jetzt bin ich schon wieder total unten durch bei allen, aber das ist völlig an mir vorbeigegangen. Also ich hab wirklich bis vor kurzem, bis Leute das immer wieder so aus ihrer Vergangenheit ausgekramt haben, wusste ich überhaupt nicht, dass es das gibt.
Ja, ich weiß.
Ich hab die ganzen Nicknames nicht verstanden.
Ich kann das auch verstehen, aber damals irgendwie hatten wir nichts anderes. Damals hatten wir ja nichts anderes. Da haben wir halt mit Kumpel zu zweit oder zu dritt davor gesessen und das halt über Wochen versucht zu spielen. Dann hat sich das einfach auch so ins Hirn gefräst und jetzt...
Ich bin auch bei diesen ganzen Rätselspielen zu schnell frustriert.
Ja, aber es macht auch Spaß, wenn du zwischendurch mal noch mal kurz in den Walkthrough guckst. Habe ich jetzt auch bei dem zweiten Teil schon mal reingeguckt, weil ich dachte, ich habe keinen Bock jetzt zwei Stunden lang da rumzusuchen. Und dann macht es halt trotzdem Spaß, weil die Story cool ist, weil die Sprüche cool sind, die Rätsel und so.
Ich werde es mal ausprobieren.
Probier es mal aus. Danke, Island1.
Mal wieder ein gründes iPad.
Hast du hier Lost Wines bei deinen runtergeladenen Dingsen dabei?
Lost was?
Lost Wines. Das ist so ein Spiel, das habe ich... Also ich habe es mir jetzt auf dem iPad gekauft, aber noch gar nicht gespielt. Also ich glaube, es funktioniert wesentlich besser. Das war damals so eines der ersten Spiele, die man sich für die Wii runterladen konnte, für relativ kleines Geld. Und das ist eigentlich so ganz putzig gemacht, finde ich.
Lost Wines.
Hat auf jeden Fall sehr schöne Grafik. Die Story war, glaube ich, ganz okay.
Eine Sache noch zu dem iPad.
Was heißt denn das, wenn die Story ganz okay ist?
Ich weiß es einfach nicht mehr.
Was meint man denn damit?
Ich habe da ein paar Stunden ganz nett gespielt.
Habt ihr da bei Spielen eigentlich denselben Anspruch an die Story wie bei Filmen?
Na ja, also bei so Action, keine Ahnung was spielen, brauch ich keine Story, aber bei so Adventures, Adventure, was heißt Story?
Wo ist mein Wasser, spiele ich nur wegen der zusammenhängenden Charaktere.
Aber das ist halt das Gleiche. Mein Gottfather zum Beispiel, der Pate ist ja so hoch gewertet als Film oder hoch anerkannt, weil einfach Schauspieler, Kamera, Drehbuch, Szenerie einfach alles top sind. Also das alles vom Feinsten im Prinzip. Und wenn das natürlich bei Software oder bei Spielen auch so zusammenkommt, wie bei Gesundheit, Grafik toll, Soundtrack toll, Idee toll, Titelscheiße. Titelscheiße, okay, ja. Ich war auch erst mal irritiert, aber es ist wirklich cool. Wenn sie auch Rotz und Wasser nennen können. Weil zum Beispiel bei, wie gesagt, bei ganz vielen, zum Beispiel Hellsing Fire, das war auch so ein Spiel, was irgendwie iTunes mir über die Weihnachtstage ans Herz legen wollte.
Was ist da super?
Er hat nach 10 Puzzlen hast du dich da in die Langeweile gepuzzelt, weil es immer das gleiche ist. Da passiert nichts Neues, außer jetzt mal ein neuer Monstertyp und so, aber das ist halt...
Ja, aber dafür spiele ich das. Also ich meine, ich fände so was so...
Ich hol mal das hier mal an, was ich hier gerade erzeugt habe.
Also ich hab, hier Hellsing Fire habe ich dann auch nicht ewig weiter gespielt, aber...
Das ist iTunes übrigens gerade auch.
Hast du es geschafft ohne CSS zu laden?
Ich hab es geschafft im App Store hier ohne CSS. Ich weiß nicht, ob das alles HTML ist.
Also der App Store, da müssen sie immer wieder ran. Das ist nicht gut.
So geht's ja nun.
Tim, jetzt noch was für dich von meinem kleinen iPad-Exkurs. Du hast ja diesen Bamboo-Stylus, hast du nicht gesehen, gekauft zum Malen. Jetzt dachte ich mir so, iPad, Mensch, tolle Sache, weil, habe ich gerecherchiert, gibt es ja tatsächlich Pro-Zeichenprogramme auf dem iPad. Namentlich hat jetzt so sich bei mir als Gewinner oder bei meiner Freundin vor allen Dingen, die da rumgezeichnet hat, das Sketchbook Pro etabliert. Wobei die anderen, was war das, Procreate und Brushes sind im Prinzip auch nicht weit weg. Aber das Sketchbook Pro war so bisher das, was am besten Ergebnisse geliefert hat.
Auch von Autodesk?
Genau. Die haben halt auch eine Desktop-Software, die so heißt im Prinzip. Und das ist sozusagen die iPad-Umsetzung davon. Und dann haben wir da mal fröhlich drauf losgemalt. Und das Coole ist, was ich noch nicht wusste vorher, dass diese Malprogramme mittlerweile ebenen können. Und du kannst die Ebenen als Photoshop-Dokumente dann exportieren. Dann hast du in Photoshop deine ganzen Mal-Ebenen drin und so. Allerdings, der Effekt, der sich jetzt eingestellt hat, durch das iPad-Malen und so, versuchen mal die Visionen von, wie heißt das, wie hieß der Typ, der Sketchpad gemacht hat? Irgendwas Iverson, Iverson? Ja, klick mal auf YouTube-Code Sketchpad. Kennste Tim, das ist hier dein Metier vom vorm Krieg. Even Sutherland. So mal das Sketchpad und... Ja, das sieht schon manchmal Ton aus. Also wenn du Sketchpad suchst, reicht. Nee, ohne Pro, einfach nur Sketchpad. So, und jetzt der zweite, hier das erste gleich, das da.
Ach, das?
Ja, uralt.
Okay, alles klar.
Aber das ist es ja, was du jetzt... Aber im Prinzip, wenn du jetzt mal ein bisschen vor-skippst in dem Video, wenn er dann da auf dem Ding malt, das ist ja im Prinzip, was du jetzt mit dem iPad und so einem Bamboo Stylus hast. Du hast ein Display, du hast einen Stift, du malst da drauf und du siehst, was du malst und transformierst das live. Weil vorher, Vakuum-Grafiktabletts, hast du das Pad unten, guckst auf den Bildschirm und siehst es nicht. Aber jetzt habe ich halt so diesen, weil der Bamboo Stylus, auf dem iPad diese Stifte sind halt schon extrem unpräzise noch. Und sie laggen auch ziemlich hinterher. Also wenn du in so einem Malprogramm malst, dann ist es halt immer so ein laggy feeling. Hat jetzt eigentlich dazu geführt, dass meine Freundin jetzt so ein Vakuum-Tablet, jetzt gibt es ja diese großen 24 Zoll Cintiq HD, heißen die? Die sind großartig, das haben Kollegen von mir, also Grafiker in der Firma. Cintiq, also C-I-N-I-Q. C-I-N-I-Q, Cintiq. Ne, Cintiq heißen die, glaube ich. Warte mal, ich suche mal kurz, warte. Cintiq 24 HD heißt das. Und das ist im Prinzip noch mehr das, was wir jetzt hier bei Sketchpad vor 40 oder 50 Jahren sehen. Hat jetzt Vakuum Ende des letzten Jahres halt ein 24 Zoll, Full HD, Display, ich nehm mal Products einfach direkt. Ja, oder guck dir das Video an, oder was auch immer. Aber auf vakuum.com sieht es schon besser aus.
Wenn man da jetzt hinklickt, dann klickst du halt nochmal auf.
So, und du hast halt so einen 20 Kilo schweren Fuß dazu und kannst dieses Display halt so frei hin und her schieben, hoch oder runter. Und das Video sieht auch echt schick aus. Und das hab ich jetzt halt in der Firma auch in echt schon zu verstehen. Und so will man, glaube ich, als Grafiker oder als Illustrator oder was auch immer arbeiten. Weil dann hast du eben so eine Applikation wie dieses Sketchbook, wo du eben in Layern zeichnen kannst und irgendwie auch wirklich...
Heißt das 24, weil es 24 Zoll sind? Das sieht doch viel größer aus.
Nee, es ist 24 Zoll. Und dann kannst du es halt mit diesen Wippen da an der Seite, kannst du es halt nehmen und auch einfach runterziehen oder in die Horizontale bringen und...
Das scheint mir hier so ein bisschen über... Im Video scheint mir das so ein bisschen...
Na vielleicht ist der Typ einfach...
Das sieht doch aus wie 30 Zoll.
Da ist halt noch so viel Rahmen drum herum.
Das geile ist halt...
Aber das geile ist halt, wie bei diesem Video von Sketchpad, also guckt auf YouTube, wenn ihr wissen wollt, wovon ich rede. Bei diesem Sketchpad hat er halt an der Seite Hardware-Controls. Also er hat ja so ein Hardware-Button-Menü, um den Modus auszuwählen von dem, was er mit dem Stift macht. Und genau das hast du halt bei diesem Cintiq Vacom Tablet, hast du das auch. Du hast so ein, wie beim iPod früher, so ein Jog-Dial oder so ein Touch-Wheel, wo du zum Beispiel, wenn du gerade deine Brush in Photoshop ausgewählt hast, kannst du an diesem Touch-Wheel halt die Größe ändern oder die Brush-Patterns durchscrollen und so weiter. Und im Prinzip ist so dieses Vacom Tablet echt die wahrgewordene Vision von 1963 von Ivan Sutherland. Und das war halt irgendwie die Realisierung, als ich dann mit dem iPad und so da beim Malen rumhantierte. Und das war halt nicht so ganz das Richtige. Und dann irgendwie hat an dem Tag auch der Kollege gleich das neue Display bekommen.
Das ist aber wirklich eine unfassbare Demo, ne?
Ja, also für 1963 ist es wirklich krass. Das ist wirklich unglaublich.
Dieser Alan Kay hat eigentlich das iPad komplett vorher gesehen.
Aber Alan Kay hält ja nur einen Vortrag über diesen Even Sutherland, ne?
Ja, okay, aber er hat ja auch noch seine eigenen Videos, wo er dann auch im Prinzip genau das iPad auch vorher sieht. Wie hieß das nochmal bei ihm? Das Alan Kay's Vision von dem, was das iPad letztlich erfüllt. Deiner Bock. Deiner Bock. Das ist halt seine Vision. Also diese ganze Bande von Visionären.
Ja, nee, aber das...
Alan Kay hab ich mal persönlich kennengelernt.
Ich hab gesehen, dass...
An der Uni. Da wurde er mal als Preisträger, Honorarprofessor, irgendwie eingeladen worden.
Und so.
Da war ich mal mit ihm in einem Raum.
Ich hab gesehen, dass er in der Wikipedia, ich gesehen, dass er schon 71 ist. Das ist auch schon krass.
Ja, das ist auch immer wieder schockierend, dass so die ganzen Veteranen nicht jünger werden.
Naja, auf jeden Fall war das so mein kleiner Ausflug in die Welt des iPads. So irgendwie große Enttäuschung, dass es keine Alarmuhr gibt. Ein bisschen Enttäuschung, dass das Malen auf dem iPad zwar ganz cool ist, aber einfach zu unpräzise und laggy. Und dann froh, dass ich Makinarium gefunden hab und Gesundheit und Monkey Island.
Gesundheit, das war doch das Wichtigste überhaupt im neuen Jahr. Aber ich frag mich bei diesen ganzen Kochbuch-Apps, warum die nicht einfach einen Timer eingebaut haben. Weißt du, das steht 10 Minuten, dann drückst du drauf, 10 Minuten, dann stellt er einen Timer auf 10 Minuten.
Hast du mal sowas wie Flipboard ausprobiert? Flipboard oder... Wie heißt das andere?
Dieses Notizprogramm oder was?
Nee, Flipboard ist so dieses sammelt aus Facebook und Twitter und so, da die ganzen Links zusammen und macht die ein bisschen hübsch.
Hab ich noch nicht probiert.
Wie heißt ja noch mal dieses andere, was ähnlich funktioniert wie Flipboard? Da gibt's noch so eine andere. Na verdammt.
Das hieß irgendwie... Also ich find...
Ich guck gerade mal, was ich hier auf dem iPad so installiert habe. Jetzt wo du das Thema aufgebracht hast, weil ich hab ja selbe Probleme.
Aber Flipboard gibt's ja mittlerweile auch fürs iPhone.
Ja, da ist es auch recht gut gemacht. Aber das ist immer noch nicht meine Art von Lesen. Aber wer so sonntags beim Frühstück in der Zeitung blättern geil findet, der könnte auch an Flipboard Freude haben.
Das hängt halt immer davon ab, was man gerade... Also ich lese ja sowohl meinen Reader-Layer als auch, dass ich über Twitter surfe. Aber manchmal hab ich auch einfach Bock, Flipboard aufzumachen. Das ist so... Da kann man so schön durchblättern und so ein bisschen drüber gucken und...
Die tollste iPad-App, die ich überhaupt gekauft hab, war Zapfservice.
Von diesem Umzugsladen?
Ich hab mir ein Angebot für ein Transport von Möbelstück machen lassen, dann bin ich auf die Zapf-Webseite gegangen und mir hinten übergefallen, was das für eine Ausgeburt der User-Interface- Katastrophenhölle ist. Also wirklich, das hast du noch nicht gesehen. Also Fünf-Jährige, die ihr erstes Bild auf dem Magna-Doodle malen, kriegen bessere User-Interfaces hin, als Zapf auf ihrer Webseite. Und dann hab ich gesehen, dass sie eine abhammen und dann hab ich mir die runtergeladen und dann konnte man tatsächlich da so ein Formular ausfüllen und abschicken und dann hat das auch geklappt, aber...
Geil, jetzt hab ich ja auch kein CSS mehr im App-Store. Das muss ja an deinem Netz liegen, ne?
Wie hieß denn das? Hast du Osmos schon mal ausprobiert? Ist das was für dich? Osmos HD dann auf dem iPad? Falls irgendwelche Entwickler zuhören, könnt ihr das mit diesem HD einfach mal sein lassen? Macht dieses Scheiß ab, so dass sie auf dem iPhone und auf dem iPad laufen. Aber nicht dieses HD, nicht HD, das ist einfach...
Also, ja, da geb ich dir auf jeden Fall recht. Aber hier Osmos, ich hab's gesehen, ich hab's auf dem Radar, ich hab auch gesehen, dass sie extrem viele gute Bewertungen haben, aber irgendwie hat mich die Optik so bisher nicht so gekickt.
Also da hat mich ein Level wirklich aggressiv gemacht. Das war...
Was ist das denn?
Der Osmos macht Spaß. Was hat auch Flash dafür? Max wollte die ausgebührte Hässlichkeit sehen.
Ah, ihr schreibt aber noch mal unten netterweise die Flash-Version, die man hat daneben.
Ja, also Osmos war ja noch so ein Kandidat, aber jetzt bin ich halt gerade mit Monkey Island ausgelastet und ich bin jetzt schon bei Teil 2.
Machst du auch so Autorennen und so?
Nee, mag ich früher gerne, aber mittlerweile...
Du hast nicht gelogen, ich bin gerade auf Seite 4 der Anleitung, fünf. Fünf Seiten Anleitung, bevor es losgeht.
Ja, das wird noch besser.
Ah, dann muss ich hier den Pfeil drücken, wahrscheinlich.
Nee, das ist geil, ne?
Dann kommt der LKW unten reingefahren. Wie? Und das ist jetzt das Formular, was mir da ausführlich erklärt worden ist? Warte mal, ich mach nochmal von vorne hier. So, ich geh nochmal auf die Seite, jetzt lade ich nochmal einen Flashfilm, siehst du, jetzt kommt hier die Hilfe so, und hier steht, wo die Pfeile sind, dann geht's auf weiterklicken, und dann nochmal weiter, und dann nochmal weiter. Ach so, ich dachte, er wollte sich...
Tim stellt die Uhrzeit ein. Ja, Autorennspiele gibt's ja auch, die sind schon ganz toll und so.
Nee, das ist so, ich wollte gerade einfach mal so dahin zeigen. Achso, könntet ihr mal... Max, kannst du auf diesem iPad hinter dir mal kurz so von unten nach oben wippen?
Was soll man auf dem Datum...
Ja, das ist auch noch eine schöne Anwendung, die ist auch universal. Die heißt einfach Atomuhr, in Klammern Gorgi-Timer, und das ist halt diese Gorgi-Uhr, die so in so, wie auch bei Fritz hängt, die in allen Radiostudios hängt. So LED-Style-Uhr. Die, wenn du sie neu im Original kaufst, irgendwie sinnlos viel Geld kostet. Du kannst ja auch irgendwie die Apje für zwei Euro kaufen, und dann hast du das halt auch auf dem iPad, und wenn du eh noch ein iPad rumliegen hast, mit dem du die Sachen machen kannst...
So ein iPad 1?
Ja, so was halt noch so rumfliegt. Meine beiden iPads sind halt beide so Experimental-Ipads. Die habe ich mir einfach nur so zum Spielen gekauft. Jetzt hängt das halt an der Wand, und jetzt habe ich aber diese Uhr. Das ist eigentlich auch ein schönes Ding.
Die behaupten in ihrer Anleitung, dass sie nicht die eingebaute Uhrzeit nehmen würden, sondern dass sie sich nach einer Atomuhr irgendwo richten würden. Genau. Wenn man da die total falsche Zeit einstellt, zeigt der trotzdem die richtige Zeit ein, oder ist das einfach kompletter Bullshit? Wenn man bei der Systemuhr die falsche Zeit einstellt?
Nee, der nimmt nicht die Systemuhr.
Macht er tatsächlich nicht?
Hast du das schon ausprobiert?
Am Anfang, beim Starten heißt das, dass er sich mit dem NTP-Server von einer physikalisch-technischen Bundesanstalt in Braunschweig verbindet. Und da hängt halt unsere Thäsiumuhr.
Was passiert, wenn man WLAN abschaltet?
Ohne Internet-Kinn.
Keine Zeit.
Also das Ding baut jetzt da keine Hardware an.
Ja, schon klar. Aber ich wollte wissen, ob die einfach nur so tun, als ob sie sich irgendwo die Zeit holen. Oder ob das gelogen ist, oder ob das wirklich der Wahrheit entspricht.
Also es entspricht auf jeden Fall nicht der eingespielten Systemuhr. Die kann anders sein. Das ist schon mal ganz gut. Das ist so die einfache Methode, eine verlässliche Uhr zu kriegen. Ja, hab ich noch einen Tipp für dich?
Na jetzt ist gerade der App Store eh im Arsch.
Sight meintest du, glaube ich, noch neben...
Neben Flipboard.
Das finde ich ja eher hässlich. Nee, das mag ich überhaupt nicht.
Ja, nee, mag ich gar nicht. Aber man muss halt schon sagen, es gibt auf jeden Fall auch echt viel Schrott in diesem App Store. Also es gibt auch ein paar coole Sachen, aber ich hab mir auch jetzt wirklich in diesem letzten Monat so viel Schrott-Apps installiert und wieder deinstalliert und...
Wissen Sie, als Kritiker muss ich mich mit so viel Dreck befassen. Grässlich. Eine grässliche App. Eine furchtbare, furchtbare Sache ist das.
Zum Beispiel ein Spiel, von dem ihr unbedingt Abstand halten solltet, auch wenn die Ratings gar nicht so schlecht sind und es irgendwie euch angepriesen wird. Puzzle Agent. Wenn ihr auf Puzzle Spiele steht und ihr seid verzweifelt und ihr installiert euch Puzzle Agent, löscht das gleich wieder. Das ist eins der Bekn... Also, Worte reichen gar nicht, um die Grausamkeit dieses Spiels zu beschreiben.
Du könntest es mit Lauten probieren.
Was ich noch nicht für ein Spiel... Welches Spiel ich mir empfohlen wurde, was ich dann aber ganz furchtbar fand, das war, wie hieß das, irgendwas mit so... da sind so kleine... Cover Orange HD.
Ja, das ist geil.
Ich find's furchtbar.
Cool, ja der Sound ist schrecklich, aber...
Könntest du das bitte mit Lauten beschreiben?
Das ist so, das ist so dieses, also man muss da irgendwelche Orangen davor beschützen, vom Frost getroffen zu werden oder vom Hagel oder irgendwie sowas. Das finde ich ja gar nicht schlimm. Aber nachdem man da... Hey Apple! Tim, du machst mir Angst.
Max kennt Annoying Orange nicht.
Nee, kenn ich nicht.
Annoying Orange, Annoying Orange ist vor allem Annoying. Echt, das kennst du nicht? Ich dachte, du bist memefest. Achso, Noyomi ist ja heute auch down oder was?
Nee, also was ich auf jeden Fall, bei dem Spiel find ich sehr nervig, dass man nach jedem Level, den man gelöst hat, erst warten muss, bis diese Blöde, also dass die, erst beten sie dann unten, dass sie auch nicht getroffen werden, und dann musst du warten, bis diese, du kannst das nicht beschleunigen, dass das durchgeht, dann wirst du da 30 Sekunden drauf.
Ich find's trotzdem ganz nett. Ich fand's auch erst ein bisschen, aber irgendwie haben mich die Puzzle dann doch angefixt, irgendwie fand ich's. Immer mal wieder so ein paar zwischendurch.
Und ein Spiel fand ich noch ganz unerträglich. Mal gucken, ob ich das jetzt finde.
Ich fand's auch so mutig, dass die halt so, das so bewusst halt mit diesen Sounds und so, also das ist ja...
Meinst du nicht, dass es einfach nur nicht besser gekonnt ist? Ich hatte ja noch so eins mit so einem Goldfisch, den man irgendwie...
Das wolltest du jetzt freundlich formulieren, Max...
.der irgendwo hochspringen musste, oder sowas, das war auch so.
Orange, you glad I didn't say Apple again?
Can you do 10 push-ups in 10 seconds?
What kind of question is that?
I don't even have arms.
How am I going to do one push-up?
Was hab ich noch hier verschwunden?
Och Mann, Apple Store, jetzt mach ich mal wieder deine CSS-Spreisekanzler.
Nen, nen, nen.
Noch so ein Spiel, wovon ihr die Finger lassen sollt. Hier. Ja, noch so eine Art, die man nicht installieren sollte, ist auf jeden Fall...
Was ist das denn?
Das sind so Süßigkeiten.
Das klingt auch so, als ob man es nicht interessieren sollte.
Das sieht ganz schön aus.
Achso, ja das sieht tatsächlich ganz hübsch aus.
Das ist auch so ein Kombinatorik-Spiel, aber es ist leider schlecht gemacht.
Und dieses Lumi HD, taugt das was?
Windowsill ist relativ kurz, nur Spielvergnügen, aber es ist auch mal so ein paar...
Langsam, wie hieß das?
Windowsill. Ne, davor. Lumi HD, aber das soll ich kaufen.
Ne, sag mir nicht, was man nicht kaufen soll.
Ja, wir machen die ganze Zeit noch, was man nicht kaufen soll. Windowsill.
Windowsill ist okay.
Klingt auch so nach so einem Fenster-Reiniger. Sill.
Das sind mal so ein paar... Also die Grafik ist ganz cool, das sind halt so ein paar putzige Puzzle und... Ich weiß nicht, was das kostet, weil der Apple Store gerade down ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich einen Kaufunmengst im Arsch... Ja, irgendwie krieg nur noch leere Formulare und so.
The App Store is down. The App Store is down!
The App Store is down. No, it's running. Kann man dich mal kurz rausfügen, Löwen, Elektro, Luft schnappen.
Na, das Memet, das habt ihr verstanden, oder?
Sind wir jetzt mit den Ups erstmal durch, oder?
Jaja, genug Ups.
Genug geabbt. Das hat den Tim gleich ganz gaga gemacht hier. Vielleicht sollen wir mal kurz mit Kalender ernten. Das misst deine Laune im Arsch.
Also wenn ihr jetzt keine weiteren iPad-Tipps habt, würde mich aber auch was anderes interessieren.
Ja, jetzt wird es in Ernsthaftigkeit.
Wenn ich dich so richtig zwischen den Zeilen lese, dann bist du auch so ein Typ, der eigentlich so mit dem iPad nichts anfangen kann.
So würde ich das jetzt nicht sagen.
Na, was würdest du denn sagen?
Also ich habe jetzt bekommen das iPad und mir war eigentlich von vornherein klar, ich werde damit hauptsächlich spielen.
Würdest du damit herumlaufen? Würdest du es mitnehmen?
Ich habe ja immer meinen Rechner dabei. Wenn ich jetzt auf eine Konferenz gehen würde, würde ich glaube ich das iPad mitnehmen, statt den Rechner. Weil? Weil ich will keinen Rechner auf dem Schoß haben und so. Also iPad ist okay. Mal kurz brausen, mal kurz Twitter. Ist ein bisschen zu klein manchmal. Also für bestimmte sind zum Beispiel Tippen. Tippen tut es sich auf dem iPad extrem fett. Also ich kann auf jeden Fall viel schneller und bequemer auf dem iPad tippen, zum Beispiel mal kurz Sachen aufschreiben und meine URL und so weiter und so fort. Und für sowas würde ich iPad mitnehmen. Oder wenn ich zur Oma fahre, Weihnachten oder keine Ahnung, weißt du schon, also es ist so ein Zuhausegerät für Rumliegen, ein Buch lesen nebenbei, was in der Wikipedia nachgucken, Wetterbericht brausen und spielen. Es ist also sonst so richtig nützlich. Abgesehen von diesen genannten Use-Cases kann ich mir jetzt erstmal nicht vorstellen. Also es ist jetzt für mich auf jeden Fall natürlich gar kein Computerersatz, weil wie ich schon sagte, lebe ich ja im Terminal. Und da ist man auf dem iPad, ja, ja, ja, es gibt Prompt und SSH und hast du nicht gesehen, nee, ich brauch Tasten. Für Terminal brauch ich Tasten. Ja und deswegen, also ich bin halt so rangegangen, ich benutze es zum Spielen vor allen Dingen und so zum Casual Browsing, wenn ich mal ein Buch lese oder so, dass ich dann mal schnell in der Wikipedia, weil ich will auch, wenn ich irgendwo rumliege und was lese, da will ich keinen Rechner irgendwie in der Nähe haben, das ist mir zu nervig und so ein iPad kannst du halt schön an die Seite mal kurz und wieder vorholen und Schnipp Schnapp und Wisch Wisch und so, so ein Casual Computer.
Okay, reden wir nochmal drüber, wenn du das ein paar Wochen mal auch wirklich so repeatedly in use hattest. Es gibt so viele Orte, wo ich immer dachte, wo man das iPad vielleicht benutzen würde, das ist dann aber doch nicht benutzt. Wie zum Beispiel, wo du es nicht benutzt.
Also ich hab das iPad tatsächlich hauptsächlich bisher nicht benutzt.
Ich kann nicht liegen und das iPad benutzen. Du kannst das iPad im Liegen nicht benutzen.
Doch.
Wieso nicht? Weil du es halt mit zwei Händen bedienen musst.
Du kannst es doch auf deinen Schoß legen und dann die Beine anwinkeln.
Also ich mach das immer so.
Ja, ich kann mich auf das iPad einstellen, ich will aber, dass das iPad sich auf mich einstellt. Denn ein iPhone macht das.
Du brauchst dann so ein...
Seitdem es den Porträt-Log gibt.
Du brauchst den Wesermount am Bett für das iPad, wo du dann so einen Arm...
Ich mein, meinen MacBook Air kann ich aufklappen und das liegt dann vertikal neben mir und ich kann so das iPad aufmachen.
Guck, so das legst du einfach so neben den Kopf und dann legst du dich auf die Seite und dann kannst du hier schön so...
Also jetzt hab ich es so, aber nur in einem einzigen Winkel. Außerdem auf so einem Bett, wo das immer so wackelt und wo du so drauf bist auf der Matratze, fällt dir das dann einfach...
Aber, es gibt so einen ähnlichen... Ja, ich hab den Link nicht im Kopf oder so, aber es gibt einen Sockel oder einen Fuß für das iPad, das so ähnlich funktioniert wie das Wacom-Tablet, wo du so ein 20-Kilo-Fuß auf dem Tisch hast und dann dieses Display, da ist total schön rum, bewegen kannst. Natürlich wiegt das jetzt für das iPad nicht 20 Kilo, aber es war so ein Ding, wo du in jedem Winkel halt und auch horizontal und vertikal konntest und so. Es gab es glaube ich auch sogar im Web-Apple Store.
Chat, tue mal was für dein Geld, chat.
Und das sah ganz gut aus. Ich war ja ROE und dann, Alter, Alter, war ich bei Gravis, dachte ich, kaufe ich mir meine iPad-Hülle, Tasche oder irgendwas. Am Ende hat sich jetzt meine Freundin...
Das ist beim Apple Store übrigens genauso. Das ist nicht besser.
Also meine Freundin hat sich dann einfach im Lederladen ein Stück Leder gekauft und hat dann selber eine iPad-Tasche genäht. Und die ist auch ziemlich gut geworden. Hat auch nur die Hälfte gekostet wie das da bei Apple. Also das war echt krass bei Gravis, was da für ein Schrott rumhängt und die Leute kaufen das auch noch alle. Also das ist wirklich...
Ja gut, andere Länder, andere Sitten, andere Leute, andere Bedienkonzepte. Und was, ich meine, jetzt iPad 3...
Mehr Auflösung nach wie vor.
Also ich hab ja kein iPad 2. Ich weiß ja nicht, ob das Leben sehr viel besser ist, wenn man ein iPad 2 hat gegenüber einem iPad 1. Das iPad 1 ist mir irgendwie immer noch zu schwer.
Also ich würde sagen, iPad 2 ist wahrscheinlich schon alleine durch die Performance im Gegensatz zum iPad 1 schon irgendwie cooler. Also das fühlt sich wirklich extrem fluffig an im Vergleich. Also noch mal fluffiger im Vergleich zu meinem iPhone 4 sogar gefühlt. So beim Bedienen. Und ich könnte mir jetzt schon vorstellen, dass das iPad 1 vielleicht nicht ganz so fluffig daherkommt und snappy und abswitchen und...
Nee, nee, das ist es nicht. Aber das ist für mich eigentlich gar nicht so das primäre Problem.
Na gut. Also ich meine, das Einzige, und das ist auch jetzt, wo ich ein iPad habe, und vorher hab ich ja nur so drüber gemutmaßt, ist schon so der Hauptknackpunkt, ich find die Auflösung halt zu gering. Also für Spielen okay so, aber für Lesen, ich find, Schrift sieht einfach so scheiße da drauf aus. Und auch diese Zeichenprogramme, da gab's halt einen Programm, da konntest du dann halt in HD, also in Full HD malen, also die Bilder hatten die Auflösung, aber es war halt alles ungenau, unscharf. Und das ist nach wie vor mein Feature-Wunsch Nummer eins fürs iPad 3. Und ich hätte mir jetzt halt auch kein iPad 2 gekauft, also jetzt... Ja, der primäre. Und... Ja, leichter könnte es auf jeden Fall gerne auch sein. Also das ist auch so ein Punkt, natürlich, wenn du es in der Hand hältst die ganze Zeit, also mir ist ja teilweise der Kindle schon manchmal ein bisschen zu ätzend. Und das iPad ist halt, wenn du auf dem Bett so rumrangierst und dass man eine Hand halten willst, geht halt nicht so richtig. Das ist auch mit dem iPad 2 nicht besser. Und da bin ich aber auch skeptisch, ob sie das mit dem iPad 3 signifikant noch mal verbessern können, also...
Ja, ein bisschen leichter kannst du ruhig sein, das stimmt.
Ja, und ansonsten wüsste ich ehrlich gesagt nicht, ob da jetzt eine Kamera drin ist und so. Ich bin ja eh nicht so der Video-Telefonierer und Foto-Bacher.
FaceTime fand ich auf dem iPad großartig.
Ja, ich bin halt wie gesagt nicht so ein...
Ja, hab ich auch nicht. Also ich hab noch nie vorher Video-Telefonien gemacht und ich find's immer doof vor... Also ich find, ich sitze wenn ich irgendwie Skype oder sowas, ich find das total doof. Aber so ein iPad, das irgendwie so hinzustellen, so ein bisschen weiter weg und dann ganz entspannt so Video zu telefonieren, ist echt großartig. Das hat viel, viel...
Wenn ich mal jemanden kenne, mit dem ich Video telefonieren möchte, dann werde ich das auch nochmal ausprobieren.
Oder schick deine Freundin in den Urlaub. Das hat bei mir funktioniert. Also, dann hab ich mit ihr Video telefoniert.
Kannst du mal rausgehen, ich will Video telefonieren.
Urlaub, Urlaub ist nicht raus. Ja, also das sind so meine primären Feature-Wünsche da in der Ecke.
Ja, so weit sieht ja die Gerüchteküche auch aus.
Ja, das ist auch das, was am naheliegendsten ist. Ich wüsste jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht, was wir noch toller machen können.
Also für mich ist eigentlich die wirklich einzige Anwendung, wo ich sage, da greife ich am liebsten zum iPad, ist Doku lesen.
So Doku lesen?
So Doku lesen, also Bücher. Und abgesehen von dem etwas mageren Zustand des EPUB-Standards bzw. seiner Umsetzung oder so, finde ich das an sich ganz praktisch, weil man kann halt suchen, man kann markieren. Das sind einfach so Dinge, die gehen halt nicht so gut auf Papier. Man kann das zwar auch markieren, aber du kannst halt nicht mal nach den Markierungen suchen und du kannst keine Annotations machen. Klar, du kannst ja jetzt irgendwie anfangen, Zettel reinzukleben und so, aber das macht man halt auch dann irgendwie nicht. So mach ich das schon, aber es ist wirklich eben diese Auflösung, die stört. Und wenn ich mich noch zurückerinnere, wie das mal so war, als man noch kein Retina-Display hatte, wenn der Effekt genau so ist auf dem iPad und das kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass das so ist, dann könnte sich da einfach nachhaltig was ändern. Wir haben ja jetzt morgen dieser Apple Termin.
Mir ist übrigens noch ein Feature eingefallen.
Wo sie diese Education-Geschichte ankündigen. Und wenn man der Gerüchtelage glauben darf, geht es ja auch konkret um E-Books und EPUB und EPUB 3.0 Standard etc. Also sie wollen jetzt bunte animierte Bücher machen, nehme ich mal an. Und es geht auch das Gerücht, dass sie da richtig Typen an Start bringen, der sich dieser ganzen Education-Thematik ja, also dass sie das sozusagen zu so einem, ich weiß nicht auf welchen Level sie es heben werden, ob sie da so einen Vice-President mal wieder ausgraben. Und das letzte, was ich gelesen habe, ist, dass es derjenige ist, der vorher iWork gemacht hat. Und wenn man jetzt mal ein bisschen eins und eins zusammenzählt, jetzt mal wieder Glaskugel. Du kannst mit Pages auch EPUB machen. Pages ist furchtbar alt. Wir haben jetzt seit wann keine Updates mehr gemacht. Die Version heißt iWork 09. Wir haben jetzt 2012. Wann ist das rausgekommen, iWork 09?
Anfang 2009, glaube ich.
So habe ich das auch in Erinnerung.
Das war ja immer so eher Anfang des Jahres.
Wir schlagen nach dem Buch der Waffen. Das steht natürlich nicht in der deutschen Wikipedia drin.
September 2008 sagt ja einer im Chat, das klingt ja ein bisschen sehr früh.
Dafür brauchen wir die englische Wikipedia.
Was kommen wir auch auf die Idee, an so einem Tag einen Podcast zu machen wie heute?
Darf ich in der Zwischenzeit während ihr hier versucht...
Januar 2009. Also das ist wirklich drei Jahre alte Software. Und ich bin ja Heavy User von Numbers. Und das ist einfach so was von überfällig, dass da mal eine neue Version rauskommt. Das ist streckenweise einfach so furcht... Nein, das ist nicht streckenweise, furchtbar langsam. Das ist furchtbar langsam und es ist streckenweise unerträglich langsam. So und ich schätze mal, Sie werden schon in den letzten drei Jahren daran gearbeitet haben und mehr als nur iCloud Integration. Meine Hoffnung ist natürlich, ein neues iWork Release könnte morgen vielleicht schon auf dem Tisch liegen. Würde ja Sinn machen, dass sie eine neue Version von Pages rausgeben, was halt oder dass sie dem vielleicht sogar noch eine neue ist, dass sie noch ein Tool ausgliedern aus Pages, so einen speziellen E-Book, Author, E-Book, könnte man das, wie würde Apple sowas nennen? Ein Schulbuchmacher, wie würde man das nennen bei Apple? Meine Apple-Wert? Sag doch mal Apple.
Bin ich den ganzen Tag, das kann ich nicht auch noch auf Feierabend sein.
Du bist den ganzen Tag Apple?
Bin mehr so Steglitz heute.
Keine Ahnung. Was sagt denn der Shit? Den Vergleich, den gab es ja auch. Garage Band für... Ja, keine Ahnung, sie werden sich schon irgendwas netzes einfallen lassen. ich kann mir das ganz gut vorstellen, dass das quasi auch schon so dieses iPad 3 in gewisser Hinsicht präantizipiert, dass dieses Gerät dann einfach optimal ist für diese Nutzung in der Schule.
Und dafür jetzt noch mal kurz nachgeschoben, mein Peacher-Request sozusagen fürs iPad 3. Besser, also schneller oder feiner aufgelöstes Touch-Dingsbumm. Also das gerade fürs Malen zum Beispiel mit dem Stift und so, wo ich das gemerkt habe, dass es halt schon relativ grob eigentlich ist und halt, wenn du malst, auch nicht wirklich schnell hinterherkommt mit dem Malen.
Weißt du, dass es wirklich einen Stift gibt, der auf den Pixel genau erkannt wird?
Also oder zumindest das Stift-Interaktion gerade so für Malen und so weiter, einfach, also auch dieses Bamboo-Pad oder wie das heißt, diese Software, die von Wacom dazukommen, das ist halt, also du kannst damit schreiben, aber wenn du wirklich klein schreiben willst, es geht nicht so und wenn du an so einem Wacom-Tablet sitzt, dann ist es halt so, wie es sein muss und das ist auch schnell genug und so und ich, also das würde ich mir wünschen zumindest, dass es beim iPad 3 einfach so ist, dass wenn du ein Stift hast, dass sie viel feiner sozusagen da die Auflösung haben.
Es gibt tatsächlich eine Auflösung des Digitizers? Also ich dachte ja, also ich hab ja, also ich hab erstens eigentlich so einen Stift, zweitens ist der ja vorne ziemlich grob an der Spitze.
Und es ist der kleinere, also es gibt Stifte, ansonsten Stifte, die noch größer sind. Also diese Bamboo-Ding ist schon mit der kleinsten Spitze, die es so gibt.
Und dann dachte ich in geringer Auflösung vielleicht und weil Glas, weil du halt über Glas halt auch immer gleich relativ weit rutscht und nicht irgendwie so und so.
Da gibt es jetzt einen neuen Ansatz, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es schon gesehen habt, hier. Cosmonaut, das ist von den Jungs, die auch diesen iPad-Halter, diesen Glyph gemacht haben. Und das ist, Lust war jetzt nicht das Problem, was du haben willst, mit ich möchte ganz genau zeichnen, aber es kommt auf dem, es kommt, sagen wir mal, dem iPad wiederum entgegen auf zweilang Art. Erstens ist das Ding relativ dick, also das ist mehr so Stockmawachs-Maler, so wie in der Weidorfschule. Und was ganz pfiffig ist, dass, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, der Stift so ist, dass wenn du ihn einfach sanft auflegst, dass er keinerlei Kontakt erzeugt. Also das iPad merkt ihn dann noch nicht, sondern erst, wenn du etwas Druck machst, dann kommt er nahe genug dran, um diesen Touch auszulösen.
Das ist ganz schlau.
Das heißt, du hast wirklich so einen Zeichnen-Effekt, kannst du so...
Also das ist ja dann den Druck, wie...
Ja, da ist einfach das, was quasi den Kontakt herstellt, wird erst den Kontakt durch Druck her.
Und dann wird es breiter eben, wenn man drückt.
Also es liegt halt der Kontakt auf, aber er verändert halt das Feld erst in dem Moment, wo du ein bisschen drauf drückst. So habe ich das verstanden. Und das ist natürlich eine sehr coole Sache, weil das war immer das große Problem mit diesen Touch-Stiften. Wenn du sie drauflegst, dann fangen sie halt sofort an zu malen, was halt so ein Stift jetzt so...
Wobei bei dem Bamboo, also bei diesen Schaumstoff-Dingern ist es auch so, dass man schon zumindest dieses Schaumstoff mal so ein bisschen eindällen muss. Also direkt losgemalt hat der auch nicht.
Stimmt auch. Aber der ist halt nicht so... liegt halt nicht so gut in der Hand. Na ja, keine Ahnung. Müssen wir dann auch erstmal ausprobieren, ob das hier wirklich die Lösung ist. Hünder Van Orwas, der ist halt hier irgendwie noch nichts zu kriegen. Aber wahrscheinlich wird hier dieser andere Vogel, der dann immer gleich den Glyph kopiert hat, dann auch schnell da ja sein.
Aber das wär ja auch für die Schule und so, wär das ja ganz toll, wenn das iPad auch so zum Schreiben und Malen irgendwie gleich besser taucht.
Auf jeden Fall, ja, das fände ich auch super.
Ja, also da könnten sie auf jeden Fall einfach auch so ein bisschen so diese Wacom-Jungs einfach nochmal so... Es wär auch geil, wenn du das iPad quasi mit deinem Rechner perlen könntest und dann hättest du einfach sozusagen, könntest du dein iPad zu so einem Wacom umfunktionieren, also das Eingabemedium für dein Rechner. Das wär eigentlich schon ganz geil.
Na das ist ja noch ein relativ simple sogar.
Oder gibt's das?
Oder gibt's eine Software, die quasi ein Eingabegerät für ein Mac darstellt?
Also du kannst...
Also Wacom-mäßig so?
Also es gibt, na nicht über Bluetooth, sondern über WLAN, es gibt R-Display heißt das. Das nutze ich manchmal so, wenn ich also damit kann man ein iPhone oder macht eigentlich nur Sinn, mit einem iPad als externes Display nutzen. Ist ganz lustig, wenn man mal so am MacBook einfach mal spontan ein externes Display braucht. Und das kann auch Eingabe, also damit kannst du dann auch Drag und Drop und sowas machen. Und dann kannst du einfach da dir ein Window draufziehen oder machst du Display Mirroring und dann kannst du da so mit dem Finger Mac-Programme bedienen.
Na gut, aber es simuliert nur eine Maus. Und das ist nicht in dem Sinne eine drucksensitive Geschichte. Ja, aber ich wollte R-Display eigentlich auch noch erwähnen. Du warst recht. Das finde ich cool. Es ist nicht nur ein externer Bildschirm, sondern es ist auch noch ein externer Bildschirm, der auch eine Tastatur haben kann und auch als Maus fungiert.
Und jetzt noch mal, so als Kleid?
Das kann ich dir sehr empfehlen. R-Display auch für ein Mac. Ja, das ist so, ich habe mir das jetzt auch gerade hier gekauft, weil dritter Bildschirm anschließend nur zwei Anschlüsse haben. R-Display ist da quasi die Lösung.
Oder auch wenn man mal unterwegs ist und irgendwie mal spontan ein zweites Display braucht an seinem MacBook. Ich meine, so viele Displays hat man ja auch nicht dabei.
Was heißt man mal spontan?
Und wenn wir jetzt wirklich bei Eingabegerechnungen gerade sind?
Wo du das gerade sagst, das stimmt, weil angenommen, du sitzt so im Zug und du möchtest mit jemanden gemeinsam etwas arbeiten, dann kannst du dir das iPad quasi auf die andere Seite stellen und machst Screen Barrow Ring. Und dann sieht er, was du da machst.
Also ich hab's jetzt benutzt um QuickTime, also ich hab mir so ein Tutorial, kann ich ja nachher noch ein bisschen was zu erzählen, runtergeladen und teilweise hab ich das dann genutzt, einfach per R-Display hab ich dann da das Video laufen lassen, auf dem externen Display quasi, und hab dann auf dem internen weitergearbeitet.
Schnell genug für Video.
Also es ist jetzt kein Actionfilm gewesen, sondern halt Screencast. Aber dafür war es mehr als schnell genug, ja.
Okay und jetzt darf ich nochmal? Ein Eingabegerät, denn das Keyboard gibt's jetzt demnächst auch für Mac.
Das Keyboard?
Aber das Keyboard ist doch eigentlich eine Tastatur ohne Tastaturbemalung.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist die Ultimate Edition von das Keyboard. Komm, Tim, du guckst zu Fragen, gib jetzt mal schnell bei mir.
Ist das diese Tastatur ohne Beschriftung?
Nein, das ist ein Modell von diesem Keyboard. Was es eigentlich hauptsächlich als Feature hat, das IBM Model M ist es das?
Ach so, das ist das Click, ein Click-Keyboard.
Genau, das ist das mit dem Gold-Click. Es gibt auch eine Silent-Variante, die aber immer noch den gleichen Hub und das gleiche Feeling vom IBM Model hat, nur dass es nicht laut klackt. Also es ist dann gedämpft irgendwie.
Und Ultimate ist ohne Beschriftung?
Ultimate ist ohne Beschriftung, genau.
Look how fast this guy is typing.
He's dangerous. Vor allen Dingen, das Krasse bei uns in der Firma, hat einer Dvorak Keyboard-Layout und das Ultimate Keyboard. Wenn mir irgendjemand an den seinen Rechner geht, es hört total sofort aus. Ja, das ist besser als ein Passwort, genau. Also das geht wirklich gar nicht. Aber das Keyboard ist auf jeden Fall auch ganz cool. Und da gibt es jetzt auch demnächst eben diese Mac-Edition mit Tastaturbeschriftung für Mac. Also wer mal wieder so ein richtiges Click-Keyboard haben will und schon lange seine IBM Model M verschrotten musste...
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das immer noch haben. Die hatten mal, dass die einzelnen Tasten unterschiedlich starke Druckpunkte hatten. Also, dass du für unterschiedliche Tasten unterschiedlich stark drücken musstest.
Das hab ich jetzt nicht gesehen, ne.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das immer noch haben. Weil die kleinen Finger, die ja tendenziell ein bisschen schwächer ausgeprägt sind, dass die dann nicht so viel Druck ausgenausken. Ich glaub, das waren die. Ich glaub, das war das Keyboard mit... Also am Anfang hatten die ja glaube ich nur diese Ultimate Edition. Diese Weichei-Version mit Tastaturbemalung, die haben sie später hinzugefügt. Aber vielleicht ist das auch... See more details? Da hatten sie...
Na da war ich, warte mal, fahr mal hoch.
PS2 Adapter.
Extra long cable, USB 2.0 Hab.
Und wenn der... Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die überhaupt ein deutsches Keyboard Layout anbieten.
Die Ultimate halt.
Das ist auch geil. You say you still want a racket, it's cool, we also sell earplugs. Gut, also jetzt sind wir durch mit den Eingabegeräten fürs erste. Und es klingt wirklich wie eine IBM Tastatur. Also original.
Fühlt es sich auch an wie die IBM Tastatur?
Ja, ich glaube schon. Es ist wirklich sehr nah dran. Ich hab auch schon dran getippt und das macht wirklich genau dieses späte Klack. Auf dem Hub.
Ich hatte ja heute die Idee, als so hier Dingsprojekt, als Kickstarter-Projekt Ersatztasten für so ein MacBook Air oder so ein MacBook Pro, auf dem einfach nichts drauf steht. Weiß aber nicht, wie schwer es ist, das auszuwechseln.
Es geht. Das ist Fummelarbeit, aber es geht.
Es gibt bestimmt ein paar Irre, die das gerne machen. Ich hab noch eine schöne App, die mir, wie gesagt, ich hab sehr viel Screencast geguckt. Auch das kann ich immer noch später erzählen. Warum?
Das Screencast.
So viel Zeit haben wir jetzt nicht mehr, ne?
Und zwar ist das eine Mac-App, die heißt Beamer und damit der kann man beliebige Videos auf dem Apple TV gucken. Also per Airplay. Von Mac aus. Man nimmt eine Datei, ein Audiodatei, schmeißt ihnen dieses Beamer-Fans da rein und dann fängt das an zu spielen. Kostet irgendwie 7 Euro. Und ähm... Im Upstore? Ne, auf deren Seite.
Weil sowas kommt ja nicht in Upstore.
Keine Ahnung, ob die da...
Beamer, so mit E, A?
Also beamerapp.com ist die Domain.
Ist das das Deutsche?
Ähm, ich glaub ja.
Ich glaub nur Deutsche nennen einen Beamer-Beamer.
Weiß nicht, anderen hätten es mit Doppel-E oder mit...
Ja, das sagt das Projektor.
Steht da irgendwo? bigbugbunny.org. Achso, ne, das ist ein Video.
Blender Foundation? Achso, das sind die, ja.
Für Texte haben die mal gearbeitet. Das sieht doch sehr nach Deutschen aus.
Kein Impressum.
Tja, haben sie halt Comdomains.
Gleich mal abmahnen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, damit kann man so schön mal...
Holland.
Damit kann man......
kann man schön mal so ein Video kurz und schmerzlos auf Apple TV angucken. Angucken, angucken. Mit den Spulen gab's so ein bisschen Probleme, und zwar, dass wenn man schnell zurückspult, dass er dann halt oft kein Bild hat. Sobald man dann play drückt, sieht man wieder was. Ansonsten war das ganz...... schöne App.
7 Dollar.
Genau.
Fast geschenkt.
Kaufen sich über Paypal. Ich hätt ja ganz gerne so ein Apple TV als als zweiten Bildschirm. Also wenn man...
Das hätt ich auch gern.
Also so was wie R-Display auf Basis von R-Play. Dass ich einfach alles, was R-Play kann, alles was ich als ich... Ich bin Display. Das ist ja Display und das ist schnell und das ist irgendwie hin streamen. Eine Software, die halt einfach alles, was sich als R-Play anbietet, beliebig als zweiten Bildschirm machen kann. Weil dann könnte ich mir hier eine Apple TV an meinem Beamer ranmachen und bräuchte gar kein HDMI mehr. Und könnte von jedem Rechner aus das Ding als zweiten Bildschirm anbieten.
Ich frag mich auch, ist das Format so kompliziert, was da... Also ich meine das iPad und das iPhone, die können ja Display, R-Play, Mirroring. Das ist ja quasi... Das ist ja eigentlich das. Genau, das ist ja eigentlich genau das. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das für da teif... Also es muss irgendwas sein, was offensichtlich schnell geht und relativ geringe Latenz hat. Ansonsten ginge das ja gar nicht so. Und ich hab da irgendwie so fancy Stuff gehört, von wegen, dass die da komplett die... die Choregraphik-Sachen rüber scheuchen und weiß ja doch was. Aber ehrlich gesagt, meine Vermutung ist ja, dass das da so ein aufgebohrtes VNC ist, was dahinter läuft. Und dass da noch niemand hintergestiegen ist, das hätt ich so gerne. So gerne hätt ich das!
Ey, verpippsch noch mal.
Ich guck mal, was das Chat so sagt. Chat beschäftigt sich mit Gossip.
Wie immer.
Und Fehlinformation.
Was haben wir denn jetzt eigentlich so als nächstes, als echtes Thema auf dem Zettel?
Ach so, naja, was denn?
Ich hätte gern dieses... Das ist voll die Abschlacht. Mr. Dazey and the Apple Factory angehört. Das ist so ein Podcast.
Jetzt kommen wir ja sozusagen in den politischen Bereich.
Ja, ist schon ein bisschen...
Wir kommen jetzt in den politischen Bereich. In das freie Bashing und...
Ach so, das freie Bashing kommt ja danach.
In der Cruiser und Mittelgewichtsklasse.
Genau, und zwar geht das... Das ist so ein This American Life Podcast. Das ist so ein... Also, This American Life ist hier NPR, also amerikanisch-öffentlich-rechtliches Radio quasi, ein bisschen öffentlich gefördert. Ein bisschen anspruchsvolleres Radio, die machen eine Sendung, This American Life, die manchmal sehr gute Folgen hat, manchmal... Nicht so tolle Folgen, aber lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, öfters mal reinzuhören. Und die hatten jetzt eine Folge Mr. Daisy and the Apple Factory. Und das geht um einen Typen, also es ist nichts weiter, die ganze Sendung oder der größte Teil der Sendung ist nichts weiter als ein Typ, der nach China gefahren ist und sich die Zustände bei Foxconn angeguckt hat und daraus ein Monolog gemacht hat, also ein Bühnenmonolog und das auf einer Bühne vorträgt. Sehr, sehr unterhaltsam, durchaus auch lustig, aber dadurch natürlich auch ein bisschen erschreckend und erzählt so, wie es bei Foxconn abläuft. Also erstmal, wie er das rausgekriegt, die ganzen Sachen, er ist einfach hingefahren, hat sich in Taxi gesetzt, hat eine Däumetscherin mitgenommen, die ihm gesagt hat, du bist doch komplett wahnsinnig, was du hier vorhast, das wird nie was, hat sich vor die Foxconn-Fabrik gestellt und hat dann gehofft, dass Leute kommen und ihm erzählen, wie es da so drin abgeht. Und seine Däumetscherin hat dann angefangen, die rauskommen den Leuten so, hey, wollt ihr nicht? Und die haben das gemacht. Also die haben das wohl nicht so ein paar so, haha, ja okay, wir erzählen mal ein bisschen was, sondern es haben sich wohl regelrechte Schlangen gebildet von Leuten, die ihm unbedingt erzählen wollen, wie es dann so in einer Foxconn-Fabrik drin ist.
Aber er war selber nicht drin.
Na ja, er war bei Foxconn nicht drin. Was er dann gemacht hat als nächstes, ist dann sich ausgegeben als westlicher Investor, der jetzt gerne was produzieren lassen würde in Fabriken und sich unter dem Vorwand dann, jetzt möchte ich aber auch sehen, was hier abläuft, bevor ich hier investiere. Und die haben ihm dann wohl mehr oder weniger alles gezeigt, was er sehen wollte und macht auch nicht den Eindruck, als ob das irgendwie gefaked wäre oder sowas. Und auf der einen Seite, die arbeiten offensichtlich extrem lange. Also so acht Stunden wie bei uns, offiziell ist das so, aber er meinte, er hätte niemanden getroffen, der auch nur gehört hätte, dass irgendjemand tatsächlich nur acht Stunden arbeitet. Also so zwölf, sechzehn Stunden, das ist die absolute Normalität. Dann eben auch hat er gesagt, also das war dann sehr süß, eine amerikanische Stunde, eine chinesische Stunde wird anders gezählt als eine amerikanische Stunde. Und zwar eine chinesische Stunde hat, da hat die Minute 60 Sekunden und die Stunde hat 60 Minuten. Also wenn du eine Stunde arbeitest, dann hast du auch 60 Minuten am Band gestanden. Und nicht irgendwie Pause- und Raucherzeiten und Yoga-Zeiten und weiß der Teufel was-Zeiten, sondern es ist dann wirklich so BAM! Und er hat so ein bisschen beschrieben, wie das da in dieser Stadt ist, in dieser Region. Also es ist ja nicht komplett, wir denken immer, es kommt ja aus China alles, der ganze Scheiß. Aber es ist ja im wesentlichen Sinne, dass das eine Region in China, aus der das Zeug kommt, wie das da abläuft. Also die Luft ist wohl schon wirklich eine totale Katastrophe, weil die einfach so unglaublich dreckig ist. Also Shanghai soll ja schon schlechte Luft haben, aber es ist wohl kein Vergleich zu dem, was da abläuft. Und halt diese pure Dimension, ich hoffe, ich kriege jetzt die Zahlen nicht durcheinander. Das war irgendwie... Dass da, wie viel waren es? 300.000 Leute in dieser Fabrik arbeiten. Also die haben da... Die haben da Kantinen, wo pro Schicht 10.000 Leute durchgeschleust werden. Also wirklich so komplett gigantische Ausmaße. Und ja, da natürlich so das Übliche. Es gibt keine Gewerkschaften für die Gründung einer... Also es gibt Gewerkschaften, die machen sich aber nicht als Gewerkschaften tätig. Wenn du eine eigene Gewerkschaftsgründung hast, gehst du dafür in den Knast. Richtig schön lange. Also darfst dich nicht dabei ertappen lassen. Das hält die Leute natürlich trotzdem nicht davon ab, irgendwie im Untergrund Gewerkschaften zu gründen. Es ist... Die Unterkünfte müssen nicht... Also nicht so irgendwie dreckig oder komplett scheiße sein, sondern einfach keinerlei Privatsphäre, sondern sind dann Unterkünften, so mit zehn anderen Leuten in einem Zimmer. Schlafräume, extrem wenig Platz drin, also wo wir als Mitteleuropäer mit unseren Tendenzen zum Übergewicht wohl nicht mal reinpassen würden. Worin sie da schlafen. Und Krankenversorgung natürlich auch eine totale Katastrophe. Also irgendwie hatten sie einen Typen da, der hat da irgendwie so eine Presse auf die Finger gekriegt oder auf die Hand, und das Hand war danach kaputt. Die ist schlicht und ergreifend so verheilt, wie sie aus der Maschine rauskam. Also als er dann aufgrund dessen nicht mehr richtig arbeiten konnte, haben sie ihn dann gefeuert. Also so richtig, wie man sich das vorstellt. Ja, also es klang alles nicht so wirklich toll.
Das sind die Bedingungen, unter denen heutzutage so...
Es klang nicht ganz so schlimm, wie ich es mir vorgestellt hatte, ehrlich gesagt. Und sie haben danach noch hinterher recherchiert, also die eine Hälfte der Sendung war dieses Live-Programm von dem, wo er auch wirklich... Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass der die ganze Zeit auf Apple einkloppt, sondern es ist wirklich toll gemacht. Er erzählt am Anfang, dass er ein totaler Apple-Fanboy ist und er sagt natürlich auch, es ist jetzt nicht so, als ob man ein HTC-Gerät sich kauft oder irgendwie, da produzieren alle. Das ist im Wesentlichen die gleichen Bedingungen.
Das finde ich aber auch wirklich mein entscheidender Knackpunkt, weil irgendwie bei dieser Greenpeace-Geschichte, was die alle auf Apple rumgekloppt haben, alle anderen haben es nicht gemacht, oder haben sich weiter drum und dreck geschert. Genauso jetzt mit diesem Foxconn, irgendwie alle auf Apple rumhacken und schreien, aber ist jeder da, jeder macht das so.
Er hat überhaupt nicht auf Apple eingekloppt. Er hat sich wirklich Apple rausgesucht. Er hat es so gesagt, er ist ein totaler Apple-Fanboy. Er hat erzählt, wie er sein MacBook zerlegt und reinigt mit Druckluft. Also er könnte durchaus hier in diese Sendung reinpassen. Aber er hat sich nie Gedanken darum gemacht, unter welchen Bedingungen die Dinger produziert werden. Und dann kann man natürlich auch sagen, ja klar, dass ein Samsung-Telefon unter schlimmen Bedingungen hergestellt wird, ich meine, so sieht es auch aus. Aber das ist ein Apple-Produkt. Also für ein besonders schönes Produkt, dass das unter schlimmen Bedingungen hergestellt wird, ist doch wesentlich erschreckender, als wenn tendenziell sowieso schon hässliches Produkt unter schlechten Bedingungen hergestellt wird.
Aber jetzt wird ja alles besser mit Tim Cook.
Sie haben auch in den Podcasten auch dazu gesagt, dass sich Apple eigentlich tendenziell im Vergleich zu anderen tatsächlich schon länger mehr Mühe gegeben hat als andere Firmen. Dass sich aber trotzdem auch nicht wahnsinnig viel gebessert hat. Also dass ich immer noch... Und...
Ja, also ich meine...
Und dass diese Firmen mittlerweile auch wohl Fluktuationsraten haben. Also dass die Leute da einfach, dass die... Ich weiß die Zahlen nicht, aber es waren irgendwie so, innerhalb eines Monats sind 20% der Belegschaft nicht mehr da. Also die haben wirklich so gigantische Durchbrennraten von Leuten, denen es einfach zu blöd wird, da zu arbeiten. Und so dass sie die Hoffnung da zumindest geäußert haben, damit die sich das überhaupt leisten können, weil du musst ja die Leute immer anlernen und so was, dann hast du ja Leerlaufzeiten, dass selbst die irgendwann mal in den Zustand kommen, dass es einfach bessere Bedingungen schaffen müssen, damit die Leute länger bleiben. Was sie aber auch gesagt haben, und das war das eigentlich erschreckend, also sie haben zum Beispiel erwähnt, dass es gibt da einfach Leute, die reinigen das Display von diversen Telefonen, also von iPhones und anderen Telefonen, die werden damit gereinigt, mit irgendeiner Flüssigkeit, dann kannst du Alkohol für nehmen, dann kannst du aber auch eine andere Flüssigkeit für nehmen. Die macht irgendwie, macht die Lunge kaputt und macht alles kaputt, wenn es so lange, aber sie verdunstet halt ein bisschen schneller. Das ist noch nicht mal so unbedingt das Problem, sondern das Problem ist, dass die Leute da wirklich zehn Jahre lang an dieser Stelle arbeiten. Wenn die da irgendwie mal ein halbes Jahr arbeiten würden, dann wäre das alles gar nicht so ganz furchtbar schlimm. Also es wäre bestimmt immer noch mit deutschem Arbeitsschutz nicht zu vergleichen. Aber dass die Leute wirklich daran kaputt gehen, liegt nur daran, dass sie so ewig lange daran arbeiten. Und dass sie so lange an einer Stelle arbeiten, liegt einfach daran, dass es keine Sau interessiert. Also es gibt niemanden, der sich darum kümmert und probiert, die Bedingungen zu verbessern. Es ist nicht so, dass das irgendwie wahnsinnig viel teurer werden würde, wenn man das machen würde, dass es irgendwie Aufwand bedeuten würde, sondern es ist einfach, du bist jetzt da und machst das halt, dann kümmert sich. Und dann interessiert das auch keinem mehr, ob da deine Gesundheit bald draufgeht. Und dass dieses Bewusstsein quasi, schon allein da fängt es an, dass der ganze Scheiß dann irgendwann auch mal kostet, ist ja dann, so Standards einzuhalten, ist ja deine nächste Ebene. Aber es interessiert nicht mal immer. Aber es ist, also kann man sich echt gut anhören, es ist ein bisschen erschreckend, aber es ist auch wirklich lustig und man ist dann auch ein bisschen schlauer und ist ja auch ganz schön mal zu wissen, wo die Dinge herkommen, die man mit denen den ganzen Tag so umspielt.
Ich frage mich, ob die Bedingungen in Asien generell so sind oder ob das wirklich nur so ein chinesisches Phänomen ist. Ich meine, Samsung kommt ja aus Korea und ob die Bedingungen da vergleichbar sind... Ja, natürlich produzieren die auch in Korea.
Na ja, also meinst du nicht, dass das der meiste Scheiß von denen auch aus China kommt? Von Samsung? Ich meine, Sie sind jetzt auch der hübsche Deutschlander.
Ich kenne jetzt nicht die Liste der Production Facilities, aber die haben definitiv in Korea auch Production Facilities.
Ich meine, dass die da ihre eigene Technologiekomponenten bauen, könnte ich mir auf jeden Fall locker vorstellen, aber ich könnte mir auch genauso gut vorstellen, dass die dann halt so das Assembly oder das Produkt zusammendängeln, halt dann trotzdem in China machen lassen. Weiß man nicht genau.
Hey, wer JavaScript anschaltet, bleibt doof. Zumindest heute. Was ich in dem Zusammenhang neulich gelesen habe, ich bin ja großer Freund von diesem Blackberry Pie, von diesem Mini-Muzzer-Boardchen, diesem Minim Arm-Board. Die haben jetzt die ersten Beta-Boards, haben sie bei eBay verkloppt für ein Schweinegeld, haben sie richtig viel rausgeholt. Und die gehen jetzt in Produktion, oder sind jetzt in Produktion gegangen, und die lassen jetzt auch alles irgendwo in China zusammenbauen. Und die haben in ihrem Blog erläutert, dass sie gerne wenigstens das zusammensetzen, weil sie sind ja eine britische Firma und wollen ja auch, dass sie das gerne in Großbritannien hätten machen lassen, dieses Zusammenbauen. Und das wäre bizarr, viel teurer geworden, als das in China zusammensetzen zu lassen. Oh Wunder, oh Wunder! Was mich allerdings wirklich überrascht hat, ist der Grund dafür, warum es so wahnsinnig teuer war, und zwar weil es nämlich eine Einfuhrsteuer gibt in England auf Komponenten. Auf fertig zusammengesetzte Produkte fällt diese Einfuhrsteuer wohl nicht mehr an. So dass sie natürlich die Chips, die werden schon irgendwo in Fernost produziert, aber die hätten sie wenigstens alle ins Land holen können und dann irgendwo in England zusammenlöten lassen können. Aber das ging wohl nicht wegen dieser extremen, wegen dieser merkwürdigen Einfuhrsteuer, auf die da auf alles lag. Also, ja. Find ich auch ganz lustig in dem Zusammenhang, so wie so Industrieförderung oder eben wie das aussieht.
Ja, schwer zu sagen. Irgendwie im Chat wird hier gerade irgendwas zusammengetragen, aber es bringt das jetzt glaube ich auch nicht weiter. Ich meine, das ist irgendwie so gut wie alle. Letztlich in Asien, also alle produzieren in Asien. Das kann man glaube ich mal festhalten. Die einzigen Ausreißer in der Hinsicht sind jetzt, glaube ich, dass jetzt auch die Chinesen langsam anfangen. Also ich glaube Foxconn zum Beispiel baut jetzt auch Facilities auf in Brasilien.
Und in Osteuropa, das boomt es doch auch gerade. Weil es da mittlerweile billiger ist als in China.
Ist Nokia nicht gerade mit viel Tamtam wieder aus Rumänien abgezogen, wo Nokia das Werk, wo war das hier in irgendeiner deutschen Stadt, haben sie es zugemacht, um es in Rumänien aus dem Boden zu stampfen? Und jetzt, nachdem die Förderung abgelaufen ist, haben sie es in Rumänien wieder eingestampft?
Ja, das muss ich doch von Nokia reden. Was kann dann Eckhardt im Keller alleine machen?
Ja, wir können das hier nur als Gedankenanregung einbringen. Das ist natürlich ein Problem. Die Frage ist natürlich, was kann man dagegen tun? Derzeit gibt es halt in dem Geflecht zu Recht keine Alternative für die Firmen. Wenn du heute was Konkurrenzfähiges bauen willst, musst du es zu ähnlichen Bedingungen bauen, wie die anderen, plus X. Du musst sogar noch versuchen billiger zu sein quasi. Da fällt halt Apples Strategie auf, die, soweit ich das wahrnehme, vor allem dadurch besticht, dass sie eben sehr viel Geld in die Hand nimmt vorher und sich exklusiv Facilities aufbauen lässt und letzten Endes auch die Produktionsmittel weitgehend owned. Das heißt, diese ganzen Maschinen, mit denen da ihre Unibody-Büchsen gebaut werden, die gehören Apple. Die stehen da, aber die gehören Apple und die können nicht irgendjemand anders auch noch benutzen. Das sind nicht die Foxconn-Alu-Schneide-Facilities, wo du dich dann irgendwie einkaufen kannst, sondern kannst dir auch nochmal so ein MacBook Air schneidern, sondern das ist halt alles offenbar so, dass Apple da sehr viel investiert. Da gab es ja auf Asymco eine interessante Analyse der Ausgabenwellen, die Apple so hat. Ja, da hat sich das Budget, also nach dem, nach dem was sie so quartalsmäßig veröffentlichen angeschaut und hat dann in dem Bereich, der so für Investitionen in Fabriken und Facilities zuständig ist, weiß nicht mehr ganz genau in welchem Bereich das fällt, aber in diesem Bereich, halt immer so zwei Quartale, bevor sie wieder irgendwas Neues, Heftiges rausdrücken. Ja, so das neue iPhone, das neue iPad etc. Spiegelt das immer auch entsprechende Investitionen zwei Quartale vorher wieder. Und das heißt, die kaufen da sehr viel ein, neue Gerätschaften werden angeschafft und zahlen sich dann ein halbes Jahr später aus.
Und jetzt haben sie doch aber auch, hat ja Apple jetzt auch noch ihren Report veröffentlicht, was ja wahrscheinlich glaube ich auch sonst keiner so macht.
Na doch, es machen schon ein paar. Das sind die Mitglieder dieser Vereinigung.
Ja, aber so wie das klang, war jetzt Apple ja die einzige Tech-Firma, die in dieser Vereinigung drin ist. Und ich habe jetzt, es mag sein, dass IBM so etwas vielleicht auch veröffentlicht, habe ich jetzt aber noch nicht gesehen.
Die geben sich auf jeden Fall Mühe.
Und jetzt, also machen sie ja sozusagen auch politisch, also ähnlich wie bei dieser Recycling- und giftigen Komponenten-Debatte, wo sie dann tada, alle Produkte 100% total biologisch abbaubar oder was auch immer, aber jetzt mit gutem Gewissen machen sie jetzt sozusagen den nächsten Schritt, in der Hinsicht, dass sie jetzt versuchen zumindest, irgendwie mal ihre Arbeitsbedingungen da so ein bisschen hinzukriegen. Was ich ja echt interessant finde und ja, wie gesagt, also das finde ich auch...
Ja, vor allem?
Echt spannend, dass sie halt auch immer erstmal auf Apple rumkloppen und Apple dann aber auch eigentlich...
Also ist sie wie alle anderen oder vielleicht sogar besser, meinst du?
Ja, dann irgendwie so...
Ob sie wirklich besser sind, das mag ich nicht zu beurteilen, aber sie sind auf jeden Fall nicht schlechter als die anderen. Und die ganze Debatte ist halt eigentlich eine Debatte um China. Und ich meine, wie das so ist mit dem Einfluss von außen auf China, wissen wir ja alle. Aber jetzt kann eine Firma halt nicht sagen, ach naja, also so das mit den Schlafräumen, das geht ja gar nicht. Wir produzieren jetzt mal woanders.
Ja, also ich meine, es ist natürlich schön, wenn sie da probieren, ein bisschen Einfluss draufzunehmen oder wenn sie dafür auch Geld in die Hand nehmen und wirklich das nicht nur ein bisschen probieren, sondern auch wirklich ernsthaft betreiben. Ich glaube, auf der anderen Seite ist es aber auch illusorisch davon auszugehen, dass Apple jetzt China verändert. Also da muss...
Naja, ich meine zumindest wäre es echt...
Da muss schon die ganze Welt... Ich meine, ein schlechtes Image ist auch für China ein Problem und wenn, weißt du, ab einem bestimmten Punkt zählt nicht nur das Geld. Besonders zählt immer schon das Geld, aber dann hat eben auch das Image einen Einfluss auf dieses Geld. Und ich glaube, das kann sich Foxconn eben auf Dauer auch nicht so leisten. Obwohl es natürlich ein bisschen absurd ist, dass sie irgendwie auf Selbstmorde halt erstmal dadurch reagieren, dass sie dann Netze zum Auffangen der Leute, die aus dem Fenster springen.
Also ich hab, ja, ich kann ja jedem verstehen. Vor allem, ich glaube, das ist, das klang nicht mal so, als ob das jetzt wirklich, das ist halt so extrem durchindustrialisiert. Das ist nicht mal so, dass es da irgendwie, dass es den Leuten jetzt, also es klang nicht so, als ob es bizarr unmenschlich wäre, als ob die da in ihren, also die warten da nicht in ihrem eigenen Blut oder was weiß der Teufel, sondern es ist einfach, wir sind natürlich total überarbeitet und dann halt dieses, du hast offensichtlich keinerlei Privatsphäre, das stelle ich mir so höllisch vor und bist dann in so einer komplett sterilen Umgebung die ganze Zeit.
Ja, das ist natürlich für die Deutschen das Schlimmste, was man sich überhaupt vorstellen kann.
Keine Privatsphäre zu haben? Also dem Umfang da mit zwölf anderen in einem Zimmer zu pennen, das ist auf Dauer.
Im Vergleich zu den allgemeinen Bedingungen des Arbeitens vor 100 Jahren ist das besser. Ja, es ist immer noch besser. Aber damit will ich das nicht schönreden. Das ist natürlich ein Problem des Gesamtwirtschaftssystems. Das ist einfach so, wie es halt läuft auf diesem Planeten, bringt es eben solche Sachen hervor. Jetzt wird es spannend sein zu sehen, was das öffentliche Naserümpfen darüber dann entsprechende Auswirkungen hat.
Vor allen Dingen, wenn es halt nicht nur Naserümpfen gegenüber Apple ist, sondern es sich halt alle mal vorknüpfen.
Auch.
Genau, nicht immer auf unserem Apple rumhauen.
Ja, also nicht nur.
Mano!
Ist ja rechtfertig, auf Apple rumzuhauen.
Ja, wir sind Fanboys, wir sind sensibel.
Kontinuos.
Wir können ja mal über was anderes reden.
Wie wär's denn über...
Lass uns mal irgendjemanden schlecht machen, richtig, wieder. Was ist denn mit Android hier überhaupt?
Komm mal ran auf den Meter. Ist so auf hilfloser ein...
Mit dieser Suche, mit dieser Suche, wie laut das da auch sofort so... Google, was habt ihr euch dabei gedacht? Das ist auch wieder schnell ruhig geworden drum, aber...
Ja, benutzen wir nicht alle jetzt DuckDuckGo?
Nee, ich finde die Suchergebnisse furchtbar von denen.
Es wird besser tatsächlich. Also ich check das so im Wochenrhythmus.
Was ist denn mit DuckDuckGo?
Na DuckDuckGo ist ja die Suchmaschine, die kein Bubbling und kein sonst was macht.
Was ist Bubbling?
Na Bubbling ist, wenn du einmal hier nach Kindle suchst auf Google und dann die nächsten Resultate, egal was für Keywords du hast, wenn da irgendwas in der Wolke in der Nähe zu Kindle ist, werden die Ergebnisse nach oben geschoben, wenn du halt ein Cookie und so weiter gesetzt hast. Also du wirst geprofalt und du kriegst für dich angepasste Suchergebnisse. Und das immer mehr. Und das jetzt mit dem Google Plus wird ja noch stärker. Und DuckDuckGo ist halt, die sagen, wir speichern nichts von dir und wir machen auch kein Bubbling. Also das heißt...
Wenn ich nach Mobile-Max suche, kommt als erstes der Flatter-Button von Mobile-Max. Okay, dann ändere ich jetzt mal eine Suchmaschine.
Interessant. Es gibt übrigens auch eine Suchmaschine, wo man den Regenwald retten kann, mit jeder Suchanfrage. Das funktioniert so... Den Regenwald retten durchs Suchmaschine? Ja, das ist so. Die benutzen Bing als Suchmaschine und sie zeigen Ads von Yahoo an. Das heißt, sie machen eigentlich nichts selber, außer eine Webseite an. Wenn du da suchst, werden sozusagen die Werbeeinnahmen von Google dafür zu 80% verwendet, um ein Fleckchen Baum im Regenwald zu kaufen. ecosia.org. Wenn wir jetzt schon mal bei der Weltverbesserung sind.
Wie heißt das nochmal? Da gibt es auch so einen Namen für Welt ändern und dabei das Sofa nicht verlassen.
Das ist das ultimative Slacktivism Tool.
Das ist ja alles so furchtbar und irgendwie Foxconn und die Ferien fallen um und überhaupt der Krieg und so. Ich such bei Ecosia wieder was getan. Slacktivism, das ist so Hashtag schmeißen auf Twitter und so. Ich bin auch dagegen und hier ist Sopa.
Ich mach mir eine Bannerei.
Es gibt ja auch Peer-Pressure, wenn du nicht genug Slacktivism an den Tag legst. Also wir senden heute zum Beispiel, es kam tatsächlich die Anfrage, ob wir nicht vielleicht unsere Sendung ausfallen lassen sollen, wegen des Sopa-Protests. Wie sollen wir denn sonst drei Stunden über dieses Thema reden? Das wir natürlich jetzt nicht gemacht haben.
Dann kommt ihr auch immer vom Hölzchen aufs Stöckchen. Also auf jeden Fall, DuckDuckGo, wenn ihr nicht in eure eigenen Suchfeld-Bubble sein wollt.
Ernsthaft, die behaupten, dass sie 679.000 Euro eingenommen haben?
Gespendet. Also das sind 80%, da fehlen noch 20%, die sie selber eingestrichen haben.
Wie viel haben sie gespendet?
679.000 Euro. Angeblich.
So viel Geld kann man verdienen mit so einer Webseite, die nichts anderes macht, als andere Dienste zu benutzen?
Ja, das habe ich auch. Das habe ich hier meinen Studenten im Kurs erklärt dann auch, dass sie nicht mal selber groß was können, außer so ein bisschen HTML und dann kann man schon Geld verdienen. Und die Welt retten.
Siehst du, man braucht keinen Slash. Nur HTML.
Und schon ist die Welt ein besserer Ort.
Kann ich hier irgendwie die anderen suchen nicht auswählen?
Ja, da musst du bestimmt extra bezahlen. Achso, ich habe JavaScript ausgeschaltet.
Also wer die Welt retten will, der muss auch JavaScript einschalten. Ich habe es gar nicht ausgeschaltet, das war der andere Rechner. Und man muss aber auch noch die Werbung anklicken. Oder verdienen die die Werbung einblenden.
Na ja, das steht da irgendwo. How it works, da ist ein Link unten. Oder so gewesen. Die benutzen halt Bing. Bing ist jetzt auch nicht total schlecht. Also wenn du mal wirklich exotische Suchterms bemühst, wird jetzt Bing und tatsächlich DuckDuckGo auch gar nicht so schlecht sein. Ich habe sogar bei irgendwelchen UDK-Unterseiten mal irgendwie einen Satz kopiert bei DuckDuckGo reingepastet und er hat auch die Seite gefunden. Also die scheinen schon so langsam so ein bisschen aufzuholen, allerdings ist ja so, wenn ich weiß nicht, wenn du bei deinen Web-Statistiken guckst, der Google-Crawler ist wahrscheinlich immer noch so bei 90% aller Crawls oder so, ne?
Bestimmt, aber ich habe derzeit die Statistiken gar nicht zugeschaltet.
Statistik, Schmatistik.
Ich möchte noch mal ein bisschen probieren, aufzuregen, als es mir zu ermüdend wäre, und zwar über die Content-Industrie. Ich hab's... Meine Freundin, die steht auf The Voice of Germany. Ich find das ganz furchtbar, aber sie liebt das halt. Was ist das? Das ist so eine Casting-Show auf ProSieben. Wirklich. Ja, ja, so was irgendwie ein bisschen anders, ein bisschen besser oder ein bisschen schlechter. Die guckt die nun nicht, wenn sie kommen im Fernsehen, sondern sie will die irgendwann später gucken. Wenn du innerhalb von sieben Tagen auf die ProSieben-Seite oder auf die Sat1-Seite gehst, dann kannst du dir das auch angucken und danach gibst du den Scheiß halt nicht mehr. Dann kannst du da theoretisch zwar bei... Wie heißt das hier? Wie heißt denn dieses Streaming-Portal von ProSieben und so? Dieses... Was ist das hier? Chat? Frag mal den Chat hier. Es gibt da so eine Seite. Streaming-Portal von ProSieben. Da kann man auch so Filme und sowas. Da hat sich dann angemeldet, weil dann irgendwie das für einen Euro... Nee, mein Spaß ist es nicht. Irgendwie sowas... Nee, auch nicht Movie-Load. Und...
Clipfish?
Auch nicht Clipfish.
Das klingt irgendwie...
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab keine Ahnung. Also irgendwie... Media-Dome, Movie... Keine Ahnung. Irgend so ein...
MaxDome!
MaxDome, genau. Hier, Serti...
Was kannst du nicht merken?
MaxDome? Ja, stimmt, hätte ich mir eigentlich merken können. Da hat sich ein Account zugelegt. MaxDome.
So kannst du dich nennen, kannst du dich so...
Ja, das lass ich aber, weil ich erzähl grad, wie die so drauf sind. Hat sich da irgendwie... Hat sich irgendwie ein Account geholt, hat sich angemeldet, wollte dann, hat dann gesagt, ja, jetzt diese Folge der Serie kaufen, haben sie gesagt, bevor wir sie hier was runterladen lassen, müssen wir erst mal überprüfen, ob ihre Bankdaten auch stimmten.
Erstmal postident machen.
Wegen ein fucking Euro. Das hat sich irgendwie am 30. Dezember gemacht. Die haben sich bis heute nicht bei ihr gemeldet. Da ist bis heute keine Antwort gekommen.
Apple kann einpacken, glaub ich.
Sie will das kaufen. Ich hab keinen Bock, den Scheißdreck irgendwo runterladen zu müssen. Aber weil Maxtorm das hier nicht auf die Reihe kriegt, mal zu sagen, hm... Gehen wir das Risiko ein, einen Verlust von einem gefühlten Euro zu haben, weil das ist ja nicht mal ein echter Euro, sie haben ja keine echten Kosten dafür, indem wir jetzt mal das Risiko eingehen, dass eventuell das Bankkonto nicht gedeckt sein könnte, und dann kriegen sie das Ganze nicht auf die Reihe. So, dann muss ich jetzt hier jedes Mal die Scheiß Voice of Germany runterladen. Für sie. Und das raussuchen. Und das nerven. Das ist unerträglich. Jetzt hab ich gehört, dass Sherlock der große Scheiß, äh, der heiße Scheiß ein solcher Sherlock, die gibt's in der BBC-Serie, die erste Staffel.
Wird grad gehypt.
Genau, wird grad gehypt. Hab ich mir also bei iTunes schön angekl... Also, setz ich mich an meinen Apple TV, gibt's Sherlock ein? Gibt's da kein Sherlock? Warum gibt's da kein Sherlock? Weil irgendwie man Serien, also Apple TV kann nur streamen, hab ich mir dann erklären lassen von irgendjemandem. Apple TV kann nur streamen, für Serien gibt's keinen Stream, Serien muss man kaufen. Okay, ist mir scheißegal, ob das Ding streamen oder kaufen heißt. Ihr Geld, ich gucken. Also, gab's da nicht. Dann hab ich das iPad rausgenommen, hab auf dem iPad iTunes gestartet, hab da Sherlock eingegeben. Sherlock gefunden, 8 Euro, ja hier, jetzt laden. Geht der scheiß kaufen-Button nicht? Auf dem iPhone das Ganze gekauft. Da ging dann das Kaufen, fängt da an zu laden, so dachte ich, okay, jetzt, ich will das jetzt abspielen, spiel das jetzt? Nein, er muss es erstmal vollständig runtergeladen haben, bis er es abspielt. Jetzt könnt ihr euch ja grob vorstellen, wie lange es dauert, bis so eine scheiß HD-Folge mit irgendwie 800, ne, wahrscheinlich deutlich mehr, mit anderthalb Gigabyte auf dem iPhone runtergeladen ist. Da hab ich den ganzen Scheiß nochmal per iTunes runtergeladen, parallel dazu, auf dem Mac. Und das hat dann eine halbe Stunde gedauert, bis ich mir die erste Folge angucken konnte.
Mit BitTorrent wärst du einfach so viel schneller gewesen.
Ey, ich hab mir per BitTorrent dazu parallel die ganze Staffel in der Zeitung geholt, hab angefangen, das zu gucken und nachdem dann die halbe Stunde rum war, hab ich dann auf meinen legalen Download bei Apple TV umgeschaltet. Das kann doch nicht sein.
Das ist aber auch, ich mein, das wissen wir doch jetzt alle, dass die einfach...
Ja, aber das muss doch irgendwann auch mal, ich mein, hier werden Gesetze geändert, hier werden irgendwelche... Ich mein, das kann man ja mal zu SOPA mal sagen. Hier werden, sollen Gesetze verabschiedet werden, dass einfach irgendwelche Seiten abgeschaltet werden können, damit die Content-Industrie weiterhin sich verkacken kann. Weiterhin verkacken kann. Sie probieren es ja nicht mal.
Da hat ja Tim O'Reilly auch einen schönen Post geschrieben zu diesem ganzen SOPA und das war halt auch einer der Punkte, den er da angesprochen hat, dass gar nicht das Problem ist, dass da groß wird, sondern das Problem ist, es gibt einfach nicht den legalen Weg, so wie es die Nutzer gerne hätten. Weil er meinte halt auch so, bei O'Reilly hätten sie es mittlerweile so im Flow hinbekommen, dass tatsächlich sie, denen es egal ist, wenn da Leute in Rumänien mal ein E-Book kopieren oder so, aber sie verdienen genug Geld jetzt mit ihrem Online-Shop. Und das ist es halt auch. Ich hab jetzt hier über die Feiertage wollte ich mal Alien gucken, weil ich hab noch nie Alien gesehen, also noch keinen der Filme und wollte mir Alien 1 bis 3 angucken.
Und?
Hab ich gemacht, aber nicht über iTunes, weil gibt's nicht.
Alien?
Ja, nicht in Englisch halt und sowieso, ne?
Ja, genau, wenn es mal was gibt, dann immer nur in Deutsch.
Achso, na doch, also hier Sherlock gibt's auch.
Ja, das gibt's auch in Englisch, aber das sind ja nur drei Filme.
Ja, ja, das sind, na, das ist eine Staffel. Eine Staffel?
Das sind eineinhalb Stunden lange Episoden, sind das?
Ja, aber die fängt, glaube ich, noch.
Ja, ja, das ist die erste Staffel. Die war drei Folgen lang, anderthalb Stunden. Und jetzt die zweite Staffel, die ist auch schon wieder vorbei. Das waren auch drei Folgen, anderthalb Stunden.
Ja, aber da steht, ganze Staffel kaufen, 7,99.
Ja, ja, das ist die ganze Staffel. Die hat drei Folgen. Das sind englische Staffeln.
Englische Staffeln sind drei Folgen?
Ich meine hier so, so, so, IT-Crowd, die haben, wie viele haben die pro Staffel? Sechs Folgen, sieben Folgen. Das sind halt, also ich meine, das sind auch britische Verhältnisse, das ist ein extrem kurzes Staffel, aber das sind, das ist die ganze Staffel, mehr gibt's da nicht.
Das ist toll.
Na, das wird gerade von den Nerds total gehypt.
Das ist ja schön gemacht, das ist so, das ist so angelehnt, also der heißt doch Sherlock Holmes, die heißen Sherlock und Watson und so und ist so, ist ja unterhaltsam, also ist so ein bisschen, hat mich ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen an Dexter erinnert. Und ja, also kann man sich gut angucken, die zweite Staffel gibt es jetzt im Tracker eurer Wahl, bei Elton's bestimmt dann irgendwann auch mal in einem halben Jahr und dann wundern sich wieder, warum es keiner kauft. Und ich hab ja, ich meine, es kostet 8 Euro für, was sind das jetzt, anderthalb Stunden?
Dreimal anderthalb Stunden?
Vier und halb Stunden, also ich meine, es ist, kann man jetzt, also es ist jetzt nicht...
Ja, das zahlst du sonst für einen Film so.
Na wenn du ihn kaufst, ja. Ich will ja nicht kaufen eigentlich.
Das Problem wird sich demnächst, glaube ich, mit iCloud dann auch erledigen. Dann wirst du halt auch wieder die Sachen auf dem Apple TV auch kaufen können und das, was du gekauft hast, direkt aus der Cloud holen.
Ja, das muss. Aber wahrscheinlich will jetzt die Content-Industrie von Apple mehr Geld dafür, dass sie das auch machen. Ansonsten...
Aber, also ich meine, ich hatte das gleiche Problem, quasi fast mit Alien, also gab's nicht. Gab's einfach nicht im deutschen Store. Da denkst du dir ja fest, der ist schon echt... Gibt's kein Movie mit Alien? Also klicken wir auf Movie oder Filme, aber ich glaube, da war keiner.
Rock und Dance gibt es irgendwie.
Alien 4 und 3. Das sind aber nun auch echt...
Alien versus Zombies.
Aber 1 und 2 sind ja eigentlich die guten, ne? Und 3 ist ja schon auf einem deutlich absteigenden Ast.
3 und 4 kann man auch gucken.
Aber 1 und 2 fand ich ja tatsächlich... Also ich wusste ja nie genau, warum Sigourney Weaver so einen Action-Heldinnen- Mythos hat, ne? Also hat sie ja, ist ja so dieser... Jetzt weiß es aber auch. So wie Sarah Connor hier. Wie heißt sie eigentlich?
Die Schauspielerin, die Sarah Connor gespielt hat im Terminator. Kennt auch keiner aus irgendeiner anderen Rolle.
Genau so in dieser Kategorie ist ja auch Sigourney Bion. Ich wusste dann nie wieso und jetzt dachte ich, okay, gucken wir uns mal Alien an. Dann hab ich den ersten geguckt, war ja schon mal ganz gut. Linda Hamilton. War mir ein bisschen zu anstrengend, so mit dieser Katze und dann der Katze hinterher rennen und alles so ein bisschen so auf Kinder-Horror mäßig gemacht. Im ersten Teil.
Da bist du aber auch wirklich eine andere Generation, muss ich sagen. Damals, ich weiß noch ganz genau, wie die Leute sich ins Hemd gemacht haben bei diesem Film. Also so richtig.
Ich weiß, aber wenn du das heute guckst, ist es halt so, jetzt rennt der alleine, der Katze hinterher, jada, jada, jada, gleich kommt der Alien, nanananana. Der zweite Teil, da geht's ja richtig aufs Ganze. Da wird ja so richtig aus allen Rohren gepustet. Fand ich gut. Den dritten hab ich jetzt auch gesehen. Aber da war's auch wieder so im iTunes gesungen. Ich dachte, Jungs, ich will euch Geld geben. Gebt's mir doch einfach. Und nee, geht nicht, muss ich runterladen. Und bei anderen Sachen, die ich mir aus dem iTunes runterladen wollte, ist es halt auch so, dass die manchmal einfach zehnmal länger dauern als aus dem BitTorrent. Ich versteh's einfach nicht. Also wenn ich Geld dafür bezahle, erwarte ich, dass es mit Wirespeed, mit fucking Wirespeed in meinen Rechner reinsprudelt.
Ja, aber dann darüber hinaus hier bei diesem Sherlock, da sind nicht mal Untertitel dabei.
Ja, das ist das nächste, ja.
So, das ist bei, holst du ja aus dem Torrent, und hast Untertitel in 500 Sprachen, und weißt ja teufel was.
Das versteh ich auch überhaupt nicht.
Keine Untertitel.
Ja, oder überhaupt mit diesen Spuren. Ich hab die ganze Zeit überlegt, was das Problem war. Ich wollte nämlich auch irgendwas mieten. Muss ich mal kurz überlegen, was das war. Das war... Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Das war irgendein Film.
So.
Und ich wollte natürlich wieder auf Englisch sehen. Wenn ich den auf dem Mac im iTunes Store gesucht habe, dann kam halt so, ja, gibt's Deutsch und Englisch. Auf dem Apple TV sagen sie dir da überhaupt nichts dazu. Also da steht gar nichts. Sodass ich dann es nicht gekauft habe, weil ich mir dachte, weißt du, am Ende kriegst du wieder nur Deutsch, weil, keine Ahnung, passt nicht mehr rein. Ja, das ist zu teuer oder zu schwierig.
Wahrscheinlich im Zweifelsfall auch die Mietlizenzen sind was anderes als die Kauflizenzen und dann hast du andere Rechte und hast mit einem anderen Vertrieb und der hat dann bestimmt nur die Rechte für...
Das ist wirklich so...
Du musst nicht mal kanken gehen und von daher ist es auch gerade gut, dass die Wikipedia-Seite ausgeschaltet ist.
Ich hoffe ehrlich, dass die Menschheit es noch irgendwann mal gebacken kriegt, zu verstehen, dass es eigentlich ganz einfach ist und die Leute auch wirklich dafür zahlen würden, wenn dann mal ordentlicher Service geboten werden würde.
Aber das ist auch so... Ich meine, jetzt ist die nächste... Jetzt kommt die Buchindustrie. Das ist ja nicht so, dass da irgendwie... Ah, guck mal, Musikindustrie ist gegen die Wand gelaufen. Filmindustrie ist gegen die Wand gelaufen. Nee, jetzt rennt die Buchindustrie schön hinterher. Und das von einem teuer bezahlten Manager, die so lange so... Ja, wer konnte das denn ahnen, dass E-Books kommen würden, dass die Leute E-Books haben wollen? So, als nächstes wird dann, das hat ja... Das hat ja Cory Doctorow. Habt ihr das gehört, den Vortrag von Cory Doctorow auf den Kongress? Den fand ich, war ja mein Kongressvortrag überhaupt, so der beste. Der so gesagt hat, so dieses Moment mal, also ihr glaubt, wir glaubten vielleicht alle, also er hat sich explizit selber mit einbezogen, so dieses, dass die Contentindustrie der Endgegner ist. Danach kommt nichts mehr. Ich meine, und er hat, ähm, dann kam er drauf sozusagen, ne, Moment mal, in Zukunft, da wird alles, da wird man Medikamente übers Internet einfach replizieren können, wenn man die richtige Rezeptur hat. Da wird man, da wird man sich Ikea-Möbel ausdrucken können über seinen Teradet-Drucker. Da wird, da kommt noch, das hat noch nicht mal angefangen. Wie konnte, diese scheiß Contentindustrie mit ihren zwei Milliarden Umsatz im Jahr, glaube ich, in Deutschland, die werden auch von der Politik nicht ernst genommen. Die kriegen da so ein paar Gesetze, okay, hier, gebt Ruhe, wenn da erstmal wirklich eine Industrie kommt, die so richtig Asche macht und so richtig Lobbying-Einfluss hat, dann wird es erst problematisch mit dem Netz. Und mit dem freien Zugriff auf das Netz und auf Computer und etc. Und das finde ich ist ein sehr beängstigender Gedanke.
Aber wir alten Selectivisten werden denen mal zeigen, wo der Frosch die Locken hat.
Indem wir uns zur Seite schwarz machen.
Was?
Kann man ja so lange über N-Roll drum raten, wie er weg ist, oder?
Kalender.
Ey, hast du auch so Probleme? Findest du iCarly auch so geil? Ach so, Wunder-Kit. Ja, kann ich ja kurz sagen, ich hab da über Twitter rausgehauen, ich glaub das war totaler Bullshit. Ich hab ja über Twitter geschrieben, dass so... Also ich hatte... Na gut, also Wunder-Kit ist hier von sechs Wunder-Kinder, also eines der über halb den Berliner Start-ups, das über halbteste Berliner Start-up. Und... Das hat ja... Ja. Und die haben Wunderliste rausgebracht, was eine kostenlose To-Do-Liste war, womit sie schon mal die Welt, eine hübsche kostenlose To-Do-Liste, womit sie schon mal auf Techcrunch und ähnliche Konsorten geschafft haben, die einen ziemlich Einschlag gehabt haben, was jetzt erstmal beeindruckend ist für eine App, die wirklich nicht viel mehr macht als eine To-Do-Liste, die man sich allerdings mit anderen Leuten teilen kann. Das ist schon mal ganz cool. Und die haben jetzt die Beta-Version ihres Wunder-Kits, also sozusagen die To-Do-Liste war nur ein kleiner Teil des Ganzen. Das ist so ein Facebook für Projekt-Management, sag ich mal. Wie würdest du es beschreiben?
Ich hab mir nur die Seite angeguckt und hab dann davon abgesehen, diesen Invite-Link zu vergleichen. Das hat auch so meine Timeline vollgesplendert. Ich bin ja immer so ein Hype-Aussitzer. Wenn zu viel gleichzeitig irgendwie Hype, dann...
Ist wahrscheinlich nicht verkehrt, das stimmt schon.
Dann warte ich immer erst und warte, aber deswegen kann ich dann auch nicht mitreden. Also ich bin ganz oah was, das...
Also es sieht, ich finde, das ist relativ langsam. Sieht aber hübsch aus. Man kann auch, man kann Na To Do-Listen anlegen, man kann irgendwelche Termine eintragen, man kann alle seine Freunde einladen, man kann das auch irgendwie...
Ja, eingeladen wurde ich auch schon ganz viel.
Ja, also auch sozusagen, die da schon Mitglieder sind. Man kann Leute können, also wir können jetzt zum Beispiel eine Mobile-Max-Liste anlegen, können da irgendwie irgendwelche Planungen machen von irgendwelchem Zeug. Und ich glaube, dass da wirklich so ein gewisser Bedarf für da ist. Und zwar ist es mir daran aufgefallen, ein Freund von mir muss jetzt für einen gemeinsamen Freund den Junggesellen-Abschied organisieren. Und womit macht man das am besten? Also womit organisiert man so ein... Echsel. Dann kommt man natürlich auf Facebook. Also willst du ja nicht irgendwie eine Echsel-Latei per Mail durch die Welt schicken. Sondern musst ja erstmal Leute zusammentragen, so, hey, wer kommt denn überhaupt in Frage, holt ihn doch mal hier. Und dann legt man so eine Gruppe an und dann trägt man da irgendwas ein und chatten da die Leute rum und sowas. Und das geht halt über... Also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, so ein Google-Doc, da muss man sein Adresscode durchgehen. Ja, hat doch keiner, verstehst du? Da willst du jeden drin haben. Also eigentlich ist mir aufgefallen, so in unserer Altersgruppe, also ich bin jetzt hier mit 33 so, da sind schon eigentlich nicht mal genug Leute bei Facebook. Und bei Facebook muss man auch sagen, die, die jetzt noch nicht bei Facebook dabei sind, die sind es auch aus Überzeugung. Also wenn du denen sagst, hey, leg dir mal einen Facebook-Account zu, damit du hier an diesem Junggesellen-Abschiedsplanung teilnehmen machen, dann zahlen die dir einen Vogel. Sagen sie, Facebook ist doch böse. Feiert doch ohne mich. Oder eben unter falschen Namen. Und für so was könnte so dieses Wunder-Kit theoretisch was sein. Also man kann die Leute per Twitter einladen, man kann die Leute per Facebook einladen, man hat diese gewisse Vernetzung, die ist schon da, man holt die rein. Dieser Hesel scheint mir relativ klein zu sein. Ja, und dann kann man da vielleicht irgendwas organisieren, vielleicht ist es aber auch in einem halben Jahr wieder vergessen. Wird sich zeigen. Auf jeden Fall habe ich dann eine Invite-Link an jemanden, meine Freundin auch geschickt, so hey, hier, guck mal, lass mal, und das lief dann per Twitter.
Lass mal was planen.
Lass mal einen Urlaub planen. So und hab ihr dann so eine Invite-Link per Twitter zugeschickt, der dann als Public Message rausgeht, also als Ad-Reply zwar, aber halt Public.
Und wie hast du den generiert?
Da ist, in der App sagst du Invite People und dann steht da immer deine ganze Twitter-Liste und deine Facebook-Freunde und die stehen dann alle da und dann sagst du hier...
Du hast ja deine Twitter-Credentials da reingeschmissen.
Genau, ich hab mich da mit Twitter eingeloggt. Also Twitter-O-Aus-Things-Bums hier. genau, und ein paar Minuten später kriegte ich dann so eine Mail, so sowieso hat deine Einladung, irgendjemand, den ich gar nicht kannte, ist deine Einladung gefolgt und ist jetzt in der Gruppe Urlaubsplanung drin. Und dann dachte ich zuerst, ok, da hat irgendjemand wahrscheinlich einfach bei...
Ach, du hast ihn auch explizit zu einem... Wie heißt das nochmal bei dem Wunderkit? Dieses Item, diese Gruppe?
Projekt, sag ich jetzt einfach mal. Also ich hab da explizit die Einladung geschickt, genau. ja, und dann hab ich quasi diese Antwort gekriegt. Sowieso hat deine Einladung zu diesem Projekt entgenommen. Und ich bin dann davon ausgegangen, dass einfach jemand anders auf diesen Link geklickt hat, sich dann quasi angemeldet hat, obwohl er einen anderen Twitter-Account hat, weil die das offensichtlich nicht überprüfen. ja, und dann automatisch in diesem Private-Projekt drinne ist, was ich nicht mit der Öffentlichkeit teilen wollte, was mir natürlich erstmal so einen ganz ordentlichen Schock verpasst hat. Dann hat sich aber der CTO von den sechs Wunderkindern bei mir gemeldet und hat gesagt, hey, das ist überall der gleiche in Whitelink, das ist überhaupt nichts Spezielles und offensichtlich sind einfach die Mails an falsche Leute bzw. sind irgendwie falsch rausgegangen. Es war auch niemand, also ich konnte auch keine Spuren von dieser Person finden, die da angeblich dieser Gruppe zugeordnet war, die war dann auch nicht Mitglied in der Gruppe, also steht zu vermuten, dass die einfach die falschen Mails rausgeschickt haben. Hat mir auf jeden Fall einen ganz ordentlichen Schreck eingejagt und ich meine, die haben auch nie was anderes behauptet, als dass es tiefe Beta wäre. Insofern kann man ihnen darauf sicherlich keinen Vorwurf machen.
Aber...
Sag Bescheid, wenn du das erste Mal was erfolgreich damit geplant hast. Das wird mindestens so erfolgreich wie bei dir.
Also da bin ich mir schon mal sicher.
Okay, das ist erstmal eine gediegene Messlatte, sagen wir mal.
Also ich finde, ich habe jetzt noch nicht sehr viel Zeit damit verbracht. Ich habe da so etwas widerwillig drauf rumgeklickt. War dann erstmal so ein bisschen angepisst, weil ich irgendwie den Invite per Twitter bekommen habe. Und ich klick so auf diesen Link. Und das erste ist hier gib Zugriff auf dein Twitter-Konto. Hab da erstmal ein bisschen zurückgestenkert auf Twitter. Was denn hier so? Hallo? Weil ich wusste auch in dem Moment überhaupt nicht, was. Genau. Klar, Wunderkinder habe ich schon mal gehört, dass es diese komische Abdeckung, die irgendwie so ein Webkit-View da aufmacht und irgendwie so keine richtige Abseilen will.
Titanium nehmen die.
Da war ich so ein bisschen...
Accelerator Titanium, das ist schon eine native App. Kennst du das noch? Da kannst du in JavaScript native Apps entwickeln. Also die werden nachher...
They're native to me.
Ja, ja, das ist aber... Also es ist langsam, aber es ist weitgehend native.
Ich weiß, ich hab's jetzt schon lange nicht mehr angefasst. Das hat mich auf jeden Fall dazu gebracht, mich nicht weiter mit der Software zu...
Achso, da meint sich Desktop Software, die Mac Software von denen. Egal.
Es hat ihn abgeturnt.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr ganz genau, was ich meine. Es ist schon so lange her. Auf meiner Suche nach der To-Do-App von morgen...
Also die iPhone-Version ist gar nicht so schlecht. Die Desktop-App ist halt... Ich glaube, über die hast du dich mal ziemlich aufgeregt, weil die auch keinen Apple-W hatte und so und das alles irgendwie nicht richtig funktioniert hat.
Und... Wer hatte mich? Glock dich ein.
Also, ihr chatten gerade eine Mobile-Lessonativ. Nein, ich hab mal... Also, vielleicht haben sie es mittlerweile komplett neu geschrieben. Ich hab mal von ihnen einen Vortrag gehört auf der JSBerlinia, so einer Kleinen. Und da haben sie erzählt, wie sie mit AppCelerator, und das ist in JavaScript, probieren, Apps zu entwickeln. Und das ist was anderes als PhoneGap. Das kann viel, viel mehr als PhoneGap. Also, da kann man nach vielen Elementen mit anlegen.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr ganz genau. Da mögen jetzt Updates gekommen sein, die ich mir nicht näher angeschaut habe. Irgendwie, so wie es jetzt hochkam, erinnert mich das nicht an das Ding. Und auf dem Mac gibt es auch eine App?
Jaja.
Echt? Aber die hab ich doch gar nicht. Hab ich die?
Die hattest du mal. Ich weiß noch, wie du dich darüber aufgeregt hast.
Du bist dir sicher, dass das die Mac-App war? Und ist die auch jetzt im App Store?
Ja, auf jeden Fall hab ich Ihnen mit meinem Tweet da unrechtgetragen.
Meanwhile at the Ranch.
Ich wollte noch mal kurz was zum Wunder-Kit sagen. Du hast ja einiges schon gesagt, mit diesem Facebook-Of-To-Do-Apps und so. Weil natürlich macht das total Sinn. Du hast ja auch gleich intuitiv als erstes so eine Liste angelegt. Wie heißt das überhaupt? Wie nennen die das? Sie nennen das ein Workspace. Und du hast auch gleich intuitiv, oder war das MS-Pro, so ein Workspace für wir müssen reden angelegt.
Die haben beide unabhängig voneinander angelegt.
Aber du hast auch gleich so dieses Gefühl, weil diese Idee, dass man nämlich sowohl so interne hat, in dem Fall dann halt Member, als auch Leute, die unmittelbar an dem Ergebnis, was auch immer da drin entwickelt wird, ein Interesse haben und dem Fortschritt dann folgen und du quasi direkt aus deinem eigentlichen Planungskontext nach außen gehen kannst und sagen kannst so, hier und das sind jetzt die für euch relevanten Informationen, die mittlerweile entstanden sind. Das finde ich schon mal einen sehr interessanten Ansatz. Also ich denke, dass so dieses kollaborative Arbeiten an sich schreit eigentlich nach so etwas. Oder anders ausgedrückt, ich finde, die sind da an einem sehr interessanten Feld dran, unabhängig davon, ob es ihnen jetzt irgendwie gelungen ist, dieses Problem zu knacken oder nicht, aber sich darauf zu konzentrieren, finde ich auf jeden Fall einen lohnenswerten Ansatz. ich bin jetzt sehr gespannt. Bloß das Problem, was ich auch unmittelbar damit hatte, ist natürlich wieder dieses ok, jetzt habe ich hier so eine schöne Web 2.0, 3.0 Anwendung. Werde ich dann auch eine abhaben?
Auf dem iPhone? Auf dem Mac weiß ich nicht, auf dem iPhone auf jeden Fall.
Ja, aber das war nicht meine Frage.
Ich will keine Ahnung. Ich vermute mal im Augenblick nicht. Also ich weiß, also ich habe auch dann nochmal hier den bisschen...
Ja, weil das ist halt wieder so Appig hier im Web, dass es irgendwie unklar ist, ob man das dann auch nochmal nativ kriegen wird. Wahrscheinlich werden sie sich das sparen.
Ich mach mal hier Themen für ein MM79 sammeln als dann, ja. Obwohl wir es nicht gemacht haben. Hätten wir vielleicht noch machen sollen.
Hier steht Max Winde, Completed Themen für MM79 sammeln. Du hast das gemacht sozusagen.
Manche Tutu-Items erledigen sich ja von alleine.
Mich nervt, dass er mir die ganze Zeit irgendwie Connect with Facebook und Connect with Twitter irgendwie mir vor die Nase schmeißt.
Ja, es macht Sinn. Das macht auch Sinn, dass man sich nicht in jeder App aufs Neue oder in jedem Dienst...
Ja, aber ich will mich nicht jedes Mal, wenn ich diesen People-Dialog hochkriege, ihm sagen, dass ich meine Meinung immer noch nicht geändert habe.
Ja, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen... keine Ahnung.
Aufdringlich. Ja, aber es ist halt wieder so ein Event. Es ist wieder dieses Facebook-Problem. Dieses Facebook... Ich krieg das nicht mit. Weil das irgendwie sich nicht hier irgendwie qualifiziert abbildet. Sondern es will mich da immer in diese reiche Web-Welt da mit 1000 Notifizierungen. Und dann hab ich da oben so einen Pulldown. Und ja, und hier eine Freundschaftsanfrage. Und dann hast du da diesen Pulldown. Und dann steht dann so halb abgekürzt so Ja, hallo, du hast mich kennengelernt auf dem irgendwie Punkt-Punkt-Punkt und so. Und mir passt dann da irgendwie nicht rein. Und dann klickst du dann drauf. Und dann kriegst du irgendwie deine Seite mit deinen ganzen Inwites. Da steht dann aber von diesem Kommentar überhaupt nichts mehr. Und so. Und dann weißt du was?
Dann hast du deine Timeline, dann hast du noch deine Apprequests und dann hast du noch Chatwindows.
Ich versteh's nicht. Ich verstehe Facebook einfach immer noch nicht. Also ich korrektiere nicht. Ich versteh's wirklich nicht. Und das hat für mich hier auch schon wieder so fast so diesen Punkt, wo ich mir nicht so sicher bin, ob man sich das so ewig merken kann. Trotzdem, ich finde den Ansatz sehr interessant. Wir werden das eine Weile verfolgen und mal gucken. Vielleicht fällt einem ja irgendwas ein. Aber hier reden schon wieder so viele Leute mit mir. Test, Test, oh, ein Eichhorn. Warum muss ich so was lesen, wenn ich irgendwie... Ja, also hier ist schon wieder so eine Public- Quatsch-Timeline, wo die Leute genau den gleichen Scheiß abwerfen, wie äh... Wieso ist denn das hier überhaupt? Wieso taucht denn das auf?
Ein Florian Pilz, Mobile-Max-Hörer, hat gerade geschrieben, dass er...
Hab ich den gefolgt? Nee, ich frag den gar nicht.
Wie, wie, wie, wie kommt denn der überhaupt in meinen Browser-Fenster?
Ja, aber echt? Also zeitweise quatscht er irgendwie in meinem Wunder-Kit vor sich hin und äh... krieg ich den anderen werde ich gefragt, ob ich dem folgen möchte. Wozu soll ich ihm folgen, wenn er mich jetzt schon total vollquatscht? Wie kommt der denn da rein?
Vielleicht ist er in diesem... Das Workspace in dem Public hat er da einfach Kommentare hinterlassen? Das geht irgendwie. Bei mir hat auch jemand Kommentare hinterlassen.
In meinem Workspace kann Leute Kommentare hinterlassen?
In meinem Workspace können Leute komment... auf meinem ja.
Die nicht Member sind?
Wie die nicht Member sind. Des Workspaces.
Ja.
Und die sind dann Follower wahrscheinlich einfach.
Ja, aber wie können denn meine Follower mir Kommentare in meinem eigenen Workspace ablassen?
Na, weil der Public ist, die können da Kommentare ablassen. Also diese, was ist Public, was ist nicht Public, finde ich tatsächlich auch ziemlich ziemlich merkwürdig.
Ja, aber Public, klar ist der Public, aber sie sollen ihm folgen. Folgen heißt Maul halten.
Folgen heißt Maul halten. Und jetzt das Hörer-Meter-Drop. Nein, Chat. Wir sind sehr dankbar, dass wir den Chat haben. Und dass ihr uns folgt und uns unterstützt.
Ich werd alt. Ich kenn Monkey Island nicht und ich versteh Facebook nicht.
Ja, aber wenn du Monkey Island kennst, sprichst du eher für deine Jugend.
Ich war noch nicht mal jung. Ich hatte keine Jugend und jetzt werde ich auch noch alt.
Dramatische Szenen spielen sich ab, aber du kannst...
Ich weine ein bisschen in meinem Café.
Aber du kannst mit Monkey Island zumindest deine Jugend nochmal nachholen.
Oder teile davon. Ein Jungborn... Jungborn... Jungborn... Jungspund... Born to be wild... Jungborn... Ja doch, da gibt es auch was mit Born.
Irgendwas mit Born.
Auch ein schöner Titel, ja super.
Vielleicht hab ich auch nur gerade eine Heavy-Bird-Tation.
Jetzt gibt es hier das Assoziationsketten-Segenmassage.
Weil jetzt eigentlich wieder Koffee in seinem Kaffee oder ist das jetzt immer noch?
Jaja, nee, nee, das ist jetzt auch so richtig... Och, da war was mit Born. Oh man, hier die Jungs von 5x5 hier, die auch diesen Tischpodcast machen, die haben tatsächlich so ein Irrgebot. Der heißt...
Stimmt, über den haben sie es bei Build&Analyze erzählt? Kann das sein? Den hab ich auf jeden Fall gehört.
Das kann sein, dass sie davon erzählt haben. Mir wurde von einem Hörer davon berichtet, ohne dass ich schon viel Zeit damit verbracht hätte, mir darüber Gedanken zu machen. Jetzt suche ich mal kurz diesen Hinweis. Da ist der Hinweis und zwar heißt das Ding... Genau, der Showbot und das ist halt so ein Bot im URG und ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist ja einer von euch Live-Hörern, der ist auf GitHub und vielleicht kann den ja mal irgendjemand mal an stark bringen, weil das kriege ich nicht hin. Auf Heroku. Einfach mal zum Laufen kriegen, dass der vielleicht hier bei Mobimex auch mitläuft. Der macht zwar jetzt was, was ich bisher jetzt gar nicht so wichtig fand, nämlich Vorschläge einsammeln für Titel. Ich mein, das kann man ja mal machen, man muss den Titel ja nicht nehmen, aber man kann ja mal gucken, was so käme. Vielleicht kommt ja auch was Gutes. Würde mich noch nicht mal wundern. Ja, natürlich. Also ich hab auch schon ein paar mal gefragt und da kam nicht unbedingt immer was Gutes.
Es gibt verschiedene View-Modes.
Ne, Hacker View-Mode ist einfach eine Tabelle mit Texte. Porn, Porn-Oz. Ja, lass uns noch ein bisschen über Android rummeckern und dann kann man auch Schluss machen, oder?
Was ist denn jetzt hier mit der Kalender eigentlich? Wir wollten noch mehr über Kalender reden.
Nein.
Stimmt, der Kalender in Wunderkit war gut, das war ja nicht das, was ich sagen wollte.
Das ist der Ritterschlag. Jetzt können sie eigentlich. Jetzt sind sie schon mehr wert als Facebook, wenn Tim sagt, dass der Kalender nicht schlecht ist.
Hat er denn dein Endlosscrolling?
Ja, das hat er. Als Tim schrieb, dass der Kalender ja nicht schlecht sei, habe ich mich auf die Suche nach dem Kalender gemacht, der jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig leicht zu finden war, aber dann ist mir aufgefallen, ja, er hat Endlosscrolling.
Ja, wie einfach ist das?
Wahrscheinlich nicht so komplett.
Und wann kriegen wir jetzt unsere Lizenz-Tantiemen?
Ich bin ja froh, wenn alle das richtig machen.
Dann nehmen wir Tims Tantiemen mit.
So, und jetzt wo wir dieses wunderbare Wunder-Kit in allen Einzelheiten auseinandergenommen haben, schwenken wir auch gleich zum nächsten spannenden Thema, das da lautet.
Living in a post-Android-World.
Also ich hatte ja noch nie ein Android, deswegen...
Du wolltest noch mal über deinen Rucksack was erzählen.
Ist das noch eine Utopie für mich überhaupt, dieses Android?
Ich bin ja schon post.
Geht doch mal über deinen Rucksack.
Rucksack?
Mein Rucksack? Ja, ich hab letztes Mal schon erzählt, dass ich den hab, aber nicht was für einen. Das ist so ein Rucksack, also damit kann man, damit kann man mal ins Gelände, sag ich mal.
Es sieht aus, als ob man damit auf Schnee schaufeln könnte.
Ja, das kann man auch. Was ist das hier unten? Also, damit die Zuhörer auch ein Bild vor Augen haben, es handelt sich dabei um einen Bobblebee geschrieben. B-O-B-L-B-E-E. Und es ist dabei, es handelt sich genauer gesagt, um den Aeromegalopolis. Megalopolis Aero. Ja, du darfst es mal anfühlen. Und diese Firma macht diesen Rucksack schon sehr lange. Mittlerweile machen sie auch ein paar andere Rucksäcke für die gehobene Kundschaft. Gibt es das auch in Brushed Aluminium für 1000 Euro. Die Kunststoffvariante ist ein bisschen günstiger und zeichnet sich vor allen Dingen dadurch aus, dass sie eine Hardschale besitzt und als Rückenprotektor zertifiziert ist. Also der Rucksack ist als Rückenprotektor zertifiziert für Skifahren, Motorradfahren, was nicht noch alles. Und jedes Teil an diesem Rucksack ist einzeln auch nachkaufbar und auch selber austauschbar. Also mit so einem zünftigen Werkzeugkoffer kann man auch wirklich tatsächlich jedes einzelne Teil auswechseln. 250 so an dem Dreh. Und das Ding ist halt tatsächlich, also ich hatte noch nie einen Rucksack, der sich so rock solid angefühlt hat. Also ich war jetzt ein paar Mal im Supermarkt einkaufen und hab einfach alles reingeladen, also so irgendwie fünf Glasflaschen und irgendwie schwerer Scheiß. Und wobei anderen Rucksacken ich schon so dachte, na, ob ich das den Schultergurten zumuten kann, dieses Gewicht, war es bei dem so, ob ich mir das Gewicht überhaupt zumuten kann. Das ist die Frage der Rucksack, hält das garantiert auch so vom Gefühl her.
Und kriegt man hier noch irgendwie dazu, dass er hier so quasi...
Aber dass man da überhaupt so viel reinkriegt, dass er überhaupt schwer wird, dass er so richtig groß scheint, wie er immer zu sein.
Das ist schon riesig, wenn man die aufmacht.
Das täuscht ein bisschen. Also in der Tat durch diese Kuh da unten, denkt man, passt nicht viel rein. Aber wenn man den halt so wirklich dann ausgeklappt hat, also es passt. Also ich hab viel damit ein Zeug transportiert schon.
Er sieht schon echt...
Also ist täuschendrücklich. Du kannst da diverse Saftflaschen...
Weil er sich dann auch so ein bisschen ausfaltet, der dann noch mal so eine extra falte, dass er so rausgeht.
Wenn du halt nur ein Notebook bei hast, kannst du ihn halt auch so klein falten. Es gibt übrigens auch eine kleinere Version mittlerweile davon für die MacBook Air, Freunde unter uns.
Und das ist wasserdicht wirklich?
Naja, also das hier an sich soll schon wasserdicht sein und das ist jetzt halt für Motorradfahrer, wo es dann halt wirklich in Zweifel richtig rauf plaudert, haben sie dann sozusagen noch einen oben drauf gesetzt.
Also oben ist so ein, wie soll man sagen, einfach nur so ein...
Kunststoff-Deckel.
Kunststoff-Schnuffi und da drüber nochmal so eine...
Und der Aero ist halt der, der eben so für auch das Sportliche unterwegs gedacht ist und der hat halt statt so einem Riemen hier zum Verschluss halt so eine schöne... Schnappe. Schnapper-Schnalle, die man dann eben auch mit dem Handschuh an im Zweifel öffnen kann. Und ja, und diese Coole, weil da halt immer natürlich alle fragen, ja, wieso hinten da unten so eine Coole?
Das wäre jetzt meine nächste Frage gewesen, und zwar genau in dem Ton?
Die Coole ist tatsächlich, wenn man auf der Webseite ein bisschen klickt, findet man diverse Anwendungswelle. Natürlich kann man mit einem Spanngurt oder was auch immer seine Isomatte oder seinen Zelt da ran dengeln, aber man kann auch, es gibt zum Beispiel Netze, ich glaube bei Accessories kannst du die auch alle sehen, die Accessories zu dem Rucksack. Du kannst dir so eine fette Gepäckwulst noch, also für richtig längere Urlaube oder Wanderschaften rankleben. Du kannst deinen Helm da ranhängen mit so einem Netz, was es dazu gibt. Hier unten gibt's genau diese Beispiele. External Cargo. Du kannst links und rechts noch was an diese Schnallen ranhängen. Da unten ist dieses Beispiel mit dem Netz und dem Helm. Also das ist einfach nur so ein Design-Feature, weil es gibt dem Rucksack halt sehr viel Stabilität nach unten hin. Also der bricht da unten nicht einfach so durch. Und zum anderen... Und wie ist deine Farbe hier? Meine ist, glaube ich... Mattschwarz? Und da oben gibt's den in Brushed Aluminium für 1000. Und genau, in diese coole...
Coolie-Buddy?
Aber du kannst eben dann noch diversen Scheiß einfach daran bauen. Und diese coole ist da ganz nützlich für diese Gepäckwulste, die da ringsrum geht. Da kriegst du dann halt nochmal richtig zusätzlich was wegverstaut. Also, ich bin ja schon lange in der Rucksackforschung beteiligt. Und ich hab mich lange so ein bisschen geziert, diesen Bobble-Beat zu nehmen, vor allen Dingen, weil kein 17 Zoll Notebook reinpasst. Und ich hatte ja früher wie gesagt die 17 Zoll Notebooks. Und da passt nur 15 Zoll rein, von der Breite einfach her. Und deswegen ging's erst jetzt. Und ich bin froh, dass ich ihn habe. Na ja, wie gesagt, als Motorradfahrer nochmal doppelt, wenn er eben als Rückenprotektor zertifiziert ist, ist das schonmal ein cooles Feature. Man muss ihn dann natürlich, das gehört dazu gesagt, dann auch entsprechend natürlich anschneiden. Zumindest einmal hier um die Brust. Sonst, also wenn man nur die einfachen Schulterträger benutzt, dann ist der Rückenprotektor natürlich reichlich uneffektiv.
Das mach ich aber auch mit dem Rad sowieso immer.
Ist ja auch ein bisschen entspannter letztendlich.
Ja, das trägt sich dann wesentlich angenehmer. Ist das, braucht man einen Rückenprotektor oder ist das jetzt quasi nur zusätzlicher Schutz?
Das ist nicht vorgeschrieben.
Auf dem Rückenfels brauchst du einen.
Ja klar, okay, also es ist nice to have, aber es ist jetzt nicht.
Ja, die Firma Bobblebee macht wie gesagt mittlerweile auch noch ein paar andere Rucksäcke. Zum Beispiel eine kleinere Variante gibt's davon. Die ist auch ganz putzig tatsächlich.
Man muss ja hier nicht so einen external Case dran.
Weil ich so viel nicht zu transportieren hab. Also passt alles auch so rein. Und es gibt halt auch ganz geile Kamerarucksack. Also einen ganz geilen Kamerarucksack von denen. Also für die Foto-Nerds. Da oben, wenn du da auf Camera klickst, man nimmt ab. Der sieht schon sehr, sehr ordentlich auch aus. So von der ganzen Verarbeitung und den Fächern und so. Weil dann ist es sonst immer so, die Foto-Rucksäcke, siehst du, die sind immer irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, also als sei denn du kaufst ja so Pelikakes oder was ganz anderes, teures, aber der macht das schon, oh, guck mal, der kostet auch 329, seh ich gerade, das ist auch nicht gerade ein Schnäppchen, aber der sieht auch tatsächlich ziemlich gut aus.
Das stimmt.
Von der Verarbeitung und den ganzen Interieur. Guck mal, da gibt's sogar einen Double-Decker Cargo-Rohr. Was ist das denn? 130 Liter Studio, oder was hier? Also da geht's ja... Aber ist ja dann ein Softback, ob ich da dann wirklich meinen ganzen Kram so... Aber da passt auch ordentlich was rein, wie es aussieht.
Da haben wir eine ganz hübsche Laptop-Tasche zum umhängen.
Gut, jetzt...
Aber keine Laptop-
Es gibt auch noch eine andere...
Was für einen Namen, die am Start haben. Ich meine... Megalopolis Executive Protector Level 2 Darf.
Das ist die Farbe halt, also die Lackierung.
Das ist für Denis.
Eine andere ganz nette Firma, die so einen coolen Rucksack für auch 17 Zoll Notebooks macht, ist übrigens Incase, finde ich. Die machen auch ganz cooles Zeug. Falls ihr mal nochmal so auf der Suche seid. Weil ihr immer auf der Suche seid. Das ist in die Schuma nach Incase und vielleicht Backpack oder sowas. Die haben so einen ganz schicken Rucksack hier und da. Noch, glaube ich, so andere Cases. Oh, jetzt werben sie hier ganz groß mit iPhone. Daher kenne ich die auch bisher nur von denen. Ich habe auch einen Rucksack von denen oder besser sagen meine Freundin, und der war auch ziemlich cool. Der ist schlicht und schön und ist, glaube ich, dieses. Die sehen alle gar nicht schlecht aus mittlerweile. Kauft sie einfach alle. So, jetzt ist hier...
Da kann man auch so durch die Farben durchscrollen.
Menschenskinder, Schminke, Schnicker. Das Web wird langsam erwachsen.
Schau mal, da kann man hier...
Ja, ich seh, ich seh.
Wo wir gerade bei so Gadgets sind, auf der CES, die ja eine sterbenslangweilige Veranstaltung sein muss.
Wieso? Es gab doch viele MP3-Player und iPod-Höhlen.
Jaja, so war es halt. Hab ich zumindest eine Sache als sehr interessant empfunden. Da gab es zumindest einen Bericht darüber, ob die Dinger schon irgendwie verfügbar sind. Ist mir gerade noch nicht so ganz klar. Und zwar gibt es hier eine Firma namens ZIK, die sich von Philipp Stark ein Headphone haben designen lassen. Was ein Bluetooth-Kopfhörer ist, der, naja, also ich meine, gut, sieht jetzt interessant aus, ob man das jetzt mag, das weiß ich nicht. Das Coole ist, dass es ein Bluetooth-Kopfhörer ist, aber auf diese bekloppten Tasten, unter denen diese Kopfhörer meistens immer leiden, weil man die nicht findet, oder wenn man sie zu leicht findet, dann stößt man dran und so weiter. Das haben sie ersetzt durch einen Touch-Control. Zum Beispiel kannst du dann so Lautstärke dadurch regeln, dass du halt so am Rand mit dem Finger hoch und runter fährst. Also, sagen wir mal, eine recht intuitive Geschichte. Da stellt sich natürlich wieder die Frage, wie ist das mit Handschuhen und so. Das heißt, du brauchst jetzt nicht nur spezielle Handschuhe, um dein Telefon zu bedienen, sondern auch, um deinen Kopfhörer irgendwie lauter und leiser zu machen. Aber das ist ja heutzutage fast schon das Gleiche. Und so ein paar andere Sachen haben sie wohl auch über Touch gelöst. Warte mal, da gab es noch irgendeinen Spin, den ich jetzt gerade vergessen habe. Irgendwas war noch toll.
Also ich meine, für Bluetooth-Kopfhörer haben sie erstmal keinen schlechten Eindruck, aber... Sie sehen schon irgendwie klopig auch aus.
Ach so, nee, das ist hier... Also...
Tumbleweed.
Sehr viel mehr kann ich dir jetzt gar nicht zu sagen. War auf jeden Fall mal interessant. Vielleicht bringt es ja doch noch mal was, irgendwie CES zu verfolgen, aber ansonsten ist das ja eigentlich eher langweilig.
Genauso.
Aber ich finde generell die Idee gut, Touch einzubauen.
Ja genau, richtig, jetzt weiß ich es wieder.
Und zwar haben sie auch noch einen, sie haben einen Abstandssensor drin.
Das heißt, wenn du die Kopfhörer abnimmst, dann hören sie, sagen sie dem Telefonhörer, mach Pause. Ach, das ist doch mal eine schöne Idee.
Genau.
Das fand ich schon mal ganz cool. Was kostet das gute Stück?
Sieht nicht billig aus.
Und warum ist es available im App Store?
Da gibt es halt irgendwie noch eine App dazu, mit dem du das Ding irgendwie fine grained konfigurieren kannst. Und dann haben sie noch einen Bone Conduction Sensor, womit sie irgendwie noch die Lautstärke steuern, während du irgendwie telefonierst, weil sie irgendwie noch deine eigene Stimme da irgendwie noch mit rein machen. Neues Kontrollen in den ganzen Klimpen. Also wir machen auf jeden Fall, ballern sie den ganzen Kram jetzt voll mit irgendwelchen Sensoren. Hab ich mal nachher besser zusammengefasst, tut mir leid.
Na ja, also manchmal muss man halt auch mit der Keule ausholen. So wie Sigourney.
Ja, was es auf der CES nicht gab, waren endlich mal Thunderbolt of Fire war ja Adapter.
Sind welche vorgestellt worden? Ja, die im September schon bestimmt verfügbar sein sollen.
Einige davon sind auch erst seit dem April. Ja, aber ich meine, das ist so... Wie lang ist das Ding schon vorgestellt? Also das hab ich auch das letzte Mal im September letzten Jahres, oder?
Also eineinhalb Jahre Vorlaufzeit scheint sich jetzt irgendwie einzubringen. Das hat sich ja eben schon mit meiner Dante-Karte...
Ich dachte von Belkin gibt es jetzt dieses Ding?
Nee.
Aber es gab einen Preis schon dafür.
Bestimmt, für die unangekündigste Software überhaupt.
Das würde ja auf der CES gut passen. Best Announced Product.
Ich dachte, das war schon deutlich vorher sogar.
Also sie haben als Thunderbolt rausgekommen, haben sie relativ schnell Webseiten rausgeschickt mit Ja, hier machen wir auch alles und so. Wir haben uns irgendwie mal das Datenblatt durchgelesen.
Hier goes on sale.
Genau. Ja, goes on sale, aber im September gibt es das irgendwie erst in Europa.
Für 299 Dollar.
Und für 300 Dollar, das finde ich halt auch, das ist schon so, ich meine, das ist schon viel Geld für so für so kleine Thunderbolt auf Firewire Adapter oder USB.
Ethernet kostet 30 Dollar. Ist auch 10 Mal so schnell. Hast ja Gigabit Ethernet.
Was?
Mit dem Belkin. Hast du Gigabit Ethernet mit deinem USB. Hast halt nur Fast Ethernet.
Ja, aber für 1000 Euro habe ich ein Thunderbolt-Display mit 27 Zoll daneben. Und das kann man sofort haben.
Kannst aber nicht in die Tasche rein.
Das stimmt, aber dieses Belkin-Teil kriege ich auch nicht in die Tasche rein.
Cool ist, dass sie ja auch noch ein Audio-Ausgang spendiert haben.
Ja, aber ganz ehrlich, das Thunderbolt ist irgendwie...
It's not here yet. Deswegen bin ich auch ganz froh, dass mein Mac Pro irgendwie von 2009, das wurde noch keinerlei Ambition in der Hinsicht, dass es irgendwie alles noch Mini-Display World, die lebt wahrscheinlich noch on für irgendwie eine Weile. Also ich muss auch sagen, als sie das Thunderbolt vorgestellt haben, dachte ich, sie sind da weiter. Also ich weiß ja nicht genau, was das Problem ist, aber dieser September-Termin, den auch irgendjemand anders genannt hatte, mit irgendeinem Thunderbolt-Produkt, das ist halt diese Intel Developers-Konferenz, die dann noch mal stattfinden wird.
Ne, das ist wohl schon klar und zwar wird Intel dann die nächste Integrationsstufe von ihren Thunderbolt-Chips.
Achso, dann kommt dann die neue Version. Weil die erste einfach nicht taugt.
Ne, weil die erste einfach zu teuer ist.
Wahrscheinlich zu viel Strom schmeißt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du zu viel Strom hast. Ich meine, ihr kriegt es ja auch in so einen MacBook Air rein. Dann hätten sie es ja wahrscheinlich nicht drin. Aber das Problem ist wohl, dass die einfach schlicht in der Grafik zu teuer ist. Und wenn man bedenkt, dass so ein Apple Thunderbolt-Kabel schon allein 50 Dollar kostet, wo ja nun auch einiges an Elektronik drinsteht und ich glaube nicht, dass die da wahnsinnig viel gewinnen. Dass die Gewinnmafen so hoch sind wie bei einem iPhone.
Ein Kabel kostet 50 Euro. Das ist 3 Meter oder 1,50 Meter oder so.
Das machen die da eigentlich da drin? Machen die das irgendwie auf... Also da steckt ja... Das ist glaube ich auch das erste Kabel, das von iFixit aufgemacht worden ist.
Ja, die haben da halt an beiden Enden nochmal so ordentlich Elektronik drin.
Da steckt wahrscheinlich mehr Hardware drin, als ein iMac 3G vor ein paar Jahren hatte.
Wahrscheinlich tun sie das einfach.
Vorher noch ein geweihtes Wasser.
Die Erdwellen irgendwie, also es ist einfach auch eine esoterische Schirmung wahrscheinlich.
Und das macht kostenlose Hoden krebs.
Also ich weiß auch nicht, ich habe ja da eine Menge von gehalten von dieser Thunderbolt-Idee, aber das ist definitiv eine Technologie, die erst später wirklich loszicken wird. Ich habe allerdings Anwenderberichte gehört von Leuten, die mit diesem Pegasus-Thunderbolt-Raid, diesem Pier- oder Sex-Slot-External-Disc-Enclosure gearbeitet haben und da war eigentlich die Aussage nur, dass das A gut läuft und B, dass die Performance einfach awesome ist. Also das ist wirklich so richtig dermaßen rockt und so schnell liefert. Liefert.
War snappy, also es ging ordentlich der Braten durch.
Aber du kannst das halt wieder nicht als JBOD benutzen. Du kannst nicht sagen, hier liefer mal jede Platte als einzelnes Device an, damit man da mal ordentlich ZFS draufmacht.
Aber ich muss ja sagen, mit dem Thunderbolt Display bin ich ja nach wie vor auch, also ich nutze da nicht viel von. Also ich nutze halt, das denk ich, du benutzt Gigabit Ethernet. Ich benutze Gigabit Ethernet, ich benutze halt das USB und ich benutze halt das Display. Und das Ding steckst du an und dann hast du alles. Das ist echt, das ist schon, also ich meine, das ist ein Kabel zu viel, also naja, okay, man muss auch noch Strom ranstecken, das ist dann natürlich ein bisschen nervig, warum das nicht gleich mit rüber geht, aber wahrscheinlich haben sie das einfach nicht rüber gekriegt. Ja, also das ist schon schick.
Aber diese Irrglaube, dass jetzt Displays immer in diese scheiß Glasspiegelfläche kommen, müssen, das finde ich, ich finde das zu kotzen, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich mag das Display mittlerweile sehr gerne. Ich kann auch verstehen, warum du hier so ein 27 Zoll iMac haben willst, so richtig groß und so. Das ist schon schicker als so einen kleinen Scheiß.
Ja, ich...
Ja, großer Bildschirm, da geht echt nichts dran vorbei.
Aber irgendwie, ich hätte es gerne ohne Glas.
Leute, ihr merkt schon, diese Sendung kommt dem Ende entgegen.
Wir kommen dem Ende entgegen. Die Sendung geht nur weiter.
Bevor...
Bevor wir die 400-Hörer-Marke unterschreiten, sollten wir vielleicht langsam...
Das finden jetzt die Rheinländer bestimmt scheiße, wenn ich jetzt wieder so einen Rheinland-Dialekt...
Wer findet das scheiße?
Na bestimmt, ist doch immer so. Wenn andere, die da nicht herkommen, so einen Dialekt imitieren, dann finden das die, die da herkommen, wo man den Dialekt imitiert von, das finden die dann doof.
Ja, geht weg.
Nein, bleibt hier. Klickt auf unseren Flitter-Button. Lasst euch nicht von Tim irritieren. Nee, aber du hast recht, wir können auch gerne heute mal einfach die Kresse halten.
Ja genau, ich meine, es ist ja auch jetzt nicht wirklich viel passiert und ich fand es jetzt mal sehr schön, dass wir uns auch mal so ein bisschen wiedergesehen haben, mit einfachen Dingen beschäftigt haben, die das Leben bemüht.
Der fordert noch eine Kalender, aber das gibt es jetzt nur für die Premium-Kunden.
Der Witz ist ja auch von 2011, wir denken uns jetzt neue Memes aus, hier in der kleinen Mobile-Max-Welt. Die paar Minuten bis zur Vier-Stunden-Marke könnt ihr jetzt noch voll machen.
Na gut, da hat er den Punkt. Wie viel sind's denn noch?
Kann ich nicht so recht beantworten.
Ist das Display wieder aus? Hast du die Grafikkarte wieder rausgenommen?
Witzbold. Weil ich jetzt hier nicht so ohne Watt respektiere, bei wie vielen Minuten die Sendung wirklich begonnen hat. Vermutlich hier irgendwo. Ja, wir müssen jetzt wohl noch eine Viertelstunde senden, nehme ich an.
Eine Viertelstunde?
Ja, das ist Quatsch. Das war's. Mobile Max.
War mir wie immer eine Freude.
Freude. Wir werden uns hier auch weiterhin bemühen. Und ich werde auch mit Sicherheit mein Mischpult in den Griff kriegen. Aber auch andere Fortschritte.
Seien Sie auch nächstes Mal wieder live dabei, wenn Tim das Mischpult in den Griff kriegt oder andersrum.
Vielleicht haben wir im nächsten Jahr auch mehr Bot. Früher war mehr Chat.
Heute sind wir auch nur in 3 Viertel Takt.
Genau.
Das kommen wir auch noch hinzu. Also wir brauchen für die letzte Stunde noch Dennis Power. Der wädert erstmal den Mittelteil durch und wenn uns der Kraft verlässt, dann kann Dennis nochmal mit ZFS oder Bitcoins nochmal richtig den Laden hier aufmischen.
Der macht dann einfach nochmal richtig Wind. Aber heute nicht.
Wind und Daneser.
Ansonsten wünschen wir euch noch einen frohen Aufenthalt im Internet.
Genau.
Das ist ja auch immer wieder was Schönes.
Man kann ja auch nicht genug kriegen.
Genau, gerade an so einem Tag wie heute, wo so total Blackout ist.
Wir könnten ja noch ein paar Suppen vielleicht empfehlen. Die sind glaube ich nicht geblackoutet.
Nee, wir machen lieber noch ein paar Hinweise darüber, wie ihr eure Präsentation abzuhalten habt. Das war's für heute.
Danke, dass ihr da wart. Wir sehen uns bald.
Ich versuche, etwas auf den Computer zu klicken, um den Fakt zu zeigen, dass ich mich nicht mit mir selbst kenne.
Wir haben unsere Gespräche über einen popularen TV-Show von gestern gesehen. Nicht lachen. Erreiter Eier-Roll.
Die Paragraphen, die ich hier auf dem PowerPoint-Schraube beobachten, sind eine schreckliche Statistik, die ich gerade gelernt habe, und eine ganze Menge wege Lingo, die niemand von jetzt an erinnern wird. Defendere Pop-Kultur-Referenz durch eine soziale Netzwerksseite, die niemand nutzt.
ernsthaft und etwas überwichtiger Erinnerung, wie wichtig diese Information ist. Ich bin ein Unbekannte, verletzend, dass Menschen meinen Desktop-Bekannung sehen. Schneider Mark, wie Max dir besser als PC's sind.
Verschwende Pflege für IT-Guy!
Ich bin gespannt, dass jemand zurückkommt für eine Follower-Konversation.